OKAY WHY DON'T WE CALL THIS.
HEARING OF THE SENATE OF ON A
CALL THE COMMITTEE TO ORDER WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET SO WE
WILL START AS A SUB COMMITTEE
[INAUDIBLE]
AND WELCOME ARE HER VICE CHAIR.
AND LET'S ASK AS A MEMBER QUIRK.
TO TO COME UP AND PRESENT ITEM
EIGHT THIS IS.
THIS IS AB TWO NINETY TWO
WILLING TO RECYCLE WATER.
HI JUST ONE REMINDER FOR FOLKS --
THERE HAS BEEN A CHANGE ON THE
COMMITTEE -- BRIAN DOLLY CENTER
DOLLY IS NOW REPLACE CENTER
STONE.
AND SO.
SENATE I WILL BE HERE
[INAUDIBLE]
SO SOME RECORD YOU MAY BEGIN
WHEN READY.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
AND REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
STARTING ON TIME.
I ALSO.
WILL WELCOME SENATOR DOLLY HE
WAS A MEMBER OF THE
CORRESPONDING COMMITTEE IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND IF.
YOU'LL YOU'LL LOVE HAVING THEM
ON THE COMMITTEE -- AB TWO
NINETY TWO WILL CLARIFY THE
TERMS USED FOR RECYCLED WATER.
AB TWO NINETY TWO DOES THE
FOLLOWING TO LEAD THE TERMS.
DIRECT POSSIBLE RE USE IN
INDIRECT POSSIBLE REUSE
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE.
AND USES THE FOLLOWING TERMS RAW
WATER ON BEEN.
TREATING DRINKING WATER
AUGMENTATION.
BROWN WATER AUGMENTATION AND
RESERVOIR WATER AUGMENTATION.
GIVEN THE VARIOUS POSSIBLE TYPES
OF RECYCLED WATER PROJECTS A
COMMON SET OF TERMS WILL ASSIST
WATER AGENCIES WHEN PROMOTING
THE SAFE USE OF RECYCLED WATER.
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU THE NUMBER YES GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JENNIFER WEST
AND THE MANAGING DIRECTOR OF
WATER REDUCE CALIFORNIA -- WE
CALIFORNIA IS THE LEADER IN THE
U. IN THE NATION AND CALIFORNIA
IN THE NATION FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT.
OF A REDUCE WATER WHICH IS
PURIFIED RECYCLED WATER THAT
MEETS AND EXCEEDS ALL DRINKING
WATER STANDARDS WE THINK THIS IS
A VERY SIMPLE BILL AND IT
REMOVES THESE CONFUSING TERMS
INDIRECT AND DIRECT -- SO WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND I'VE OF
TODAY KIM.
THE FIRST ONE OUT ON SUPPORT.
THAT'S A LOSS ON BEHALF OF
INLAND EMPIRE UTILITIES AGENCY
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ROSIE THOMPSON WITH
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT IS
IN A CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MY DILLON REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SANITATION AGENCIES AND COUNTY
SANITATION DISTRICTS OF LOS
ANGELES IN SUPPORT.
LIKE US HERE ON BEHALF OF CITY
SANTA MONICA IN SUPPORT
[INAUDIBLE]
BEST CITY.
THEN YOUR BOSS AHEAD WITH
CALIFORNIA'S FOR UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
WE ALSO STATION CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT.
MONICA MILLER REPRESENT THE
SANTA CLARA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT OTHERWISE KNOWN AS ALI
WATER IN SUPPORT TO THINKING.
THANK YOU.
OKAY ANYONE ELSE ANYONE WANT TO
AND VOICE CONCERNS ARE
OPPOSITION.
NO NO COME ON PLEASE.
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY.
OKAY GOOD GOOD THAT'S PROBABLY.
WHY?
ALL RIGHT SO I I A GOOD AMOUNT
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
THOUGHTS -- THE BILL OKAY SO --
WHEN WE DO HAVE A QUORUM WE WILL --
WILL TAKE YOUR BILL UP TO PURSUE
THE PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
SO NUMBER THREE MAKE ONE OTHER
ANNOUNCEMENT BY THE WAY -- WILL
WE WILL RENOUNCE THESE THINGS
ONCE WE HAVE A QUORUM BUT WE
WILL BE TAKING A AND A ONE HOUR
LUNCH BREAK FROM TWELVE TO ONE
TODAY.
I BECAUSE OF THE SMALL BUSINESS
OF THE YEAR -- CELEBRATIONS. TO
THE MEMBERS CAN CAN SPEND TIME
WITH THEIR SMALL BUSINESS OF THE
YEAR SO WE WILL BE.
GOING ALL DAY BUT WE WILL HAVE A
ONE HOUR BREAK FROM TWELVE TO
ONE OKAY I NEXT I THINK WE HAVE
SOME MEMBER COOPER IS NEXT --
THIS ITEM TO THIS IS AB
[INAUDIBLE]
ONE TWENTY SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TEN
CALIFORNIA'S INVESTED OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE PROJECT.
ISSUING OVER THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND REBATES. ONE OF THE
GOALS OF THE CVR PIECE TO HELP
CLEAN THE AIR IN THE AREAS OF
THE STATE.
WITH THE WORST AIR QUALITY AFTER
TEN YEARS OF CV RP WE HAVE DATA
SUGGESTING THE MAJORITY OF
REBATES.
BEING ISSUED IN AREAS OF THE
STATE OR SOME OF THE BEST AIR
QUALITY.
IS NOT THE WORST.
IN ORDER TO FOCUS LIMITED
RESOURCES TO AREAS OF THE STATE
SUFFERING FROM THE WORST AIR
QUALITY.
AB ONE TWENTY SIX AIMS TO NARROW
THE PROGRAM'S ELIGIBILITY WHILE
BROADENING ITS REACH CURRENTLY
THERE BE LIMITS ELIGIBILITY FOR
HIGH INCOME EARNERS.
THE CURRENT LIMITS ARE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
SINGLE FILERS. TWO HUNDRED FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR HEAD OF
HOUSEHOLD FILERS.
AND THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
JOINT FILERS.
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
CALIFORNIA'S MEDIAN INCOME IS
ROUGHLY SEVENTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
IN CONTRAST NICHOLAS PROPOSED IN
AB ONE TWENTY SIX ARE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
SINGLE FILERS. HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR HEAD
OF HOUSEHOLD.
AND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR JOINT FILERS.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL INCREASES
REBATE LEVELS BY FAR FOR DOLLARS
FOR LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS.
OF THE FORTY SENATE DISTRICTS OF
THE HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT WITH
REBATES.
THIS TWENTY THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED NAY.
THE LOWEST SENATE DISTRICT THE
SIX UNDER.
SIXTY FIVE WHICH IS A VERY LARGE
MARGIN. ONE TO SEE YOUR P.
RECENTLY PROPOSED BY MY BILL AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY FOUR AND WORLD
MILLIE DOCTOR THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WITH A
ONE YEAR SUNSET.
AB SIXTEEN FIFTEEN FROM TWENTY
SEVENTEEN CONTINUE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF INCOME LIMITS
FOR ANOTHER TWO YEARS.
AN EXPIRED.
WHY DON'T AGREE WITH ELIMINATING
INCOME LIMITS AND BELIEVE THEY
HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL AT
FOLLOWING MORE REBATE DOLLARS TO
AREAS OF THE STATE?
WITH BETTER QUALITY I WAS THAT
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO KEEP
THE BILL MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU ARE.
DO YOU FOLKS YOUR TO DISPENSE
BIRTH.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BILL MCCALLUM
WITH KALISH FOR CLEAN AIR IN
SUPPORT.
THIS BILL IS NEEDED NOW MORE
THAN EVER THE CLEAN VEHICLE
REBATE PROJECT IS OUT OF MONEY.
AS OF EARLY THIS MONTH IT WENT
TO A WAITING LIST.
AND I'M TOLD THAT SALES OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLES HAVE ALREADY
BEEN ADVERSELY IMPACTED BY THAT.
AND THERE WILL OF COURSE BE MORE
MONEY COMING WHEN THE NEW BUDGET
GOES INTO EFFECT.
BUT THAT MONEY WILL BE USED UP
QUICKLY WILL NOT COME CLOSE. TO
LASTING A YEAR ACCORDING TO A
OUR PEACE PROJECTIONS.
AND THOSE OF OTHER OBSERVERS.
SO THIS BILL MAKES SOME OF THE
SMART AND NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS.
THAT WOULD ALLOW THE REBATE
PROJECT TO LIVE WITHIN ITS MEANS.
AND ALSO TO BE BOTH MORE
EFFECTIVE.
AND MORE EQUITABLE.
THE INCOME CAPS THAT HAVE BEEN
IN PLACE.
HAVE WORKED WELL.
THE MINIMUM ELECTRIC RANGE HAS
WORKED WELL THEY HAVE ALLOWED
THE REBATES TO LAST AS LONG AS
THEY HAVE.
AND HAVE MADE THE PROGRAM MORE
EFFECTIVE AND MORE EQUITABLE.
NOW THAT WE'VE HAD THE THE
SUCCESS WHICH IS GREAT THAT EVEY
SALES ARE WAY UP.
THAT ALSO MEANS THERE'S MORE
STRESS ON A LIMITED BUDGET SO
IT'S TIME TO MAKE THESE
ADJUSTMENTS. TO CONTINUE TO MAKE
THE PROGRAM MORE EFFECTIVE AND
MORE EQUITABLE -- SOME OF THE
AUTO COMPANIES WHO OPPOSE THIS
BILL WHAT THEY'RE ASKING FOR IT
A. R. B. IS THAT WHEN THE MONEY
RUNS OUT IN A GIVEN YEAR.
THE PROGRAM WE JUST GO DARK NO
WAITING LIST IF YOU BY ANY VÌ
AT THAT TIME APPLY FOR A REBATE.
JUST NOTHING DOING YOU'RE OUT OF
LUCK WE DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S
AN EFFECTIVE WAY TO SUSTAIN A
GROWING ELECTRIC THE ONLY
VEHICLE MARKET.
WE WOULD MUCH RATHER SEE THE
KIND OF ADJUSTMENTS THAT MISTER
COOPER HAS IN HIS BILL. TO HELP
THE PROGRAM TO LIVE WITHIN ITS
MEANS BE BOTH MORE EFFECTIVE AND
MORE EQUITABLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
OTHER FOLKS WANT TO VOICE THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
MORNING MR CHURCH ON THE CLAIM
TO HAVE THE COUNTY SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING TO KEEP A CROWDED
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
A GOOD MORNING WORKING CLEAN ON
BEHALF OF VALLEY CLEANER NOW IN
SUPPORT.
I ANYONE ELSE IN WAS RAISE
CONCERNS ARE OPPOSITION THE BILL
[INAUDIBLE]
DARCY.
GOOD MORNING SECURE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS KURT AUGUSTINE AND WITH
THE ALLIANCE OF AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS AND WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE -- THIS BILL.
THERE ARE SEVERAL REASONS FOR
DOING SO BUT I I WOULD ENCOURAGE
ANYONE WHO IS INTERESTED IN THIS
ISSUE. TO READ THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS IT WAS ACTUALLY -- WHEN
A MORE THOUGHTFUL PIECES WITH WE
HAVE SEEN ON THIS AND -- DID A
COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT THAT AND
AGAIN I WOULD ENCOURAGE ANYONE.
TO LOOK AT THAT REALLY SUMS UP
WHAT THE ISSUE IS THAT SAID.
WE DO OPPOSE THE BILL FOR SAY IN
PRINT. FOR SEVERAL REASONS. ONE
AT A TIME WHEN.
ELECTRIC VEHICLE SALES ARE
INCREASING BUT NOT NEARLY AT THE
RATE THAT WE'RE DOING -- WHAT
THOSE ENVISIONED WOULD LIKE TO
DO IN CERTAIN THE GOVERNOR'S?
EXECUTIVE ORDER -- RESTRICTING
THE MARKET PLACE LEGISLATIVELY
IS NOT THE WAY TO EXPAND THE
MARKET THAT JUST
COUNTERINTUITIVE.
WE ENCOURAGE EACH OTHER -- WE
AGREE YOU UNDERSTAND HE'S
ACCEPTED ARM ARE AS I SAID IN
PRINT.
OKAY I WASN'T SURE.
IF I DIDN'T.
I READ THE ANALYSIS I DIDN'T
READ YOUR ACCEPTANCE
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU -- SO WITH THOSE -- IS
I UNDERSTAND IT AT THE AT THE
SOMEONE HAS ACCEPTED THE OF
COMMITTEES MARK WE STILL OPPOSED
THE BILL.
IT THE AMENDMENTS RIPOFF WHEN AN
AND APPRECIATE BUT ONLY REALLY --
STILL A SLIGHT IMPROVEMENT ON
THE ROADS WE BELIEVE THAT THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD IS THE PLACE
TO CONTINUE TO MONITOR THE
PROGRAM -- THEY HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO MAKE THESE
CHANGES THEY'RE THE EXPERTS YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE HAVE HISTORIC.
A CHALLENGES FOR WORKING WITH
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD AND SO
IT'S SOMETHING WHEN THE
AUTOMAKERS THEIR RESOURCES BOARD
AGREED.
THAT THEY SHOULD BE THE ARBITER
OF THIS PROGRAM -- WE HAVE THE
CHALLENGES -- THAT HAVE BEEN
PAID OUT.
WE WE IT MAKES THE PROGRAM MORE
FLEXIBLE WHEN THEY ARE BE HAS
THAT THAT -- THE CHANGES THEY
CAN MAKE THAT TO EXTEND THE
LIMITED FUNDS OF THINGS AS ARE
ALL STATUTORY -- THAT'S A THAT'S
A CHALLENGE -- AND I THINK WE
HAVE TO ACCEPT.
THE REALITY THAT THIS IS THESE
ARE STILL VERY EXPENSIVE
AUTOMOBILES WE ARE TRYING TO WE
WILL SELL THEM TO ANYBODY THAT
BUYS THEM BUT WE HAVE TO TO
REALIZE THEY ARE MORE EXPENSIVE.
AND THAT.
IT IS AN INCENTIVE PROGRAM TO
PURCHASE AND THE AMENDMENTS
AGAIN ARE HELPFUL.
BUT WITH THE RESTRICTIONS ON
WHERE THE A. R. B. CAN -- TO
ALLOCATE THOSE FUNDS AND SET UP
THE PROGRAM WE THINK IT THEY'RE
THEY'RE TOO PRESCRIPTIVE.
AND WOULD ENCOURAGE -- THIS BILL
NOT TO BE PASSED TODAY AND LET A
OR B. CONTINUE TO RUN WHAT'S
BEEN THE MOST SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM
IN THE COUNTRY.
THANK YOU. ONE MINUTE I MEAN I
REMEMBER YOU'RE RINGING
ENDORSEMENT FOR A R. B.
REGULATION.
AND I WILL JUST CLEAR IF I WOULD
SAY THAT -- YOU KNOW THAT AND I
THINK THE COMMITTEE AGREES WITH
YOU AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE MEN'S
THAT WERE ASKED FOR THE DAY THEY
ASK FOR A OR B. TO PROVIDE
DIRECTION TO CONSIDER AND TO
DETERMINE IMPACTS AND MAKES A
DETERMINATIONS BUT THEY ARE BE
STILL -- RUNNING THE SHOW WHICH
IS WHAT IS ASKING THEM TO SOME
SPECIFIC THINGS A LITTLE GROUP
YOU KNOW RELATED TO THE ISSUES
OF EQUITY THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
BY THE AUTHOR -- BUT BUT VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS IN
YOUR JUDGMENT -- YES OTHER FOLKS
WORRIES CONCERNS GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR CASSIE GILSON ON
BEHALF OF THE GLOBAL AUTOMAKERS
WE WOULD SHARE THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY MY COLLEAGUE WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
ENGAGEMENT IN THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN TODAY.
I'M HAVE PARTICULAR CONCERNS
ABOUT THE MILEAGE LIMITATION --
AND ALSO WOULD THINK THAT THAT
APPROPRIATE VENUE FOR THESE
KINDS OF DISCUSSIONS AND WOULD
BE CARP TO ALLOW MORE
FLEXIBILITY AS TECHNOLOGY
EVOLVES AND AND THE PLATE AND
THE MARKET PLACE OF ALL IS TO BE
ABLE TO ADJUST IT ACCORDINGLY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH YES
SIR.
MORNING IS CHEN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE A BRANDING ASSEMBLY OF
ACCOUNTS ARE -- WITH THE SEVEN
TO BE AMENDMENTS WE LIKE TO
REMOVE OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
GREAT THANK YOU.
SEE WHEN FRIENDS LASSEN RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT -- OTHER FOLKS WANT TO
RAISE CONCERNS ISSUES.
WITH THE BILL OKAY THAT THE
MATTER LET ME NOW I TAKE A
MOMENT.
WAS DOLLY THERE IS OKAY LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM [INAUDIBLE]
I WENT.
I LOVE WELL HOW AYE AYES
DOWNSTREAM WHEN PEOPLE WEREN'T
HERE BUT BUT WE'RE GONNA
ANNOUNCE THEM AGAIN SO I'M TAKE
A PRESCHOOLER [INAUDIBLE]
ALLEN [INAUDIBLE]
WAIT HERE [INAUDIBLE]
DALY [INAUDIBLE]
TELL [INAUDIBLE]
SKINNER [INAUDIBLE]
STERN [INAUDIBLE]
MY CASKEY.
OKAY SO WE DO WANT TO REITERATE
WE ARE VERY PLEASED TO WELCOME
TO BOTH THE SENATE AND TO THE
SENATE MMO QUALITY COMMITTEE.
THE ESTEEMED AND DISTINGUISHED
SENATOR.
FROM BEAVER.
UP IN NORTHEASTERN CALIFORNIA AN
EXCELLENT PERSON AND SOMEONE WHO
IS A GOOD FRIEND AND AND AND AND
AND AND REALLY COMMITTED TO
FINDING PRACTICAL SOLUTIONS TO
ENVIRONMENTAL CHALLENGES AND
WE'RE JUST.
PLEASED TO WELCOME YOU CENTER
DOLLAR TO THIS COMMITTEE.
THE OTHER ISSUE WE WANTED TO
JUST REMIND FOLKS IS THAT -- WE
ARE GONNA BE PROCEEDING ALL DAY
TODAY BUT WE'RE TAKING A TWELVE
TO ONE LUNCH BREAK TODAY BECAUSE
OF THE SMALL BUSINESS OF THE
YEAR.
CELEBRATION SO THAT THE MEMBERS
WILL HAVE OPPORTUNITY. TO TO GO
HAVE LUNCH WITH THEIR SMALL
BUSINESS OF THE YEAR -- WE'VE
ALREADY HEARD THE QUIRK BILL AND
NOW WE'RE HERE -- LOOKING AB ONE
TWENTY SIX SO OTHER FOLKS WHO
WANT TO RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL ANY OTHER OPPOSITION OKAY
THE MATTERS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
FOR THOUGHTS AND QUESTIONS --
CENTER STERN AND ABOUT AND JUST
TO CLARIFY THE SUMMER HAS
ACCEPTED DEMANDS THAT ARE
OUTLINED ON PAGE EIGHTY THE
MOUTH.
SENATE STERN THANK YOU MISTER I
WOULD THINK THE AUTHOR FOR BRING
IN THIS IN THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR HARD WORK AND THAT WAS.
CREATIVELY DONE AND LANDED
SOMEWHERE SOLID.
I DID WANT TO ASK YOU I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL IN THIS ISSUE OF THIS ENERGY
TRAP THAT AFFECTS LOW INCOME AND
MIDDLE INCOME FAMILIES.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ME
PEOPLE ARE SPENDING MORE ON GAS
AND ENERGY THAT ON THEIR
HEALTHCARE AND FOOD IN SOME
CASES RIGHT SO THIS IS EATEN
INTO.
MIDDLE CLASS BUDGET AND HOW TO
BREAK THAT TRAVELING THIS IS
PART OF IT -- DO YOU GUYS HAVE A
SENSE HOW SOMEBODY'S EXISTING
PROGRAMS WORKING IN MY APOLOGIES
IF.
THEY'RE ALREADY BEEN THROUGH A
BUT YOU KNOW WE'VE DONE THIS EM
FIFTY F. M. P. WE'VE DONE THE
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL MAYBE SEVEN
SPONSORS HAVE INSIGHT ON MAYBE
YOU AS WELL LIKE.
THAT SCHOOL I LOVE THE SCRAPPING
REPLACE PROGRAM I THINK BIG
OPPORTUNITIES THERE -- TO WE
SEEN SINCE PROGRESS IN CENTRAL
VALLEY I'M ALWAYS CONCERNED THE
LA JUST.
WE'RE NOT.
INVESTED ENOUGH -- THOUGHTS ON
ALL THAT I THINK THE BIG MY
THOUGHTS ARE.
THE BIGGEST THING IS.
THERE IS WITH THE WORST AIR
QUALITY CENTRAL VALLEY AND FOR
INSTANCE MR TITLES DISTRICT. SIX
AND SIXTY FIVE REBATES COMPARED
TO THE BAY AREA TWENTY THOUSAND
NINE HERE NAY REBATES SO THE
AREAS WITH THE WORST OR QUALITY.
ARE GETTING WHAT YOU VEHICLES
MISTRUSTING STATED THEY ARE
EXPENSIVE AND WITH A MEDIAN
INCOME BEING. SEVENTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN CALIFORNIA
MEANS HALF THE POPULATION OF
CALIFORNIA MAKES LESS THAN THAT.
IT WILL NOT BE ABLE BY THESE
CARS.
AND THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG WITH
THAT YEAH AND I'VE NEVER HEARD
THE AUTOMAKERS TALK ABOUT CAR
THEY'VE ALWAYS COMPLAINED ABOUT
GUARDS TO CARBONI SO IT'S
INTERESTING THE COMING TODAY IN.
SUPPORT OF CAR FOR TALKING OUT
OF BOTH SIDES THEIR MALES BUT
I'M SURE WE CAN WORK TOGETHER ON
THESE THINGS.
I'LL TAKE I'LL TAKE TALK IS WHEN
THEY GO TO WASHINGTON I I THINK
THEY'VE BEEN PRETTY STRAIGHT FOR
THE PRESIDENT TO THE LIKE.
LET'S JUST STABILIZE SOMEHOW THE
MARKET PLACE SO.
I I LIKE THAT YOU'RE PUSHING IT
DO YOU MISTER GARY I KNOW YOU
AND I WORKED ON THIS ISSUE FOR A
FEW YEARS.
CAN WE CAN WE LINK WHAT HE'S
TALKING ABOUT THE AUTHORS TIME
OUT WITH SORT OF THE SCRAPPING
PROGRAM IS IT IS -- WAYS TO PUMP
ALL THAT UP AND GET PENETRATION
INTO THE CENTRAL VALLEY MARKETS
ARE IN LOWER INCOME AREAS OF LA
OR LONG BEACH YOUR THESE AREAS
WITH THE WORST AIR QUALITY DO WE
HAVE A SHOT AT MAKING.
MORE PROGRESS HERE YES I MEAN
THAT'S DEFINITELY THE GOAL AND
THE THE SCRAP REPLACE PROGRAM
CLEAN CARS.
WHICH YOU MISTER COOPER AND YOU
HAVE BOTH BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN
MOVING ALONG.
HAS BEEN OFF TO AN EXCELLENT
START IN BOTH THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AND SOUTH COAST AIR
DISTRICT.
IT'S NOW IN THE PROCESS OF
STARTING UP IN THE BAY AREA AND
BY NEXT YEAR THERE WILL BE A
PROGRAM HERE IN SACRAMENTO AIR
DISTRICT SO I THINK WE NEED.
MORE SUPPORT FOR THOSE PROGRAMS
I THINK IN NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO SEE.
MORE FUNDING FOR THEM.
AND AT THE SAME TIME WE NEED TO
HAVE THE THE REBATE PROJECT CVR
P. TO LIVE WITHIN ITS MEANS OR
THERE'S JUST FRANKLY NOT GOING
TO BE ENOUGH MONEY TO GET
THROUGH THE YEAR.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL REALLY
SIX TO DO [INAUDIBLE] THIRTY
DOLLARS.
SO ARE ARE USED TO WORKING WITH
AUTO -- MANUFACTURES ON THAT
MILEAGE CAP YES.
I THINK THAT'S WHY I'M PEOPLE
THOSE ARE USED TO TRAVEL LONG
DISTANCES AND IT'S IT'S DESK
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO BE ABLE.
TO MAKE THAT LOW BUT WITH THE
LAST WITH THE LIMITED AMOUNT OF
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S AVAILABLE
FOR CHARGING AS WELL
[INAUDIBLE]
RIGHT.
THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
YEAH AND THAT'S I MEAN I THAT'S
REALLY PART OF THE DISPARITIES
THAT HE'S LOOKING AT YOU KNOW
PEOPLE THE MORE URBAN AREAS TEND
TO HAVE SHORT COMMUTES.
SO EVEN IT WOULDN'T EVEN OTHER
MAYBE LONGER TIME WISE.
THIS ONE DRIVE A CAR PULLING
YEAH WELL THAT'S THE CA YEAH I
DON'T KNOW WHAT HE'S GOT TO DEAL
WITH.
WHEN IS A GOOD IDEA WITH IS THAT
THEY USE BUY A CAR USE -- YOU
TYPICALLY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
THOSE STICKERS.
AND THAT'S ACTUALLY WHAT WE'RE
GONNA GET A LOT I GET A LOT OF
THE EQUITY ISSUES THAT YOU'VE
BEEN RAISED WE DON'T DO ANYTHING
NEAR ENOUGH TO HELP.
PROMOTE THAT PART OF THE MARKET
THAT I THINK HAS A LOT OF
POTENTIAL AND AND A LOT OF
BENEFITS -- SO.
MINIMIZER I YES I I THINK TODAY
I'M NOT COULD BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
IT ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER I
THINK YOU'RE GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT
THE ISSUES RAISED BY THE AUTO
DEALERS ARE SIGNIFICANT WE PUT
THEM IN A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
POSITION THAT THEY HAVE. TO
PRODUCE NO NOT JUST THESE BUT
YOU KNOW AND THE WHOLE THE EEVEE
ON AUTO SO I I WANT.
TO OPPOSE TODAY TO KEEP THE
PRESSURE ON I DO THINK 90% OF
THAT I'M KIND OF THEIR WAY OUT.
BUT I THINK THEY'RE THEY'RE
VOICE HAS TO BE REPRESENTED SO
YOU CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE
ISSUES OF THE RACE SO.
OUT THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK.
OKAY ALL RIGHT.
HI.
WITH NO FURTHER QUESTIONS JUST
MOVE BY CENTER STERN -- CENTER
IF YOU LIKE CLOTHES SO I THINK
THE CHAIR FOR SELF AND SING DOWN
AND WORKING ON THIS BILL AND
HELPING WITH THE AMENDMENTS THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU OKAY SO WITH WITH THE
THE TO THEM THE MOTION IS TO
PASS -- WITH THE AUTHOR
ACCEPTING ME IN THE COMMITTEES A
MAN'S IT WILL NOW MOVE ON IF
IT'S PASSED OUT OF COMMITTEE
TODAY TO THE SENATE.
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
ON WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING I'M I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL.
LET'S MOVE AYE CENTER STERN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALLER.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB ONE TWENTY
SIX THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
ALLEN HI ALLEN HI BATES NO BATES
NO HILL.
SKINNER.
STERN. FIVE STERN ICE.
DOLLY.
DALI I'D LIKE OWSKI.
OKAY SO WE'LL KEEP WITHOUT ROAD.
FOR FOR FOR THE MEMBERS AND I
THINK YOU SO MUCH SO MAYOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR PARTICIPATING.
LET'S ASK US WE WERE PRISONERS
HERE TO COME UP AND PRESENT ITEM
THREE THIS AB ONE FORTY TWO
RELATING.
TO LEAD ACID BATTERIES AND YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN.
WHEN READY ASSEMBLYMEMBER?
THANK YOU TO THAT CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE AND TO THE STAFF FOR
THEIR HARD WORK AND THEIR
ANALYSIS ON THE BILL.
I WANT TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON PAGE
ELEVEN TWELVE AND THIRTEEN IN
THE ANALYSIS I DO APPRECIATE IT.
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY THREE IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN REALLOCATED IF
HE ALREADY IMPOSED ON ALL CAR
BATTERIES TO FUND THE CLEANUP
AND CONTAMINATION.
CAUSED BY LEAD ACID BATTERY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THIS WAS.
THIS BILL IS GREAT IN RESPONSE
TO THE DISASTER EXIDE BUT I WANT
TO BE CLEAR THAT THE FUNDING
CLEANS UP A LOT MORE THAN JUST
EXCITED OUT THERE WE HAVE AT
LEAST FIFTEEN SMELTERS ACROSS
THE STATE INCLUDING ONE IN MY
THAT IS ELIGIBLE.
AB ONE FOUR TWO ADDRESSES THE
TECHNICAL PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED IN THE IMPLEMENTATION
AND BUY THE CD TFA.
IT ALSO ADDS A PROCESS FOR CD
TFA TO BETTER TRACK THE
EXTENSIONS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW AT THE POINT
OF SALE ONE DOLLAR FROM
CONSUMERS THE CONSUMERS IS
DEPOSITED. TO GO TO THE CLEAN UP
FIND MANY FACTORS ALSO PAY ONE
DOLLAR.
ON ALL BATTERY SOLD IN THE STATE
STARTING APRIL TWENTY SECOND THE
CONSUMER FEE INCREASES TO TWO
DOLLARS.
AND THE MANUFACTURE OF THE SUN
SETS.
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT THIS --
FIND CONTINUES TO BE EQUITABLE
AND THE CONSUMER FEE AND THE
MANUFACTURE FEE ARE EQUAL TO
EACH OTHER AND CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE [INAUDIBLE]
THE FIRST.
GOOD MORNING SENATORS FROM THIS
I'M JANE WILLIAMS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES
AGAINST TOXICS I ALSO CHAIR THAT
TECHNICAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
FOR THE X. I. CLEANUP -- WHAT
THE AUTHOR STATED WAS THAT WE
ACTUALLY HAVE FIFTEEN GO
SMELTERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
I'M A NUMBER OF THEM WERE IN LOS
ANGELES A NUMBER IN SAN
FRANCISCO?
AND WE THINK THAT THERE IS ONE
HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
I'M ALL OF THE SITES NEED TO BE
CLEANED UP AND ASSESSED.
ON THIS BILL WOULD CREATE A LONG
TERM STABLE SOURCE OF FUNDING TO
DO THAT IT IS SOMETHING THAT NO
OTHER STATE IN THE COUNTRY IS
DOING RIGHT NOW.
AND WE ARE DRY VOTE THANK YOU.
BILL ELLIOTT FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP IS THISCOMMITTEE
KNOWS IN THE LEAD SEARCHES VERY
AWARE NOW LET IS A TERRIBLE
THING TO HAVE IS THE CHILD FOR
SURE AND REALLY BAD AS AN ADULT --
YOU GET TO CHRONIC AND AND
SOMETIMES FATAL -- SYMPTOMS AND
DEATH FROM LEAD EXPOSURE SPILLS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE ABLE TO CLEAN UP TOXIC
LEAD SITES AND THE SPECIALLY IF
YOU WANT TO GET LEAD POISONING
WORKING IN A BATTERY RECYCLING
PLANT IS PROBABLY THE BEST WAY
TO DO IT.
IS THAT IN SOME DATA WE'VE
GATHERED FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
THE LEAD A RECYCLERS BATTERY
PEOPLE IN LA HAVE.
YOUR AFTER YOUR EXPOSURES TO
WITH WORKERS TO HIGHER THAN
RECOMMENDED LEAD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ON A SIDE TRIP IS ANY LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS I WOULD ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE
AND JUST KNOW THAT THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO THE COMMUNITIES OR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
THEY HAVE SUFFERED HEALTH
DISPARITIES A SIGNIFICANT --
HEALTH ISSUES SUCH AS CANCER
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES.
SO WE WOULD VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEES I VOTE
[INAUDIBLE]
OKAY.
HI GOOD MORNING WORKING CLEAN
FOR BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS AND SUPPORT.
LARA COMMISSAIRE CLUB CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT.
SELECT DOES HERE WE HAVE TO STOP
HUESO SUPPORT.
I DO SANBORN IN SUPPORT OF FROM
THE NATIONAL STORAGE AFFECTION
COUNCIL ON THE CALIFORNIA
PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL.
CLEAN WATER ACTION ANDREA
VENTURA IN SUPPORT. THREE
SEPARATE VERGE ON BEHALF OF THE
LOCAL ADMINISTRATORS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH IN SUPPORT.
SHERIN CENTERS OF COST AND THEY
HAVE TO CALIFORNIA NEW CAR
DEALERS IN SUPPORT.
THAT CHOICE ON BEHALF OF THE
BATTERY COUNCIL INTERNATIONAL
REPRESENT.
BATTERY MANUFACTURERS RECYCLERS
AND CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE A NEUTRAL POSITION AND
HAVE REMOVED -- OPPOSITION SINCE
THE RECENT AMENDMENTS AND JUST
WANNA.
THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF -- FOR WORKING
COLLABORATIVE CLEVERLY WITH US
AND WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU.
I ANYONE WANTS REYES OPPOSITION --
CONCERNS OF THE BILL.
I TO SING THEM WILL BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE --
FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS LAWCENTER
DOLLY.
THE YEAH GOOD TO SEE YOU.
I JUST WANTED.
I AS YOU KNOW I WORKED.
AS AN EQ WITH YOU -- TOXICS A
LOT OF THIS ISSUE.
WORK ON THE ON BEEN CRITICAL OF
IT ABOUT.
HOW THOSE FUNDS HAVE BEEN?
ACTUALLY MOVED TO THE GROUND SO --
MAYBE CAN TOUCH ON THAT A LITTLE
BIT.
THE OTHER THING I WANT TO ASK
YOU IS.
AFTER WORK ON A THE RECYCLING
BILL ON AUTOMOBILES -- EDIE'S
AND NOW WE HAVE THE YOU KNOW THE
PACKS THAT -- BASICALLY THE THE
STORAGE BATTERIES THAT ARE.
BUILT BY A DIFFERENT COLOR --
LIKE TEST LÀ HAZIM FOR YOUR
HOME -- IS THERE A IS THERE A
FEE ON THOSE -- AS FAR AS IS IS
JUST CAR BATTERIES AND AND THE
LIKES.
THIS IS AT LEAD OF BATTERIES AND
SO A LOT OF THOSE BATTERIES
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WITH TESLA.
ARE NOT YOU SEEN LAD.
I I THINK THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
FOLKS INCLUDING MY IN
LEGISLATORS WHO ARE HERE TODAY
AND TOMORROW WHO HAVE BEEN
ASKING ABOUT THAT ISSUE AND ARE
WE THINKING AHEAD AND AND
PLANNING AHEAD.
AND HAPPY NOW THAT WE'RE ASKING
THOSE QUESTIONS AND SOMETHING
THAT I'M I'M INTERESTED IN I
THINK RIGHT NOW IT'S BEEN MORE
ABOUT ING AND YOU'LL HAVE TO
HEAR FROM ME THREE TIMES AND ARE
ON TWO DIFFERENT THINGS -- THE
CONTAMINANTS WE DO YOU KNOW
ABOUT IN MY COMMUTER AND HOW WE
DEAL WITH THOSE EXISTING MAN
MADE DISASTERS BUT INTERESTED IN
HOW WE MAKE SURE WE PREVENTIVE
IN THE FUTURE AS WELL -- THE
MONEY'S COMING TO DO INITIALLY
THE MONIES ARE BEING USED TO PAY
OFF THE LOAN THE ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX MILLION DOLLAR LOAN.
THAT GOVERNOR BROWN HAD
AUTHORIZED TO HELP CLEAN UP
EXCITED -- TO DO THE BUY TO
NEGOTIATIONS THAT PRACTICE HAS
NOT STOPPED IN SO THE BILL DID
ALLOW FOR THAT LONG TO HAPPEN --
IT WAS SO TECHNICALLY WITHIN THE
SPIRIT BUT I THINK WITH THE
SPREAD OF WHAT WE REALLY WANT TO
SAY WE CLEAN EVERYTHING UP AND
WE WORRY ABOUT THE LOAN AT THE
END.
I INTO THAT PRACTICE HAS HAS NOT
STOPPED THE INITIAL PROCESS TO
CLEAN UP EXCITED.
HAS BEEN DIFFICULT -- AT BEST I
WOULD SAY MY CONSTITUENTS HAVE
SHARED A LOT OF STORIES WITH US.
WE'RE CLOSE TO GETTING TO THE
FIRST ONE THOUSAND HOMES BEING
CLEAN A LONG WAY FROM THE TEN
THOUSAND HOME WITH MINIMUM THAT
WE NEED CLEANED UP.
BUT I THINK AS WE NOW HAVE A
SECOND -- CONTRACTOR THERE.
WE ARE IMPROVING THE PROCESSES
BUT I'M NOT GONNA LIE I JAMES
VESTRY HERE WE HAVE A LOT OF
HISTORY SINCE ALONG THE WAY.
I KEEP TALKING ABOUT ONE HAVING
A STABLE SOURCE OF REVENUE TO DO
THE WORK AND TO LEARNING EVERY
STEP OF THE WAY SO THAT WHEN WE
EXPAND TO LIST OTHER SMELTERS
AND THE FOR THE COMMUNITIES AT
ALL FOR THE SERVER.
FROM JUSTICE I THAT WOULD THT
WE DO A BETTER WE LEARN FROM THE
SITUATION -- INTO THEIR STUFF
THAT'S BEYOND EVEN THE CLEAN UP
WHICH IS THE TNC THAT THAT WE'RE
ALSO TRYING TO DRAFT OTHER.
OPINIONS OUT THERE.
ALL MY LIFE THESE THESE ISSUES
HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED -- FROM MY
LIFE LONGER MY COMMUNITY AND
COMMUNITY SEGMENT HAVE BEEN
TREATED LIKE WASTELANDS.
THE EXCITING PART IS THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE DON'T
HAVE ROLE MODELS OF HOW TO DO IT.
AND SO WE ARE STUMBLING FORWARD
BUT THE PROCESS THAT WE HAVE IS
WE HAVE AN OUNCE I KEEP TELLING
FOLKS ON THE GROUND AS YOU
PATIENT AFTER OUT HOW.
HOW TO MAKE IT BETTER ALONG THE
WAY IT'S NOT THAT I DON'T THINK
WE DESERVE BETTER BUT THIS IS
WHAT I HAVE RIGHT NOW WHICH IS
BETTER THAN WHAT I'VE HAD MOST
OF MY LIFE?
OKAY OTHER QUESTIONS SPOTS --
OKAY -- IS -- I'M CERTAINLY
SUPPORTING THE BILL -- WITH YEAH
I I REVIEWED SAID THE MAN YES
OKAY SO YOU ACCEPT THE
COMMITMENTS -- I DON'T KNOW IF
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
DICE RIGHT NOW WILLING TO MOVE
THE BILL IF NOT WE CAN.
WAY FOR MOTION.
THE TERM OKAY SO WE'LL WAIT FOR
MOTION -- OR AT YES ORDER.
OKAY EVEN MAKE EMOTIONAL.
DOES HE GET OUT OF THE WAY.
OKAY OKAY ALL RIGHT THAT'S
PRETTY THE CURRENCY OKAY SO --
HI WITH CHECK THAT WITHOUT
CHECKING WITH TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO GOVERNANCE OF FINANCE.
HAS ACTED WITH COLOR.
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB ONE FORTY
TWO THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE ALLEN HI
ALLEN I BATES [INAUDIBLE]
HILL [INAUDIBLE]
SKINNER [INAUDIBLE]
STERN [INAUDIBLE]
DOLLY [INAUDIBLE]
I CASKEY.
OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA HOLD THAT
OPEN FOR HIM OTHER MEMBERS AT
AUDIT DEPRECIATE THAT CENTER.
AND THANK YOU THANK YOU SON OVER
TO MY BILL FIFTY MORE BILLS OKAY
GREAT ARE YOU NEXT PRESENT.
ITEM THIRTEEN IS AB SEVEN FIFTY
SIX THIS IS ACTUALLY THE TO
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS.
THANK YOU I'M SORRY I'M SORRY
NUMBER FIVE IS AB ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN REALLY INTO USE MATTRESS
RECOVERY THANK YOU [INAUDIBLE]
THE BILL.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT.
GET AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I'VE BEEN WORKING -- WAIT THAT'S
THE TRUTH OKAY.
THANK YOU BEFORE I BEGAN I WANT
TO COMMIT TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE STAFF ON THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE BILL.
ANALYSIS -- I DO APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
DOING ON THIS BILL AND ACTUALLY
DO APPRECIATE ALL THE
STAKEHOLDER SEVEN AT THE TABLE
TRYING TO GET TO A CONSENSUS.
I WE HAVE A MEASURES RECYCLING
COUNCIL OUT THERE THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED.
SOME YEARS AGO I WAS HERE IN THE
LEGISATURE AND WE ASK FOR AN
AUDIT TO SEE HOW WE WERE DOING
ALONG THE WAY AND TO SEE HOW THE
PRIME WAS WORKING AND ALONG THE
WAY.
THE AUDIT HAD AND HIGHLIGHTER
NUMBER ISSUE THAT NEEDED TO BE
ADDRESSED THE REQUIRES AND
RECOMMENDS THAT WE REQUIRE A
COPY CYCLE TO PROGRAM GOALS AND
MEASURES.
REQUIRE THE MRC TO RESUBMIT PLAN
FOR APPROVAL AS A TUTOR CAP ON
RESEARCHERS REQUIRE AND MY
SECRET TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
BUDGET INFORMATION TO CARRY
CYCLES OF CLASS.
ADDRESSES HOW THE PROGRAM
OPERATES WHEN A BUDGET IS NOT
APPROVED -- AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BIGELOW ALSO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
WORLD COMMUNITIES HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO USE -- TO HAVE
THEIR MATTRESSES RECYCLED.
AND SO AB ONE EIGHTY SEVEN IS
IMPLEMENTING THE RECOMMENDED
CHANGES I THE STATE AUDITOR IT
IS A BIPARTISAN.
BILL ARE WE CONTINUE WE ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
ANY OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT ARE
OUT THERE.
AND HAVE FULL FAITH THAT WE WILL
HAVE A CONSENSUS.
IN THE NEAR FUTURE WITH THE HELP
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS AND WITH THE
HELP OF YOUR COMMITTEE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH OTHER
FOLKS ON A WIN THIS IS PART.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS MICHAEL DOT ON THE MANAGING
DIRECTOR OF THE MATTRESS
RECYCLING COUNCIL.
MRC IS SUPPORTIVE OF EIGHTY ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN AS IT IS AND PRINT
APPRECIATES THE HARD WORK THE
AUTHORS STAFF AND STAKEHOLDERS
HAVE PUT INTO THIS BILL OVER THE
LAST SIX MONTHS.
MRC THE NONPROFIT FIVE OH ONE C.
THREE AUTHORIZED BY CAL RECYCLE
TO A MINISTER CAL RECYCLES
MATTRESS RECYCLING PROGRAM.
AMBER SEA'S CREATED A STATEWIDE
NETWORK OF OVER TWO HUNDRED
MATTRESS COLLECTION LOCATIONS TO
SERVE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
PROVIDING CONVENIENT MATTRESS
RECYCLING ACCESS 290% OF
CALIFORNIANS.
THIS NETWORK IS AUGMENTED BY
TARGETING COLLECTION EVENTS AND
RETAILERS TAKING BACK OLD
AT NO COST.
IMMERSE IS EXCEEDED EACH OF CAL
RECYCLES ANNUAL COLLECTION GOALS
AND IS RECYCLED OVER FOUR
MILLION MATTRESSES SINCE.
TWENTY SIXTEEN OVER 80% OF
MATTRESSES DISCARDED ANNUALLY OR
DISCARDED FROM LANDFILL BECAUSE
OF MRC SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM.
THIS BILL REFLECTS THE STATE
AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS
ADDRESSES A STAKEHOLDER
GOVERNANCE CONCERNS AND PROVIDES
CAL RECYCLE WITH EXTENSIVE.
NEW OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY.
THIS BILL ALSO MANDATES THE
SOLID WASTE FACILITIES COLLECTED
OVER COLLECTING OVER ONE
THOUSAND MATTRESSES AND REALLY
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM.
A SUGGESTION MADE BY THE CAL
RECYCLE MATTRESS ADVISORY
COMMITTEE.
THIS PROVISION SUPPORTS
CALIFORNIA'S 75% DIVERSION GOAL.
EVER SEE SUCCESSFULLY NEGOTIATED
CONTRACTS WITH OVER TWO HUNDRED
FACILITIES ACROSS THE STATE USE
AN EQUITABLE FORMULA FOR
COMPENSATION.
MANDATORY PARTICIPATION WILL
INCREASE CONSUMER ACCESS AND
DECREASE ILLEGAL DUMPING.
WITHOUT FULL FACILITY
PARTICIPATION SOME CONSUMERS
WILL BE CHARGED TWICE RECYCLING
MATTRESSES.
ONCE THE TIME OF PURCHASE AND
AGAIN IF THE USE OF SAUDI THE
CHARGES EXCESSIVE DISPOSAL FEES
SOME CURRENTLY CHARGING UP TO
TWO HUNDRED AND TEN DOLLARS. FOR
A MATTRESS AND BOXSPRING.
OVERALL MRC SUPPORTS THE BILL
HOWEVER AND MARK SEE DOES
DISAGREE WITH THE PROVISION
PROHIBITING MRC FROM USING
PROGRAM REVENUE LITIGATION
INVOLVING THE STATE.
WE HAVE AN EXCELLENT WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH CARY CYCLE
HAS NEVER SEE THE STATE AND
DOESN'T ANTICIPATE THE NEED FOR
LITIGATION.
BUT CIRCUMSTANCES MAKE CHANG'S.
FUTURE ADMINISTRATIONS FOR
INSTANCE COULD TRIED TO DIVERT
AMHERST HE'S REVENUE FOR OTHER
PURPOSES IN VIOLATION OF THE ACT.
WOULD BE BOTH UNFAIR AND UNWISE
TO PROHIBIT M. R. C. OR ITS
SUCCESSOR ORGANIZATION FROM
DEFENDING THE PROGRAM'S
LEGITIMATE AND LAWFUL INTERESTS.
EVER SEE IS ALSO CONCERNED WITH
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENT TO STRIKE
LIABILITIES FROM THE TRANSFER OF
ASSETS AND LIABILITIES TO A
SUCCESSOR ORGANIZATION.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS PROVISION IS
TO FACILITATE AN ORDERLY
TRANSITION OF ALL OF THEM ARE
SEIZE BUSINESS DEALINGS.
BOTH ASSETS AND LIABILITIES NEED
TO BE TRANSFERRED.
LIABILITIES COULD INCLUDE
ACCOUNTS PAYABLE AND HUNDREDS OF
LONG TERM VENDOR CONTRACTS.
WERE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE -- ON THIS MATTER IS
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD.
IN CONCLUSION -- AMMERSEE
BELIEVES AB ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
IMPLEMENTS BUT THE AUDIT
RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND ADDRESSES STAKEHOLDER
GOVERNANCE CONCERNS.
YOUR TIME TODAY THANK YOU.
THE WORK ON THE YES MARK MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK MURRAY
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE.
GREATLY APPRECIATIVE OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA'S PERSISTENCE AND
PATIENCE WITH THIS PROGRAM AND
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS AND THIS
LEGISLATION REPRESENTS AN
IMPROVEMENT.
IN WHAT WAS THE A DECENTLY
OPERATING PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY PROGRAM WE THINK
THAT THAT THESE PROVISIONS WILL
IMPROVE THAT PROGRAM MAKE IT
BETTER -- THE ANALYSIS
IDENTIFIED -- OF A VISION IN THE
LANGUAGE THAT IS NOT ENTIRELY
WHAT WE WERE ANTICIPATING I
THINK THE ANALYSIS IS CORRECT
AND I THINK WE WANT TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE
ON THIS BALANCE.
BETWEEN.
PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY FOR
RECYCLING REFINANCING RECYCLING
AT THE FRONT END.
AND THAT CONSUMER RESPONSIBILITY
WHICH WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
AND THIS NOTION OF OF THE
FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITY THE
CURSE THE BACKEND WE DON'T WANT
CONSUMERS TO HAVE TO PAY TWICE --
BUT WE DO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE PROGRAM FINANCES ARE SUCH
THAT THE THE SOLID WASTE SECTOR
THE PROFESSIONAL RECYCLERS ARE
ENTICED TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PROGRAM.
AND IF A WASTE HAULER IS
CHARGING TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR
A MATTRESS.
IT'S BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT THE
MATTRESSES THEY FEEL LIKE THAT'S
THEY WERE THERE DOING WHATEVER
THEY CAN TO DISCOURAGE IT SO
WHAT WE WANT TO WORK.
WITH WITH THE AUTHOR AND WITH
THE OTHER STAKEHOLDERS ON THAT
LANGUAGE TO KIND OF TO TO
FINESSE THAT PROVISION.
SO THAT CONSUMERS ARE CHARGED
TWICE BUT THE EXISTING SOLID
WAST INFRASTRUCTURE IS EAGER TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROGRAM --
BUT WHEN I HAD THE BILL CONTINUE
MOVING AND ARE SUPPORTING IT
TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU MARK
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OKAY -- BUT THE FOLKS WHO WANT.
TO THE FREE SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MARKUP
PREY ON BEHALF OF REPUBLIC
SERVICES.
AND I'M HAPPY -- TO INDICATE
THAT REPUBLIC SERVICES IS -- IN
SUPPORT IF THE BILL AS AMENDED
WE'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
STAFF AND WITH THE MEMBER -- AND
WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT WE'LL BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS.
THE CONCERNS THAT RELATE TO THE
MANDATORY PARTICIPATION
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL -- IN
WHICH WE BELIEVE WOULD PROVIDE --
A MONOPOLY IF YOU WOULD AND
WOULD PRECLUDE THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO NEGOTIATE A A CORRECT
OR MARKET PRICE WITH THE MRC WE
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
NOT IN A POSITION OF BEING
FORCED TO DO THE WORK AND NOT
GETTING ADEQUATELY.
COMPENSATED THE ALTERNATIVE
MIGHT BE COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO WHICH IS
THAT -- VENDORS OUR SOLD LISA SO
THESE WOULD NOT BE TAKING THESE
THESE -- MATTRESSES AT ALL AND
THAT OF COURSE WOULD BE
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO SO WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO ADOPT A BANKER AND
PASS IT OUT AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU [INAUDIBLE]
MR.
BUT A SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU [INAUDIBLE]
YES SIR.
GOOD MORNING MR MEMBERS JOHN
MOFFITT ON BEHALF OF WASTE
MANAGEMENT JUST ONE LINE OUR
COMMENTS WITH THOSE MADE BY
MISTER.
THANK YOU.
CITY SANTA MONICA.
COME ON I WANT HERE WITH CITIES
AND MUCH OF IT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT YOU'RE TWEENER
LET'S HEAR FROM YOU.
SO I'M WITH A NATIONAL PRIVILEGE
DOES YOUR ON BEHALF NATIONAL
ACTION COUNCIL HEALTHCARE PART
SEARCH COUNCIL AND STOP -- WE
ARE REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION WE
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR ALL HER
WORK WE CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS.
I WON THIS BILL WAS INTRODUCED
IN PRIOR TO THAT -- SO WE WANT
TO MOVE OUR OPPOSITION TO TO A
SUPPORT IF AMENDED THERE ARE
STILL FEW.
KEY OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT MARK
HAS OUTLINED ABOUT THE BIGGER
IT'S NOT MANDATED AND MAYBE
WRITE SOME INCENTIVES.
AS WELL AS INSURANCE REPORTS AND
STUDIES DEVELOP BY WITH CONSUMER
FEE MONEY OUR PUBLIC WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS AND PRIORITIZING
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER FAMILY TO BE
SPENT ON CONTRACTING WITH
CALIFORNIA PROCESSING FACILITIES.
ARE WILL CONTINUE HAVING A
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE WE THINK THE OFFICE
OFFICE AND THE THE STAFF FOR ALL
THE WORKING COMMITTEE -- BUT
WE'RE REMOVING OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU FIGURE MUCH
[INAUDIBLE]
OKAY -- OPPOSITION.
CONCERNS ANYONE WANT TO RAISE
[INAUDIBLE]
OKAY.
I'M SEEING THEN THE MATTER IS
BROUGHT BACK MANY QUESTIONS
THOUGHTS -- SENATE ALI.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK THE AUTHOR.
FOR WORKING WITH US RULE
LEGISLATORS TO HAVE A REALLY
DIFFICULT.
TIME IN A OF TRANSPORTATION
THEY'RE THEY'RE OFF AWFULLY
LARGE AND THEN THE COST THAT'S
ASSOCIATE WITH THAT AS WELL --
WIND UP SEEING THEM ALONGSIDE
THE ROAD ON THE FOREST AND SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR KNOWING ARTISTRY
CAN COME ALONG SIDE THE
RELIGIOUS LEADERS AS MR BIGELOW
NIGHT SO -- LOOK FOR THIS BILL
GETTING SIGNED IN LAWN AND DO
SOME GOOD WORK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER AT MINISTER.
I JUST A QUESTION REGARDING THE
THE THE LITIGATION FEE HAVE YOU
CONSIDERED REMOVING THAT
PROVISION FROM.
AS PART OF THE AMENDMENT AS IT
GOES FORWARD YEAH THAT SEEMS TO
BE A REAL.
AREA OF CONCERN.
ON THE PART OF MRC.
YES CORRECT -- WE'VE OF SERVE TO
OTHER PROGRAMS -- ISSUES AND
ABUSES WITH.
A WITH THE SEIZE OF LITIGATION
ALONG THE WAY WE THINK THAT THE
ORIGINAL PURPOSE OF OF THIS FINE
WHEN I WAS CREATED WEST TO HELP.
RECYCLE MATTRESSES.
ON IN COMBAT ILLEGAL DUMPING YOU
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE MONEY
IS BEING USED FOR THAT ENOUGH
FOR OTHER ITEMS -- ALONG THE WAY.
I THINK THE SUGGESTION IS THAT
IT MAYBE PIECE OF FIFTY TWO
SPECIFIC A LITIGATION SO IF YOU
CONSIDER THAT GOING FORWARD.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE ASKING FOR
SO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT BECAUSE
IT'S IT'S A GREAT PROGRAM AND
I'D LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOU.
SOME REMEMBER WE HAD ON AND AND
INVENTION MY DISTRICT AND IT WAS
VERY POPULAR.
WE HAVE A LOT OF MATTRESSES
TURNED IN BY MRC SO I AM GONNA
SUPPORTED TODAY BUT JUST WITH A
A LITTLE URGING TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THAT BECAUSE I THINK IT CAN
BE NARROWED.
SO THAT IT'S ACCEPTABLE AND THEN
WE GET EVERYBODY ALL THE STAKE
HOLDERS ON THE SAME PAGE BECAUSE
IT'S REALLY A GOOD PROGRAM.
WE WE ARE GREAT THINK ALL OF US
IN THE STAKEHOLDERS AND WAY
EVERYONE AT THE TABLE IS THAT WE
HAVE.
A PROGRAM AND WE HAVE THE RARE
OPPORTUNITY TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO MAKE IT BETTER.
ON A AND SEND THAT TO US WE ARE
WORKING HARD TO MAKE SURE ESTAS
CONTINUES WE GET CLOSER TO A
FULL CONSENSUS.
ALONG THE WAY AND SO ON JUST
LIKE THE LAST BILL WE CONCERT
TRYING TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS.
TO MAKE US ALL.
HAPPY ENOUGH RIGHT.
WE ARE GOING TO BE A LITTLE
UNCOMFORTABLE ALONG THE WAY BUT
HAPPY ENOUGH AND SO WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE MRC -- AND
ALL THE OTHER STAKEHOLDERS AT
THE TABLE WITH US.
HELLO CONSIDER.
THANK YOU OKAY -- IN THE
QUESTIONS IN THE COMMITTEE I DO
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK
ON THIS AND AND OBVIOUSLY.
HAS BEEN A LOT OF BACK
CHANNELING WITH ALL THE
DIFFERENT -- STAKEHOLDER SO I
KNOW HOW MUCH WE'RE GOT INVOLVED
SO -- I'M STRONGLY RECOMMENDING
IT.
AND I VOTE.
YOU KNOW WITH THE WITH THE
AGREEMENT TO ACCEPT OUR
COMMITMENTS AND AND IF IT PASSES
OUT -- GO TO SEND A PREPARATION
SO -- IF THERE'S A WILLINGNESS
TO MOVE THE BILL.
ARE YOU DID OKAY SO THANK YOU SO
THAT'S WHAT YOU DID THE VERY
BEGINNING SO THIS MOVE BY CENTER
DOLLY APPRECIATE THAT SENATOR --
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ALLEN
HI ALLEN I BATES.
RIGHT BATES HI HILL.
SKINNER [INAUDIBLE]
STERN.
DOLLY.
DALI AYE WIECKOWSKI.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO THAT WILL HOLD
THAT OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO
AND ON AND NOW -- YOU'LL PRESENT
YOUR FINAL BILL THE DAILIES THIS
MORNING -- THIS IS ITEM THIRTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEMS.
THANK YOU SO THE FIRST TWO BILLS
FOR ABOUT IMPROVING NO WORK
WE'VE ALREADY DONE -- AND THIS
BILL IS ME VENTURING UNTIL A
WHOLE NEW SPACE I AND P. FOSS --
WHICH IS A CHEMICAL -- THAT I
LEARNED ABOUT US I WAS READING
ABOUT EXCITED WHICH LED ME TO
FLINT WHICH LED ME TO VERMONT
AND MINNESOTA -- AND LET ME TO
P. FIVE I AND AND I WANTED TO
THE HISTORY OF YOUR BOOKING
RESCUE ARE YOU WORKING ON THIS
AND WHEN I STARTED TO LEARN
ABOUT PEOPLE US AND THE DANGERS
BEHIND IT AND I SAY TO LOOK AT
MAPS.
WHEN I LOOKED AT THE MAP OF?
OF WHAT WE HAVE SO FAR WHAT HAS
BEEN TESTED WHEN I LOOKED AT LA
COUNTY.
ALL OF THE TECH ALL OF THE SITES
ALL THE WEALTH WITH P. FOSS FOR
CONCENTRATED IN MY DISTRICT.
AND VALLEY COUNTY ONLY IN MY
DISTRICT I HAVE A FEELING THAT'S
PROBABLY NOT TRUE BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T TESTED X. EXPENSIVELY.
BUT IT DID RECENT ALARMING KIND
OF PUSH TO THE FOREFRONT THAT
CONTINUE DISCUSSION OF
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE TREATED
LIKE WASTE LANCE AND LEAD
CHROMIUM SIX ARSENIC -- AND NOW
PEOPLE US AMONG OTHER CHEMICALS
OUT THERE THAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH.
AND SO -- WITH THAT I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE.
TAKING THE SPACE THAT WERE OUT
WITH THE KNOWLEDGE AND WE'RE AT
LEAST GETTING INFORMATION ONLINE
CONSUMERS TO MAKE.
RIGHT CHOICES FOR THEMSELVES --
I THINK I AM TAKING AMENDMENTS
HERE BUT OTHER EXCEPT YES I AM
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HARD WORK ON THAT -- TO BE CLEAR
IT THIS BILL DOES NOT AUTHORIZE
THE TESTING AS THE WATER BOARD
ALREADY HAS THE AUTHORITY AND
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE. TO
DO THAT.
AND THERE THE FEDERAL
UNREGULATED CONTAMINANT
MONITORING ROLE WE GATHER SOME
INITIAL INFORMATION ABOUT P.
FLOOD CONTAMINATION.
THAT INFORMATION IS JUST THE TIP
OF THE ICEBERG.
UNDER THE SAME WILL CALIFORNIA
HAS MORE CONTAMINATION
DETECTIONS THAN ANY OTHER STATE
THIS FAMILY A CHEMICAL HAS BEEN
LINKED TO CANCER AND BIRTH
DEFECTS.
CALIFORNIA QUITE FRANKLY HAS
FALLEN BEHIND WAITING FOR
CONGRESS OR THE EPA TO SAY WITH
THIS WISHFUL THINKING.
AS WE SEE THAT THEY'RE OFF THE
ROLLING BACK -- WORK MUCH
HONESTLY MOVING FORWARD.
WHILE THE INITIAL VERSIONS IS
BILL WOULD HAVE REQUIRED ALL
WATER SYSTEM TO TEST THE TECH TO
WILL . FIVE THE BILL IN PENN
SIMPLY BOTH THERE'S A WATER
WORTH INVESTIGATIVE TESTING. TO
GET A HANDLE LOW WHERE THESE
FOREVER CHEMICALS ARE.
THE WATER PERSONALLY EMBARKING
ON A FACE INVESTIGATIVE TESTING
OF SYSTEMS THAT ARE SUSPECTED TO
HAVE CONTAMINATION.
ARE WITH ME HERE TODAY I HAVE
JEAN WILLIAMS AND ANDREA EVANS
HER TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF.
DURING THE UNREGULATED
CONTAMINANT MONITORING ROLE
FIFTEEN WELLS WERE ACTUALLY
FOUND TO BE CONTAMINATED WITH
THESE CHEMICALS IN CALIFORNIA
WERE SHUT DOWN BUT THERE WERE
YOU.
NOTIFICATION OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
DRINKING THAT WATER.
AND IT CANNOT BE UNDERSTATED HOW.
TOXIC THIS CONTAMINANT IS IT TOO
CAN TO PCB BUT PC BEES DON'T
USUALLY GET INTO DRINKING WATER.
THESE CHEMICALS DO THEY'RE
EXTREMELY SOLUBLE -- WHEN I
TESTIFIED RECENTLY IT'S?
POLLS FOUND IN DRINKING WATER
BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA END UP WITH
AN EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE PROBLEM
TO FIX.
AND IT IS NOT JUST GOING TO BE
IN CRISTINA GARCIA IS DISTRICT
IT'S GOING TO BE IN DISTRICTS
LIKE YOURS TO SENATOR DOLLING.
WHEREVER THEIR MILITARY BASES
WERE GONNA FIND THAT THESE
CHEMICALS HAVE CONTAMINATED
DRINKING WATER.
SO -- THIS BILL WOULD -- NOTIFY
PEOPLE THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
DRINKING CONTAMINATED WATER --
THEY WOULD HAVE THE OPTION THEN
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THEY SHOULD
FIND NEW SOURCES OF WATER AND
RIGHT NOW JUST IN PHASE ONE OF
THEIR SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTY
WELLS.
THERE IS NO COUNTY THAT IS
UNAFFECTED BY THE SOURCE WELLS.
FROM AND THERE'S TWO HUNDRED
NINE WATER SYSTEMS THAT'S JUST
DAYS ONE OF THE THREE PHASE
PROGRAM TO LOOK EXTENSIVELY FOR
THESE CHEMICALS.
IN OUR DRINKING WATER WELLS AND
AT AT SOURCES WHICH ARE
LANDFILLS AIRPORTS REFINERIES
CHEMICAL MANUFACTURING
FACILITIES IN CHROME PLATING.
SO I READ YOUR AYE VOTE AND I'M
SURE I WILL BE IN FOR THIS
COMMITTEE AGAIN ON THESE
CHEMICALS THEY ARE
EXTRAORDINARILY TOXIC AND VERY
PERVASIVE NOW IN OUR DRINKING
WATER SYSTEMS THANK YOU.
JUST THE OPPOSITE.
HI I'M ANDREA EVAN TURNER WITH
CLEAN WATER ACTION AND I WANT.
TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
THIS BILL AS A STEP IN MOVING
FORWARD IN CALIFORNIA AS YOU
HEARD CALIFORNIA BASED ON
LIMITED DATA.
OF ACTUALLY HAS THE MOST TO TECH
KNOWN DETECTIONS IN THE COUNTRY
AND YET WE ARE FAR BEHIND OTHER
STATES THAT ARE MOVING TO GET A
BETTER GRIP ON WHAT THIS
CONTAMINATION MEANS SO.
MIGHT MY HOPE TO BE HERE TODAY
IS TO PROVIDE YOU WITH A LITTLE
BIT OF BACKGROUND BECAUSE AS
AWARENESS HAS BEEN GROWING.
ABOUT THIS PROBLEM AND OUR STATE
ABOUT THESE FOREVER CHEMICALS
THEY DO NOT BREAK DWN THEY ARE
GOING TO BE WITH US.
PRETTY MUCH FOREVER -- I JUST
WANTED TO PROVIDE A LITTLE A FEW
BACKGROUND POINTS ABOUT WHAT
THEY ARE BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT
OF MISINFORMATION OUT THERE.
FIRST OF ALL THIS IS A CLASS OF
ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND CHEMICALS.
ARE WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT.
WITH THE VAST METADATA IS CHIU
CHEMICALS AND BEEN USED FOR
DECADES BUT THE GROWING NUMBER
OF THESE NEWER GENERATION
CHEMICALS ARE AS PERVASIVE AND
AS PERMANENT IN THE ENVIRONMENT.
AND DESPITE SOME CLAIMS FROM THE
CHEMICAL INDUSTRY TAT THESE
NEWER VERSIONS ARE SAFER WHAT
THAT REALLY MEANS IS THEY HAVE
NOT BEEN STUDIED.
AS EFFECTIVELY AS THEIR OLDER
COUSINS BUT THE EMERGING SCIENCE
AND SCIENTISTS FROM AROUND THE
WORLD TO CALLING THE ALARM ON
THIS.
IS THAT THEY ARE STRUCTURALLY
THE SAME AND ARE EXTREMELY TOXIC
SO WHAT WE REALLY NEED TO DO IN
CALIFORNIA AS OUR FIRST STEP IS
TO GET A BETTER PICTURE OF HOW
MUCH OF THIS STUFF IS OUT THERE
AND REALLY WHAT IT IS WHICH
CHEMICALS ARE OUT THERE.
AND THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP IN THAT DIRECTION -- I DID
WANT TO JUST MAKE TWO FINAL
POINTS ON THIS YOU MAY HEAR THAT
AS THE YOU KNOW THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS A PLAN TO DEAL
WITH THIS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS A
PLAN THAT WILL DEAL WITH CHIU
CHEMICALS AT A FIVE THOUSAND AND
THERE ARE NO DEADLINES THERE ARE
NO GUARANTEES OF HOW THIS IS
GOING TO MOVE FORWARD.
THAT'S WHAT I STATES LIKE NEW
YORK VERMONT.
MINNESOTA ARE MOVING AHEAD
ALREADY STUDYING WITH THEIR
PROBLEMS ARE IN TRYING TO
ADDRESS THEM.
THE SAME THING IS HERE -- THE
STATE IS NOT YET WORKING ON A
REGULATION BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
THE DATA YET WE DON'T KNOW HOW
HOW BROAD THIS PROBLEM IS AS YOU
JUST HEARD IT'S GOING TO BE VERY
BROAD THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THEY'RE DOING A GREAT JOB
THEY'VE GOT IT GOOD SITE
INVESTIGATION STARTED THIS YEAR.
THIS BY A BILL BOTH BOLSTERS
THAT.
FINALLY TRANSPARENCY IS
ESSENTIAL.
OUR PEOPLE HAVE THE BASIC RIGHT
TO KNOW ABOUT WHAT'S IN THEIR
WATER SO IF -- WE ARE MONITORING
THEIR SYSTEMS THEY SHOULD BE
TOLD WHETHER THESE CHEMICALS ARE
THEY ARE WHAT THEY ARE.
THAT NOT ONLY IS HUMAN RIGHTS
BUT IT ALSO BILLS ACTUALLY MORE
TRUST IN WATER -- PUBLIC WATER
PURVEYORS MANY OF WHOM ARE
TRYING TO DO THE BEST THEY CAN
TO ADDRESS THESE KIND OF
MERCHANTS.
EXCUSE ME CONTAMINANTS SO WE
THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS BILL AND
OUR MEMBERS CALL FOR THAT KIND
OF TRANSPARENCY.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE SUPPORTING IT
THANK YOU.
OKAY OTHER FOLKS WHO WANT -- TO
REYES SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
FILL OUT ANY OF OUR DELYLAH
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP --
AS MISS VENTURE POINTS OUT THESE
NEWER CHEMICALS ARE SERIOUS
BUSINESS A NEW REPORT JUST CAME
OUT OF FAST CHEMICALS AND
PANCREATIC CANCER IN RODENTS.
SO AS THE SCIENCE EMERGES WE
NEED TO BE CAUTIOUS ABOUT THE
USE OF THESE CHEMICALS THANK YOU
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU. THREE SEPARATE VERGE
ON BEHALF OF THE DIMINISH THE
LOCAL ADMINISTRATORS
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND SUPPORT.
NEGO CHAPMAN ON BEHALF OF ME
WATER CENTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY HI FOLKS HONOREES CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL OPPOSITION.
WE CAN MAKE SOME SPACE FOR THEM.
DRAW IT OFF AGO JUST.
I CAN ALWAYS CONSENSUS I TRY.
THE TO HAVE SOME OF THE COOLEST
GLASSES IN THE BUILDING AS FROM
A SALAD THAT YEAH IT'S A GOOD
INTRODUCTION SO HE'S GOT
SOMETHING IN COMMON YEAH THAT'S
FINE.
WELL A LOT IN COMMON YEAH.
GOOD MORNING SENATORS AND CAN
UNITS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENTS HERE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
TO AB SEVEN FIVE SIX WANT TO
THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- FOR
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH US AND
AND BEING OPEN -- TO SERVE OUR
FEEDBACK.
I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT
OUR CONCERNS.
DURING FOR P. FAST.
THIS IS A AS AS WAS DISCUSSED
BEFORE THIS IS A CHEMICAL FOR
ART FOREVER CHEMICAL VERY
PREVALENT.
IN WATER SYSTEMS IN FOOD IT'S
IT'S ME IN MANY PLACES.
I APPRECIATE THE COST WAS
BROUGHT UP -- WATER AGENCIES DID
NOT CREATE THIS PROBLEM BUT WE
DO HAVE A SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN
ADDRESSING IT AND THERE IS.
SIGNIFICANT COSTS RELATED TO
THAT.
WE ARE NOT OPPOSED TO PUBLIC
NOTIFICATION PARTICULARLY
THROUGH THE CONSUMER CONFIDENCE
REPORTS AND SO WE APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE COMMITTEE
OFFERED IN THE ANALYSIS.
THEY DO MAKE THE BILL -- MUCH
BETTER WE'RE NOT OPPOSED TO
FIXING AN ADMINISTRATIVE ISSUE
WHICH I BELIEVE IS THE INTENT OF
SUBSECTION A OF THE BILL --
REGARDING THE WATER BOARD AND
THEIR STORY TO ISSUE ORDERS TO
MULTIPLE AGENCIES.
WE WE ARE NOT OPPOSED TO THAT I
THINK THE LANGUAGE THAT HIS
IMPRINT IS MUCH MORE BROAD THAN
THAT GIVES THE BOARD A LOT MORE
AUTHORITY -- IN THAT REGARD.
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT IS THAT
ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY GRANTED TO
THE BOARD.
UNDER EXISTING LAW THE BOARD
BEFORE THE ISSUE AN ORDER HAS TO
DETERMINE POTENTIAL
CONTAMINATION.
OF A OF A WELL OR WATER SOURCE
UNDER THE LANGUAGE CRAFTED IN
THE BILL THAT -- REQUIREMENT IS
NOT THERE SO THE WATER BOARD CAN
SIMPLY REQUIRE EVERY WATER
AGENCY TO MONITOR FOR P. FAST WE
THINK THERE SHOULD BE SOME.
OF BELIEVE THAT IF THERE'S
CONTAMINATION.
WE HAVE SOME AMENDMENTS THAT WE
THINK WOULD RESOLVE THAT ISSUE
AND WOOD -- REALLY FOCUS ON
AMENDING EXISTING LAW.
WE ALSO DON'T THINK THAT -- IT
WOULD IT'S BENEFICIAL TO HAVE
WATER AGENCIES REPORT ON WELLS --
FOUR OF FIVE YEARS EVEN AFTER
THOSE WELLS OR WATER SOURCES
HAVE BEEN CLEANED UP AND
ADDRESSED -- THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE CONTINUOUS -- REPORTING
FOR FIVE YEARS -- IN CONSUMER
CONFIDENCE REPORTS -- OUR
PRIMARY CONCERN IS REALLY THE
SEPARATE REGULATORY AUTHORITY
AND NOTIFICATION PROCESS THAT'S
BEING CREATED SPECIFIC TO P. F.
A. S..
CHEMICALS -- AS AS MANY OF YOU
ARE AWARE THERE IS SIGNIFICANT --
WORK GOING ON ALREADY REGARDING
P. FAST AND CHEMICALS AT BOTH
THE STATE AND FEDERAL LEVEL
USEPA IS IN THE PROCESS OF
MAKING A DISH AND THE SHOULDER
OF DETERMINATION ON TO CHEMICALS
AS WAS STATED EARLIER -- WHO
THEY BELIEVE TO USEPA SAYS THEY
WILL HAVE THIS DONE BY THE END
OF THE YEAR?
THERE ARE MORE THAN A DOZEN
BILLS MOVING THROUGH CONGRESS
RELATED TO P. FAST THAT WOULD
EITHER EXPEDITE AND MCL.
OR REQUIRE OTHER ADDITIONAL
REGULATION -- A NUMBER OF THESE
HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT -- AND
SOMETHING MAY ACTUALLY HAPPEN ON
P. FAST REGULATION IN CONGRESS
IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS I
KNOW THAT SOUNDS CRAZY -- IT
SOUNDS CRAZY TO SAY -- BUT IN
MARCH UNDER EXISTING WATER BOARD
AUTHORITY -- THEY INITIATED THIS
PHASED INVESTIGATION TO
DETERMINE THE SCOPE OF A P. FAST
CONTAMINATION IT AND THEY
ORDERED.
AS WAS SAID EARLIER SIX HUNDRED
SIXTY WELLS AND TWO HUNDRED NINE
WATER SYSTEMS -- TO TO TEST FOR
A P. FPS CHEMICALS WE WILL BE
TESTING OVER THE NEXT YEAR AND
NUMBER OF THOSE ARE WITH.
AQUA MEMBER AGENCIES.
WE ARE FULLY IN SUPPORT OF
TRYING TO IDENTIFY THE SCOPE OF
THIS PROBLEM BECAUSE WE DON'T
REALLY FULLY UNDERSTAND -- HOW
HOW MANY WELLS AND SYSTEMS ARE
IMPACTED -- SO THEY WILL BE
TESTING OVER THE NEXT YEAR IF
THEY EXCEED NOTIFICATION LEVELS
THEY WILL REPORT THAT TO THEIR
GOVERNING BODIES -- THEY WILL --
THESE WILL GO INTO THE CONSUMER
CONFIDENCE REPORT AS WELL -- AND
SO WE AGREE -- AGAIN WITH THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THAT THAT
SAYS THAT IF A RESPONSE LEVEL IS
EXCEEDED THAT SHOULD ALSO GO
INTO THE CONSUMER CONFIDENCE
REPORT THAT MAKES SENSE.
BUT AGAIN A SEPARATE REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK FOR P. FASS DOESN'T
SEEM TO MAKE SENSE AND I KNOW IT
SOUNDS CRAZY BUT WE WOULD ASK
THAT IF WE'RE GONNA SAYS IF.
PROCESS IS NOT WORKING -- IF
IT'S NOT WORKING FOR P. FAST IF
IT'S NOT WORKING FOR OTHER
CONTAMINANTS LET'S CHANGE
EXISTING LAWS SO THAT IT DOES
WORK.
THAT'S NOT CREATE A SEPARATE
REGULATORY STRUCTURE FOR ONE
GROUP OF CONTAMINANTS -- FINALLY
JUST A REALLY QUICK ASSEMBLY A
BILL EIGHT FOUR ONE BY -- MR
TANG -- THOUGH WE KNOW THAT BILL
IS NOT MOVING THAT THE BILL WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF IT SET
TIMELINES FOR STATE AGENCIES TO
COMPLETE SOME WORK REGARDED.
REGARDING P. FAST WE SUPPORT
THAT EFFORT THEEXISTING PROCESS
IS VERY SCIENTIFIC VERY
TECHNICAL.
WE THINK THAT REGULATING
CONTAMINANTS LENDS ITSELF TO THE
REGULATORY PROCESS BETTER
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
THE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHASING AND
SOLVE THIS REPRESENTING THE
ORANGE COUNTY WATER DISTRICT WE
TO SHARE MANY OF THE CONCERNS
MOST NOTABLY THE SEPARATE P.
FAST REGULATORY STRUCTURE.
BUT THAT SAID WE ALSO VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE AND THE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS AND THE WATER
DISTRICT WILL BE RE EVALUATING.
THE POSITION BUT WOULD HOPE TO
HAVE THE SEPARATE REGULATORY
PROCESS ADDRESSED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER FOLKS WANT TO
RAISE CONCERNS.
I'M DANIEL BLASTED OF CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
I WANT TO APOLOGIZE TO THE
AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEE WE ARE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE JUST MATT
AND WE WERE NOT ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE OUR AND CONCERNS BUT
WE DO SHARE MANY OF THE CONCERNS
THAT THAT AWKWARD HAS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING.
WITH -- THE AUTHOR IN THIS
COMMITTEE TRYING TO DRESS.
THE SECURE MEMBERS THE THIRTY
MILLION ON HAND HALF OF THE
SENATE CLEARED OF OUR WATER
AGENCY IN MAY SO WATER DISTRICT
WE HAVE THE SAME CONCERNS AS
AQUA.
THANK YOU.
RYAN IS JACKING WITH THE
REGIONAL WATER AUTHORITY -- HAVE
IDENTICAL CONCERNS SAGA DO
SUPPORT -- ADDRESSING P. FAST
WOULD LIKE TO JUST THE
INCORPORATED UNDER EXISTING LAW.
AND APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT WILL CERTAINLY TAKE A
LOOK -- AND REEVALUATE BASED ON
THAT.
THANK.
OKAY.
YEAH I MEAN IT I MEAN -- THE END
OF THE DAY.
THE BILL SCALED BEEN SCALED BACK
FROM ACQUIRING THE WATER SYSTEMS
A TEST REVIEW THIS DOWN.
TO YOU KNOW AUTHORIZING THE
BOARD OR MONITORING I UNDERSTAND
YOU YOU YOU MAY BE WORRIED ABOUT
THAT BUT YOU'LL STILL BE AN
AGENT WITH THE BOARD OVER.
THE VALUE IN THE COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS OF SEAT WITH DOING THAT
AYE AYES TO YOU KNOW THE BOARD
IS AN INTERESTING POINT AND
WATER AGENCIES OUT OF BUSINESS
BUT THERE ALSO NEEDS TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE HIGH.
WATER QUALITY THAT RECEIPT THAT --
THESE CHEMICAL PROBLEMS ARE OF
YOUR MAKING BY YOU CAN
RESPONSIBILITIES OF I'D CLEAN
WATER.
TO FOLKS -- SO I'M I'M.
I HEAR YOU I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE
GONNA CONTINUE WORKING TOGETHER
AND SEE WHAT YOU CAN GET BUT I I
I'M FEELING.
COMFORTABLE SUPPORT THE BILL THE
DAIS.
AS AMENDED -- OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE MEMBERS.
THE BILL OKAY -- OKAY ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION NOW ALRIGHT I HAVE
YOU MAY CLOSE.
OUT YES THEY DO ON A RESPOND TO
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION I THINK
YOU'D BE HERE FROM THEM THERE IS.
A LOT OF COMMON GROUND -- I
DON'T AGREE THAT WE ARE REALLY
CREATING A SEPARATE REGULATORY
PROCESSES WERE ST. TO THE WATER
BOARD IS ALREADY LOOKING AT AT
LEAST TWO OF THESE CHEMICALS --
AS WE KNOW MOST ABOUT TO TREAT
HIM LIKE A FAMILY THERE ARE
FOREVER CHEMICALS WE KNOW THEY
BEHAVE VERY SIMILARLY -- AND SO
WE DON'T HAVE TO RUN THROUGH.
FIVE THOUSAND OF DIFFERENT
PROCESSES WE COULD.
HAVE WON THAT THEY'RE ALREADY
WORKING OUR NOT INTERFERE IN THE
AND THAT PROCESS AT ALL
WHATSOEVER CRIME FAMILY.
YES AT YOU KNOW I I THINK IT'S
MAYBE WORTH IN A CRIME FAMILY --
FROM FROM THE EFFECTS OUT THERE --
YOU KNOW AND I FIND IT
INTERESTING THAT THEY SUPPORT MR
TING THIS BILL THAT IS SPECIFIC
TO P. PHOSPHO IF THE SEPARATE
REGULATION WAS TRUE ARGUMENT.
THAT'S ALSO CREATING A SEPARATE
ELATION THERE ON P. -- FIVE AND
SO I I FIND THAT TO BE AN
INTERESTING ARGUMENT THERE I
WOULD SAY THAT.
ANY PROCESS WE HAVE CAN ALWAYS
BE IMPROVED AND SAVE THE M. CELL
PROCESS THESE TO BE INPUT AT THE
STATE LEVEL THAT'S A DISCUSSION
THAT COULD BE HAD.
SEPARATELY I IN THE FUTURE
SOMETHING I'M COMMITTED TO I
WANT TO MAKE SET UP PROCESS IS
WORKING.
PROPERLY I LOOK AT OUR PROCESS
WITH CHROMIUM SIX AND THAT'S
TAKEN OVER A DECADE AND SO
THERE'S DEFINITELY IMPROVEMENTS
THAT CAN BE HAD.
I THINK WITH THIS BILL MY GOAL
IS TWO THINGS ONE TO RAISE
AWARENESS WITH THE PUBLIC OF
WHAT P. FIVE IS.
A LOT OF FOLKS ARE JUST TRYING
TO LEARN ABOUT THIS -- INTO THAT
THEY ARE ABLE TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS IF YOU ARE PREGNANT
THERE'S A RECOMMENDATION THAT
YOU DO NOT DRINK THIS WATER IF
YOU DO NOT KNOW.
THAT HOW DO YOU MAKE THAT
DECISION -- I THINK THAT'S JUST
ONE EXAMPLE OF OF NEEDING TO
MAKE DECISIONS IF YOU KNOW THAT
WE ARE AT A TRESTLE THAT SHOULD
BE THIS CLOSE TO THE GOVERNING.
BODY WHY SHOULD WE NOT DISCLOSE
IT TO THE CONSUMER AS WELL IN A
PROCESS THAT'S ALREADY BEING
USES CLOSE.
A BUNCH OF OTHER THINGS TO THE
CONSUMERS OUT THERE THIS
CONSUMERS THAT WANT IT WILL USE
THAT INFORMATION AND THOSE THAT
DON'T.
WILL DISCARD THE LETTER LIKE
THEY DO EVERY YEAR -- WITH THEIR
BILL OUT THERE THIS IS A SMALL
BILL IF HE ASKED ME FOR A REALLY
LARGE AND SCARY PROBLEM OUT
THERE.
I RECOMMEND YOU ALL LOOK AT THE
DEVIL WE DON'T KNOW ON WILL BE
ON NETFLIX A DOCUMENTARY ABOUT
THIS.
THIS PROBLEM IS BAD ENOUGH THAT
WE HAVE -- RANCHERS IN THE STATE
OF OUR CENTER LAB TO KILL
THOUSANDS OF CAL'S BECAUSE IT IS
A FOREVER CHEMICAL IN IT IF IT'S
IN YOUR WATER AND THEN LISTEN TO
YOUR FOOD SOURCE IN A STAYS
THERE.
IT'S POPPING UP AND THINGS LIKE --
CAKE -- THIS CAKE BAKING BOXES
OUT THERE -- IT'S IT'S POPPING
UP NOT TO THEIR PLACES IN A
WHILE ONE SMALL AMOUNT OF IN A
BOX MAY SEEM LIKE NOT A BIG DEAL
BECAUSE IT THE FOREVER CHEMICAL
THAT SISTER IT ACCUMULATES.
INSIDE THE COMPOUND IT ISSUE
THAT WERE BEING FACED WITH IT'S
IT'S PRETTY GREAT OUT THERE AND
SO.
WE KNOW.
I WOULD SAY THAT AQUA AND THESE
OTHER WATER AGENCIES MIGHT HAVE
CONCERNS THAT ARE FOR A FIRST
LOOK AT THE P. FOSSE'S DANGEROUS
ENOUGH.
WE KNOW ENOUGH ABOUT THIS
INFORMATION ABOUT THIS FAMILY
EVEN THOUGH MORE AND MORE THE
SCIENCES EMERGING.
THAT WE SHOULD BE TAKING ACTION
I ALWAYS SAY IT'S CRIMINAL FOR
US TO SIT HERE AND SAY LET'S
WAIT THIS WE KNOW THE TEN YEARS
TO LEARN A LITTLE BIT MORE I
LISTEN TO ME TO PUT COMMUNITIES
IN DANGER.
ON COMPETING AND CONTINUE TO PUT
KIDS WHO ARE DEVELOPING IN
DANGER WHILE WE FIGURE OUT A
LITTLE BIT MORE AND I FIND THAT
TO BE A CRIMINAL STAND SINCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND I I DO HOPE I SCARE
SOME OF THE TO GO LEARN A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT THE SAME MAKING
BETTER CHOICES FOR YOURSELF.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
I'M.
AS OUR CLOTHES I WE WE BUT WE
CERTAINLY.
HAVE A YEAR.
IF YOU WANT YOU TO THE COMMITTEE
AFTERWARDS WE HAVE TO HAVE IT
HAPPEN HERE FROM YOU IN AND
CONTINUE WORKING WITH YOU.
I'M OKAY WITH THAT AS ADAM TO
MOVE BY CINEMA CASKEY --
SURGICALLY KALRA.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX THE MOTION AS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE BATES
[INAUDIBLE]
HILL [INAUDIBLE]
SKINNER.
STERN.
DOLLY.
I BY CASKEY.
ESKI AYE OKAY THANK YOU FOR
USING AMBER AND YVETTE EVERYONE
FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION.
IT LOOKS LIKE A OBSERVERS
COLORANTS AROUND AS A BEEN USING
INTENSE DISCUSSION AND
NEGOTIATION OF WHO'S GONNA GO
FIRST.
OKAY ALL RIGHT -- APPRECIATE
YOUR YOUR FORBEARANCE SOONER
CERVANTES SO LET'S NOW HEAR FROM --
COLORADO'S HERE TO PRESENT IN
TENNIS AB SIX FORTY SEVEN ACT
REALLY HAZARDOUS MATERIALS.
MAYBE SEE ONE RIGHT THANK YOU --
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
FOR THE OPTION PRESENT AB SIX
FORTY SEVEN BEFORE YOU TODAY.
I LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENT JUST
OUTLINED THE ANALYSIS AND
APPRECIATE THE TIME GIVEN TO
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE AT
ADDRESSING CONCERNS EXPRESSED.
SB SIX FORTY SEVEN REQUIRED
COSMETIC AND DISINFECTING
MANUFACTURES WERE ALREADY
REQUIRED UNDER CURRENT LAW. TO
POSE A SAFETY DATA SHEETS ONLINE
AND TRANSLATE INTO COMMON
LANGUAGES SPOKEN BY SOMEONE
SPECIALS.
CITY DATA SHEETS ARE USES A
SOURCE INFORMATION ABOUT HAZARDS
INCLUDING ENVIRONMENTAL HAZARDS
AND TO OBTAIN ADVICE ON SAFETY
PRECAUTIONS.
SALON PROFESSIONALS MANY OF WHOM
ARE IMMIGRANTS WOMEN OF COLOR
AND HAVE LIMITED ENGLISH SKILLS
THAT ARE EXPOSED TO BEAUTY CARE
PRODUCTS CONTAINING A MULTITUDE
OF CHEMICALS KNOWN.
OR SUSPECTED TO POSE A HEALTH
RISK CAUSE HARM.
BY ALLOWING SAFETY DATA SHEETS
TO BE ACCESSIBLE ONLINE AND
TRANSIT IN OTHER LANGUAGES
INCREASES TRANSPARENCIES RAISES
SAFETY AWARENESS TO IMPROVE THE
HEALTH AND WORKING CONDITIONS
FOR SOME PROFESSIONALS.
AS THE BILL MOVES FOR UP TO TWO
TO TRY TO FOR THE CURRENT BY THE
BILL AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH INTERESTED PARTIES.
WITH ME TODAY PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY I CATHERINE PORTER
CALL CALIFORNIA HEALTHY MEALS
LONG COLLABORATIVE AND IN A
TRÊN NAIL SALON COMMUNITY
MEMBER.
OKAY YES MA'AM HI I'M CATHERINE
PORTER -- AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SAID THE A POLICY DIRECTOR WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HELPING ELSE ONE
COLLABORATIVE.
WE ARE ONE OF THE TWO
ORGANIZATIONAL CO SPONSORS ALONG
WITH WORK SAFE -- AND ON WHOSE
BEHALF I WILL ALSO BE SPEAKING
TODAY.
CALIFORNIA NAY ALLEN HERE SALON
WORKERS MANY OF WHOM ARE OF
REPRODUCTIVE AGE.
SINCE IN COSMETIC PRODUCTS
CONTAINING CARCINOGENS IN
CHEMICALS LINKED. TO
REPRODUCTIVE RESPIRATORY ANOTHER
HARM MANY SALON PROFESSIONALS
ARE LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT.
UNDER EXISTING LABOR LAW
MANUFACTURERS MUST DEVELOP AND
DISTRIBUTE HARD COPY SAFETY DATA
SHEETS FOR PRODUCTS CONTAINING
HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES IN THEIR
ULTIMATELY REQUIRED TO BE
AVAILABLE.
OUT TO OUR WORKPLACES BY
EMPLOYERS BUT AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
THESE HARD COPY DOCUMENTS CAN
THAT GET LOST IN THE CHAIN OF
DISTRIBUTION.
SALON OWNERS -- SAY THAT THEY'RE
OFTEN NOT AVAILABLE AT BEAUTY
SUPPLY STORES -- ADVOCATES LIKE
OUR ORGANIZATIONS.
AND COUNTY NC COORDINATORS
WOOKIE LOCAL HEALTHY NAIL SALON
RECOGNITION PROGRAMS HAVE A HARD
TIME OBTAINING SAFETY DATA
SHEETS TO ASSIST OUR NAIL SALONS
TO BECOME HEALTHIER WORKPLACES --
OFTEN BECAUSE LICENSE NUMBERS
ARE REQUIRED BEFORE OBTAINING
SAFETY DATA SHEETS ONLINE -- IS
SO THIS IS A VERY STRAIGHT
FORWARD BILL -- REQUIRES SAFETY
DATA SHEETS THAT ARE ALREADY
REQUIRED TO BE CREATED TO BE
POSTED ON THE MANUFACTURER'S
WEBSITE.
AND THOSE ARE ONLINE VERSIONS --
MUST BE TRANSLATED INTO --
SPANISH VIETNAMESE CHINESE AND
KOREAN WE THINK THIS IS A MODEST
AND REASONABLE ATTEMPT TO SHINE
MORE LIGHT ON THE POTENTIAL
HAZARDS OF COSMETICS AND
DISINFECTANTS USED EVERY DAY BY
WOMEN SALON WORKERS.
HAVE FOR THESE REASONS WE URGE A
YES VOTE ON A. B..
SIX FOUR SEVEN THANK YOU
[INAUDIBLE]
SORRY.
HI GOOD MORNING -- MY NAME IS
THE ENTRANCE AND MY PARTNERS AND
I OWN A COPY -- EAGLE ELSE ON
HERE IN POLLS IN CALIFORNIA.
ON MY MOTHER'S BEEN IN THE
INDUSTRY FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AND I JUST KIND OF LIKE
HIGHLIGHTED.
DETAILS WHEN I WAS AND YOU KNOW
QUITE HIGH SCHOOL.
COLLEGE AND I NEVER [INAUDIBLE]
HI -- EITHER I NOR MY MOM OR
THOUGHT THAT IT WAS A TOXIC
ENVIRONMENT BECAUSE WE'RE JUST
LIKE EVERYONE IS USING IT AND
YOU KNOW THEY'RE SELLING IT TO
LESSEN MUST BE SAFE.
RIGHT -- BUT AFTER YEARS -- WE
HAVE.
A LOT OF FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ARE
IN THE BUSINESS AND TO YOU KNOW
HOW THIS LANGUAGE BARRIER WITH A
TO UNDERSTAND -- BY THESE
CHEMICALS ARE TOXIC AND THE ONLY
REASON WHY I KNOWS OF THE SAFETY
DATA SHEETS IS BECAUSE I LEARNED
IT FROM A DIFFERENT INDUSTRY
THAT I WASN'T.
SO WHEN I OPEN SALON I MADE SURE
WE HAD TO LOSE DATA SHEETS BUT
YOU KNOW THERE AN ENGLISH AND
FOR ME IT'S HARD -- TO TRANSLATE
INTO YOU NEEDS TO LET MY
EMPLOYEES KNOW YOU KNOW WHAT
CHEMICALS.
ARE IN THERE [INAUDIBLE]
ON AND I THINK FOR ME X. -- IF
THEY'RE ROUGHLY AVAILABLE ONLINE
IT'S EASIER TO ACCESS.
ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE AVAILABLE
AND OTHER LANGUAGES -- SO THAT
WE CAN PROVIDE A SAFER
ENVIRONMENT NOT ONLY.
FOR EMPLOYEES THE FOR THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE SERVE -- SO
I YOU KNOW AS ANY ALSO HONOR I
FEEL LIKE YOU KNOW I HAVE THE
RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT CHEMICALS I'M
EXPOSING YOU KNOW MY MY WORKERS
TO ENTER CLIENTS THAT WERE
SERVING.
SO ON IN THE EVENT OF AN
ACCIDENT THAT HAPPENS YOU KNOW
WE KNOW KIND OF LIKE.
WHAT CHEMICAL THREE HUNDRED
PERSON WAS EXPOSED TO AND IN MAY
SAVE HIS OR HER LIFE?
SO -- PLEASE HELP US PROVIDE A
SAFER MORE TRANSPARENT WORK
SPACE -- ALL THIS IN THE MAIL
INDUSTRY IN THE COMMUNITIES WE
SERVE.
SO I REGION PLEASE -- YES ON
EIGHTY SIX FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
OTHER FOLKS WANT TO VOICE THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
THE BILL OUT LEÓN BERMAN A
WORKING GROUP IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THERESA BREAKAGE ON BEHALF OF
THE LOCAL ADMINISTRATORS
ADVANCINGJUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
AND ALSO SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY IN SUPPORT.
OKAY -- SIX HONOREES CONCERNS
WITH THE OPPOSITION [INAUDIBLE]
YOU COMPARE.
THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS IMMEDIATELY
ON BEHALF OF THE PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS COUNCIL WE HAVE BEEN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
AND APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT.
THE AUTHOR DR TODAY IN
CLARIFYING THAT UNIVERSE OF
PRODUCTS THAT THIS BILL WOULD
IMPACT WE DO APPRECIATE THAT
AMENDMENT AND WE'VE BEEN -- THAT
ISONE OF OUR REQUEST FOR
AMENDMENTS WE HAVE BEEN IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE.
AND I THINK THEY'RE JUST A
COUPLE OF ITEMS THAT NEED TO BE
REFINED IN THE BILL AND THERE IS
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THAT TOOK
TO OUR MEMBERS READ.
AS THOUGH THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE MANUFACTURERS TO CREATE
AND TRANSLATE AND POST.
A DIFFERENT MSTS FOR EVERY SHADE
OR TENT -- I THINK THT IN OUR
CONVERSATIONS WE AUTHORS OFFICE
IT IS AT IT HE'S MADE CLEAR THAT
THAT'S NOT THE INTENTION OF THE
BILL HE ONLY WANTS US TO CREATE --
AND TRANSLATE IMPOSED A MSTS IF
ONE EXISTS FOR DIFFERENT COLOR
AND TEN WE'VE DISCUSSES IN THE
LAST POLICY COMMITTEE AND WE'RE
WORKING WITH HIM TO REFINE.
THAT LANGUAGE IN ORDER TO BE
CLEAR -- IN ADDITIONALLY WE ARE
ASKING FOR AND THE AUTHOR HAS A
VERBALLY AGREED TO US TO DELAY
THE IMPLEMENTATION DATE ONE YEAR
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS -- SO THAT WE CAN
TRANSLATE LITERALLY TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF SAFETY DATA SHEETS
AND HAVE THE CAPABILITY TO POST
THEM ONLINE.
OKAY OTHER FOLKS WANT TO RAISE
CONCERNS [INAUDIBLE]
LISTEN.
SHARE MEMBER SUGGESTED WITH
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT REALLY FOCUSES
ON AND AN ERROR ISSUE THAT WE
HAD -- SURROUNDING DISINFECTANTS
WE APPRECIATE THAT HAVE A
QUESTION LANGUAGE YET BUT
APPRECIATE THE WORK ON THAT AND
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS FROM.
OKAY PRODUCTS THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
OKAY -- TING OTHER COMMENTS FROM
THE PUBLIC LET'S BRING THIS BACK
TO COMMITTEE THAT'S QUESTIONS AS
AN ADULT.
AWARENESS THROUGH THE BILL I SAW
THIS BILL OR A I THINK IT'S A
GREAT BILL -- AND I AM THE DID I
NEEDED EVEN THE MINUTES THAT YOU
TOOK OR EVEN MAKE IT ALL BETTER --
SOMEBODY WHO WORKS WITH -- MSTS
IS ALL THE TIME MY OWN BUSINESS
I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
AND I THINK IT'S A GOOD FOR THE
EMPLOYEES AND AND ACTUALLY
DOLLARS TO TO KNOW -- MARGOT BY
THOSE PLACES IN MY EYES BURN
SOMETIME SO I KNOW THERE'S THEY
NEED TO KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON SO
APPRECIATE THIS BILL MOVE AS
THEY MOVE ALONG AND I APPRECIATE
MISLI AND OTHERS THAT.
HAVE A WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
OUR OFFICE AND AND WE'RE
CONFIDENT WE'LL BE ABLE TO
COMPROMISE ON SOME OF THOSE
MINOR -- THOSE LAST COUPLE
ISSUES WITH THAT ASPECT PASSED
FROM ABOUT.
OKAY WITH THAT WILL OPEN UP TO
VOTE AS EXCERPTED CORAL.
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB SIX FORTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
COMMITTEE.
ALLEN.
ALLEN HI FAITH [INAUDIBLE]
HILL [INAUDIBLE]
SKINNER [INAUDIBLE]
STERN.
DOLLY.
SALLY I WOULD CASKEY.
CASKEY AYE.
OKAY SO WE'LL KEEP THEIR OPEN
FOR THE MEMBERS THAT ON YOUR
PRESENT AYE IN SEVENTEEN IS AB
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO AN ACT REALLY
LODGING ESTABLISHMENTS THANK YOU.
PLASTIC BOTTLES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF THE
PROLIFERATION OF SINGLE USE
PLASTIC WASTE -- AS I KNOW --
YOU KNOW MISTER CHAIR IS HAVING
A DEVASTATING IMPACT ON OUR
ENVIRONMENT OVERWHELMING
LANDFILLS.
THOSE TINY PLASTIC SHAMPOO
BOTTLES ARE COMMON IN HOTEL
ROOMS REPRESENT A SIZEABLE
AMOUNT OF WAYS IT CAN BE EASILY
ELIMINATE TO MORE COST EFFECTIVE
AND ENVIRONMENTALLY.
FRIENDLY ALTERNATIVES ASSEMBLY
BILL THAT IS.
SIXTY TWO I WOULD RESTRICT
HOTELS AND OTHER LODGING
ESTABLISHMENTS AND PLACING SMALL
SINGLE USE BIOLAGE SHAMPOO
CONDITIONER AND SO -- IN GAS
ROOMS OR BATHROOMS BY GENERATE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE FOR LARGE
HOTELS AND JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR FOR HOTELS A FIFTY ROOMS
ARE LESS.
CALIFORNIA HOTEL LODGING
ASSOCIATION SUPPORTS SB ELEVEN
SIXTY TWO AND IT IS ABSOLUTELY
ALIGNED WITH THE INDUSTRIES.
EFFORTS TO MINIMIZE ITS
ENVIRONMENTAL FOOTPRINT SB
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO IS ALSO -- WHO
SUPPORTED BY NUMBER OF CLEAN
OCEAN ORGANIZATIONS A SUPPORT
ALL EFFORTS TO REDUCE PLASTIC
POLLUTION LIKE THIS BILL HELPS
TO DO?
WHEN YOU CONSIDER THE FACT THAT
EACH ROOM CAN GENERATE UP TO A
THOUSAND TINY BOTTLES PER YEAR?
THE AMOUNT OF PLASTIC WASTE ESTA
LANDFILLS WE ARE MOVING A
SIGNIFICANT -- IN CALIFORNIA
LOMA TALK ABOUT HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF BOTTLES EVERY YEAR --
AND IT'S NOT FEASIBLE FOR THESE
PLUS BOTTLES TO BE MANAGEMENT
CYCLE BECAUSE OUR SMALL SIZE AND
THE RESIDUAL PRODUCT LEFT IN THE
BOTTLES.
WITH ME IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IS ON CALDWELL ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA HOTEL LODGING
ASSOCIATION RESPECT US RIGHT
[INAUDIBLE]
JOHN TIME.
I KNOW CHAIR FOR AWHILE OKAY.
MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS LIKE JOHN CALDWELL --
CALIFORNIA HOTEL LODGING
ASSOCIATION WE'RE PROUD TO
SUPPORT AB.
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO NOW THE
INDUSTRY IS ALREADY TAKING
INNOVATIVE STEPS TO CREATE A
MORE SUSTAINABLE FUTURE AS WE
PUT IN OUR LETTER.
INTERCONTINENTAL HOTEL GROUPS IS
LISTED ON THE S. AND P. DOW
JONES SUSTAINABILITY INDEX HELP
HASREDUCE LANDFILL WASTE BY 41%
ACROSS MANAGED HOTEL SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT HI IT HAS
COMMITTED TO DIVERTING 40% OF
ITS WASTE FROM LANDFILLS BY THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY AND AS
YOU'RE NOT ANALYSIS POINTS OUT.
MARRIOTT ANNOUNCED PLANS TO
INSTALL FULL DISPENSERS IN FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY PROPERTIES
INCLUDING HIGH AND FACILITIES
LIKE REST OF RITZ CARLTON --
YEAH AND MERRY OUTS NOT ALONE
ALL ACROSS THE INDUSTRY -- FROM
OUR BED AND BREAKFAST TO OUR
ECONOMY HOTELS LUXURY HOTELS.
THEY'RE PHASING OUT THESE
PLASTIC BOTTLES -- WE SUPPORT AB
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS THE TIME NEEDED. FOR THIS
TRANSFORMATION AND IT DOES IT IN
A UNIFORM AND PREDICTABLE MANNER.
AND WE'D LIKE TO THANK -- THE
AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH US.
IN OUR MEMBER COMPANIES -- FOR
COMING UP WITH WITH -- A
BALANCED -- SB.
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO OKAY -- FOLKS
WANT REYES SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
VOICE SUPPORT.
HI I AM ANDREW VENTURE WITH
CLEAN WATER ACTION I WANT TO
APOLOGIZE WE DID NOT GET A
LETTER IN ON TIME ON THIS BILL
BUT WE DO SUPPORT IT AS WE
BELIEVE THAT SOURCE REDUCTION IS
REALLY THE KEY TO PLASTIC
POLLUTION SOLUTIONS AND SO WE
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS.
BILL.
REMEMBER TROUBLING AS WITH
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
HI BRANDY GARCIA WITH READING
GRAYSON SUPPORT.
Q..
FOREIGN COMMERCE HERE CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
NOW NICK CARTER PRESIDENT
FOUNDER CONNECTION EARTH IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
OKAY ARE OPPOSITION CONCERNS --
LET'S BE BACK TO ME AND BY THE
WAY THIS IS DOUBLE OR FOR IS
GOING OFF.
TO GOVERN FINANCE TRAVEL OR FOR
MY GOD.
THAT'S LACKEY MANTLE REFLECT.
IT'S A WONDERFUL THING OKAY IS
GONNA GET SO MUCH SO MUCH
EXAMINATION YES SO STRONG OKAY
MADAM I STIR.
JUST TWO QUESTIONS ARE ONE OF
HIS OF THE POTENTIAL FOR PENALTY
FINES.
THERE'S THAT MANY INTENDING TO
GO IN TERMS OF IMPROVING THE
ENVIRONMENT.
HOW DO YOU?
SEE THAT.
FUND DEVELOPING AND ITS USE.
OF MOBILE THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION MY MATTER BY CHER FIRST
OF ALL WE HOPE THAT THERE WON'T
BE A LOT OF OF FINES IMPOSED I
THINK AS MENTIONED BY THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE INDUSTRY.
THIS IS A DIRECTION THAT TO THE
INDUSTRY IS GOING IN AND SO IT'S
NOT.
AN INTENT -- TO TO TRY -- TO
ASSERT FINES AND SO I'M HOPEFUL
TO BE VERY VERY FEW FINDS
FRANKLY AND YEAH.
SO WHATEVER AGENCY IS THE ONE
THAT IS CERTAIN THE FINAL A
YOUNG GIRL WHO FOR CLASS
MINISTRY OF PEACE FOR DOING SO
AND SO -- THE ULTIMATELY -- THIS
IS NOT A ANY KIND OF SCHEME TO
RAISE FUNDS FOR CLEANING THE
OCEANS ARE CLEAN PLASTIC IT'S
REALLY A WAY TO KIND OF CHANGE
BEHAVIOR IN THE INDUSTRY
INTERACTION THERE ARE YOU GOING.
I THINK GOING FORWARD THAT NEEDS
TO BE A PRETTY CLEAR AND BECOME
SOME FINDS THAT.
ARE YOU KNOW ADMINISTERED AND
FOR A VIOLATION OF THIS SECONDLY
I HAPPEN TO LIVE IN A HOTEL.
THAT HAS THESE DISPENSERS THEY
ARE ACCESSIBLE BY. 8% -- IN THAT
ROOM AND FOR THAT REASON I HAVE
GREAT CONCERNS AROUND --
REGARDING THE PUBLIC SAFETY THAT
IS BEING PUT AT RISK.
PEOPLE WHO ARE JUST TENANTS IN
THE ROOM CAN ACCESS FEES
DISPENSERS THEY ALSO NEED TO BE
REFILLED YEAH I MEAN SOME OF
THIS IS A QUESTIONABLE REGARDING.
THE SAFETY THE THE CLEANLINESS
OF ALL OF THAT SO I'M NOT SURE
THAT WE WE REALLY THOUGHT
THROUGH.
CAREFULLY HOW THERE MIGHT BE
ANOTHER KIND OF JUST ANSWER
THAT'S MORE RECYCLABLE THAN
PLASTIC MIGHT BE A BETTER CHOICE.
WE'VE SEEN THE RE RUSHING TO
THERE SO I WON'T BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY.
BUT I HOPE THAT ARE -- YOU KNOW
OUR TOURIST INDUSTRY WILL THINK
ABOUT THAT.
ALL THOSE ARE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS THAT WE'VE HEARD THEM
JUST WITH THE PLASTIC BAGS THEY
CAN BE CONTAMINATED SO YOU'RE
ONLY SUPPOSED TO USE THEM ONE OR
TWO TIMES AND THEN DISPOSE OF
THEM.
WE HAVE THESE LARGE BOTTLES THAT
CONTAIN BODY LOTION CONDITIONER
AND SHAMPOO THEY'RE IN THEIR
PLASTIC SO THEY'RE GONNA BE
DISPOSED OF AWFUL.
SO -- I THINK THERE MIGHT BE A
BETTER ANSWER SOMEWHERE IN THERE --
AND I DON'T THINK THIS IS THIS
IS THE ANSWER FOR ME TODAY.
THANK.
THINK ABOUT MY SHIRT AND I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT THIS IS ALREADY A
COMMON PRACTICE WHETHER YOU GO
TO A JAM WITH YOU GO ON A CRUISE
SHIP WITH THE YOU GO TO MANY
HOTELS ARE READY -- I I I WOULD
TRUST THE INDUSTRY AND VERY OUT
FOR EXAMPLES AND HAVE TO TWO
HUNDRED PROPERTY BUT THERE'S AND
THIS YEAR THEY HAVE A LOT OF
LAWYERS HAVE A LOT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPERTS.
THAT ARE PART OF THE MARRIOTT
TEAM THAT I THINK THEY WOULDN'T
EVEN DARE TO STEP FORWARD IN ONE
HOTEL UNLESS THEY BOTH THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WOULD BE
SECURE BECAUSE IT'S THEIR
LIABILITY AT REST SO.
I ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE THAT WITH
THIS BILL WILL SEE IMPROVEMENTS
IN INNOVATION IN TERMS OF
SECURITY IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE
THAT THE PRODUCT IS SAFE FOR
EVERYONE TO USE.
THANK YOU -- OTHER QUESTIONS OR
THOUGHTS IN THE COMMITTEE ALL
RIGHT AND THE BILL'S REMOVED.
IF YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU
JOHN I APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE I THINK
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF STEPS
THAT ARE THE LOWER HANGING
FRUITS SO TO SPEAK.
THAT CAN ACHIEVE SOME OF THE
GOALS AND I KNOW THAT YOU SEEK
TO ACHIEVE AS A STATE.
THAT I WAS LIKE YEAH.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT AT BILLS
MOVE WESTBURY SO MEMBER CENTER
WE CASKEY -- SO TYPICAL.
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB ELEVEN
SIXTY TWO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE.
ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE AYE BATES NO
BATES NO HILL.
SKINNER.
STERN.
DOLLY MY CASKEY.
CASKEY I OKAY I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR MUCH WILDER OPENED FOR
FOLKS TO ADD ON OKAY -- WHAT'S
BEING WORKED OUT BY OUR ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS.
OKAY ALL RIGHT.
WELL YOU ARE YOU ARE HIGHER IN
THE LIST IN TERMS OF THE THE
FILE OR SO WHAT WE'LL ASK YOU TO
COME FORWARD -- MY CELL NUMBER --
AB EIGHT FIFTEEN THIS ITEM
FOURTEEN YOUR AGENDAS MEMBERS
THIS IS AN ACT RELATING.
TO INTEGRATED WITH MEASURE PLANS
AND I UNDERSTAND SOME
OPPOSITIONS THEY REMOVE THIS IS
JUST THAT.
ALL THIS OPPOSITION IS BEING
REMOVED REMOVED TODAY HAS
REWARDED A BILL HARD OKAY SO YOU
MAY PRESENT WHEN WHEN.
THE WHEN READY GREAT A GOOD
AFTERNOON.
I GUESS IT'S STILL MORNING SUSAN
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB EIGHT FIFTEEN ALLOWS
CAL RECYCLED TO CONSIDER WHETHER
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS
IMPLEMENTED A DUAL STREAMS AND
RECYCLING PROGRAM.
WHEN DETERMINING IF THEY MADE A
GOOD FAITH EFFORT TO MEET STATE
RECYCLING GOALS TOOL STREAM
PROGRAMS REQUIRE CURBSIDE
SEPARATION OFTEN KEEPING PAPER
SEPARATE FROM CONTAINERS? TO
REDUCE CONTAMINATION RATES IN
THE RECYCLING STREAM.
IN COMPARISON WHEN WE THROW AT
THE WHEN WE THROW ALL RECYCLES
IN THE SAME BEEN.
GLASS BREAKS LEFT OVER SO TO
SPILLS AND COPY PAPER AND
RECYCLED MATERIALS BECOME
CONTAMINATED.
CONTAMINATION REDUCES THE
QUALITY OF OUR RECYCLABLES
MAKING THEM DIFFICULT OR
IMPOSSIBLE TO RIP MARKET FOR RE
USE.
WE USED TO SEND OVER HAVE ARE
CONTAMINATED RECYCLES TO CHINA
WHERE THEY WERE FREQUENTLY
LANDFILLS ARE BURNED.
THE CHINA ISN'T TAKING ARE
CONTAMINATED RECYCLES ANYMORE.
STILL STREAM PROGRAMS KEEP
RECYCLED MATERIAL SEPARATED AND
CLEANER IN THE WASTE STREAM.
CLEAN STREAMS PROTECT THE
QUALITY AND THE VALUE OF ARE
RECYCLABLE SO THEY CAN BE SOLD
TO MAKE NEW PRODUCTS.
AB EIGHT FIFTEEN WILL ENCOURAGE
LOCALS WITH EXISTING DRAWSTRING
PROGRAMS TO CONTINUE OPERATING
THOSE PROGRAMS.
AND CONSIDER -- AND ENCOURAGE
OTHERS TO CONSIDER SWITCHING.
THIS BILL DOES NOT TAKE AWAY
LOCAL CONTROL OVER RECYCLING.
AND IT DOES NOT GIVE CAL RECYCLE
AUTHORITY TO WITHHOLD A GOOD
FAITH EFFORT DETERMINATION FROM
JURISDICTIONS.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE A BOOK
BUT DOLE STREAM.
THIS BILL RECEIVE UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
ASSEMBLY NATURAL SOURCES
COMMITTEE AND PASSED OFF THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR ON CONSENT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IBM.
THANK YOU.
YES FOLKS IN SUPPORT.
SORRY.
GIVE ME THAT IMPLY THAT MY
MICROPHONE PREMATURELY THERE ARE
THOSE THREATS.
MICRO HERE ON BEHALF THE GLASS
PACKAGING STUDENTS SCORED THE
BILL ON I THINK I'VE TOLD THIS
COMMITTEE MEANT MANY TIMES CLASS
GLASS BOTTLES ARE ABOUT THE MOST
RECYCLABLE -- MATERIAL COMMODITY
IN THE IN THE MARKET PLACE TO
RECYCLE NOT DOWN CYCLE THE GLASS
BOTTLE CAN BE 1% OF GLASS
BOTTLES.
IF IT'S PROPERLY HANDLED
RECYCLED AND THAT THE SINGLE
STREAM RECYCLING SYSTEM CURBSIDE
RECYCLING SYSTEM HASN'T BEEN
KIND TO CLASS OVER THE YEARS --
YOU GET GIVEN EVERYTHING THAT
THE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MET --
DISCUSSED ON ON CHINA NATIONAL
SORT IN AND THE AND THE
COMMODITY MARKET PLACE WE THINK
IT'S A GOOD A GOOD TIME TO START
ENCOURAGING TOLL FREE RECYCLING
IN.
THIS IS A VERY MODEST BILL THE
DOES SO AND AND JUST -- I WOULD
I JUST REFERRED TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- TO PAGE FOR THE
COMMITTEE NOW OR THE COMIC
NUMBER FORMED COMMITTEE NOW SAYS
WHICH DISCUSSES THE FACT THAT
THERE'S NOTHING IN THE STORE
THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
DISADVANTAGED A HOLLER OR
COMMUNITY AND AND AND IN.
REFER YOU TO THE ANALYSIS ON
THAT AND I CAN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT COME UP.
AND AS THE HEARING GOES OFF
THANKS THANK YOU.
OKAY -- FOLKS WANT TO VOICE
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
I COULD MORNING ACOSTA
CALIFORNIA'S GETS WASTE WE DON'T
HAVE OFFICIAL SUPPORT POSITION
BUT WE DEFINITELY SUPPORT THE
INTENT OF ENCOURAGING TO OCEAN
COLLECTION -- I THINK THAT THE
AUTHORS OR STAFF OF DONE A GREAT
JOB OF GETTING STAKEHOLDERS THE
OTHER FROM BOTH SIDES TRY.
TO WORK THROUGH SOME OF THE
ISSUES -- AND THERE'S DEFINITELY
A PATH THERE -- SO WE'LL WE'LL
FOR WORKING ON IT OVER THE
SUMMER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING TYLER
BLOCKING THE ONE IN CEDAR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
RESULTADOS HERE ON THE OFFICE
ALWAYS ASSOCIATION OF NORTH
AMERICA AND WESTERN PLASTER
WASTE MANAGEMENT THIRTY ONE
THINK THE AUTHOR AND HER STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US THAT'S FROM --
THIS PROCESS AND WE ARE -- AT
ABOUT THE AMENDMENTS THAT WILL
BE COMING IN AND WHIPS REMOVING
OUR OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
BY ANYONE ELSE.
REYES SUPPORT OR WINNERS --
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL CONCERNS.
YOU MAY COME UP.
MORNING MR SURE MEMBERS KELLY
ASTRON BEHALF OF THE LA COUNTY
WASTE MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION.
AND TO OTHER LOCAL REAL REGIONAL
ASSOCIATIONS WERE PART OF A
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED LETTER
THAT WAS SUBMITTED ON JUNE FIFTH
TO THE AUTHOR OF A COUPLE
COMMENTS.
I'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
REPRESENTING WASTE COLLECTION
AND RECYCLING FIRMS FOR THIRTY
SIX YEARS -- I KNOWN OBJECTIVE --
ANALYSIS WHEN I SEE WHEN I WANT
TO COMMEND COMMITTEE STAFFER
WHAT I THOUGHT WAS A VERY.
FAIR AND BALANCED ASSESSMENT OF
THE ISSUE.
THE ISSUE OF DUAL STREAM IS A
LITTLE BIT COMPLICATED -- WE
HAVE BY CAL RECYCLES BEST
ESTIMATE FROM WHAT THEY TELL ME
ABOUT TWENTY ONE JURISDICTIONS
IMPLYING THIS PARTICULAR
TECHNOLOGY TODAY.
WHICH MEANS THE MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
DON'T.
SOME OF THE BEEN MIGRATED AS I
THINK PAGE SIX OF THE ANALYSIS
REFLECTS.
FROM DUAL STREAM TO A SINGLE
STREAM FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS.
I AM WILLING TO CONCEDE TO THE
COMMITTEE TODAY THE DUAL STREAM
CAN YIELD.
AN OUTCOME THAT RESULTS IN LESS
CONTAMINATION BUT THAT'S NOT THE
ONLY THING WE LOOK AT WHEN WE
BUILT THE MULTI BILLION DOLLAR.
WASTE RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT EXISTS TODAY IT'S ALSO
ABOUT VOLUME.
AND MOVING A HECK OF A LOT OF
MATERIAL THROUGH THE PRIOR TO
NINETEEN NINETY WAS NOT GETTING
RECYCLED AT ALL.
SO WERE CONFRONTED WITH IS THIS.
HUNDREDS OF HOLDERS OF
CONSIDERED AND REJECTED BY IN BY
NOT IMPLEMENTING THIS SYSTEM IN
FAVOR OF ANOTHER SYSTEM.
NOW RESPONSE I GET TO THAT IS
WHAT THIS BILL DOESN'T COMPEL
ANYTHING.
BUT A COUPLE OF THINGS ARE ALSO
TRUE.
NOTHING PROHIBITS THE CITY OR
COUNTY FROM ADOPTING DUAL STREAM
RECYCLING TODAY AND A HANDFUL
HAVE.
NOTHING PREVENTS CAL RECITE FROM
CONSIDERING DAHLE STREAM
RECYCLING AS PART OF A GOOD
FAITH EFFORT TERMINATION TODAY
WITHOUT EXPRESSLY CALLING ON THE
CRITERIA.
AND WHAT EIGHT FIFTEEN DOES IS
IT BREAKS NEW GROUND BY SAYING
NO THE EXISTING -- BUT BY SAYING
THAT THIS PARTICULAR CRITERIA IT
MERITS BEING CALLED OUT WHEN
NONE OF THE OTHER CRITERIA FOR A
GOOD FAITH EFFORT TO TERMINATION
INVOLVES AN OPERATIONAL DECISION.
ABOUT WHAT SPECIFIC TECHNOLOGY
TO USE.
WE WOULD ALSO RESPECTFULLY
SUBMIT THERE IS INSUFFICIENT
EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT INCENTIVIZE
INDUSTRY BUT THIS TIME WE NEED
TO STUDY IT GOES BEYOND.
THE VERY ANECDOTAL INFORMATION
THAT'S AVAILABLE TODAY SOMETHING
THAT MAKES ACCOUNT FOR THE FACT
THAT NOT JUST WEALTHY.
COMMUNITIES WITH A HOMOGENEOUS
POPULATION CAN IMPLEMENT TO
SUCCESSFULLY THAT ALSO WORK IN
RIALTO THAT WILL ALSO WORK IN
RIVERSIDE -- OR 95% THIS STATE
THAT DOESN'T CURRENTLY USES SO
WE'RE NOT AGAINST IT WE WE WOULD
BECOME CONCERNED WITH A
PARTICULAR -- AND TO THIS.
EXTENT UNPOPULAR A METHODOLOGY
GAINES AN INCENTIVE AND WHY DO
WE CARE.
BECAUSE INCENTIVES HAVE A NASTY
HABIT OF BECOMING PREFERENCES
AND FROM PURPOSES IT BECOME
GOALS AND GOALS A BECOME
MANDATES.
WE ARE VERY MUCH OPEN AS AN
INDUSTRY TO HAVING A THOUGHTFUL
CONVERSATION ON THE ISSUE WE'RE
VERY MUCH OPEN TO A STUDY.
THAT LOOKS AT DIVERSE AREAS OF
THE STATE.
BUT AT THE TIME WHEN WHEN OUR
FOLKS ARE TRYING TO DEFEND THE
CURRENT OPERATION GROWN EXPAND
THEIR FACILITIES.
THE IDEA THAT THESE STATES GOING
TO SUBSIDIZE OWN JUDGMENT WHEN
THERE ISN'T EVEN AMPLE EVIDENCE
TO SUPPORT THIS AS BEING A
PREFERRED TECHNOLOGY WE THINK
IT'S ON WHY STEP WE DO ON THE
OTHER HAND. ONE RECOGNIZE
SOMETHING VERY POSITIVE ABOUT
THIS BILL.
I SPENT THE BETTER PART OF LAST
YEAR TRYING TO GET.
THE LEGISLATURE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT WE HAD A PROBLEM WITH
NATIONAL SORT.
AND SO HE IDEATHAT THIS AUTHOR
HAS DECIDED TO TAKE UP SOME OF
THAT MANTLE IS VERY PLEASING TO
US WE WERE MUCH WE'RE ALSO
GRATEFUL FOR THE EXTRAORDINARY
EFFORT PUT FORWARD BY HER STEP
IN TRYING TO REACH A COMPROMISE.
I THINK I SAID DURING BACK HERE.
WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME ON THIS
WE'RE JUST NOT THERE YET SO
WE'RE GONNA HEAR WILL MOVE THE
BILL FORWARD AND I UNDERSTAND
ALL THAT BUT I'D SURE LIKE THIS
FIXED.
BECAUSE I HATE TO SEE RECYCLERS
DEBATING EACH OTHER ABOUT WHICH
TECHNOLOGY OUGHT TO BE PREFERRED
LET'S GET BETTER INFORMATION AS
TO A COMPREHENSIVE STUDY AND
THEN WE CAN TALK ABOUT WHETHER
GOOD FAITH EFFORT.
CRITERIA SHOULD OR SHOULD NOT BE
MODIFIED THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND I'M ALSO AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL
THIS MONEY SHOULD THAT
[INAUDIBLE]
OKAY -- I MEAN I DO WHAT I WILL.
YOU KNOW SAY THAT IN THE END OF
THE DAY.
THE BILL IS ASKING FOR CAROL TO
CONSIDER -- YEAH SO IT'S IT'S
NOT A IT'S NOT DISPOSITIVE I I
GET THAT THERE'S A CONCERN ABOUT
THE SLIPPERY SLOPE BUT YOU KNOW
YOU CAN MAKE THAT ARGUMENT ABOUT
NEARLY ANY BILL THAT PASSED IN
THIS LEGISLATURE -- SO. FIVE
WITH THAT I'M I'M CERTAINLY --
AFTER WITH THE BILL TODAY.
IN PASSING ON TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE BILL IT'S PRETTY BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE AND THAT'S OUR
OTHER FOLKS WANNA RAISE CONCERNS
OPPOSITION.
OKAY -- TELECAST I GUESS -- ALAS
THE AUTHOR'S DATA SUPPORTING THE
CHANGE AND OTHERS A MILL VALLEY
PILOT PROGRAM IS THAT.
TRANSFERABLE TO LA AND WHAT WE
HAVE ON THE DATA.
AGENDA WELL FIRST OF ALL THERE
ARE -- TWENTY ONE JURISDICTIONS
THAT USE DUAL STREAM TODAY SO WE
DO HAVE SOME DATA THAT'S OUT
THERE -- MILL VALLEY DID DO A A
PILOT PROGRAM THAT THEY DEEMED
VERY SUCCESSFUL YES IS IT A MORE
LEAGUE MAYBE COMMUNITY THAN
OTHERS BUT WE GOT TO START
SOMEWHERE AND I THINK THAT WE
HAVE REALLY GOOD EXAMPLES WHEN
YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THE OTHER
JUPITER'S.
JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE USING IT
NOW.
REMEMBER IS THAT I'M MY HEART
GOES OUT BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE
GONE DOWN ONE OF PATH ARE
RECYCLERS WHEN I WENT TO SINGLE
STREAM.
AND NOW SWITCHED TO DUAL STREAM --
WE'RE GIVING THE LOCALS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SIDE WHICH WHICH
WAY THEY WANT TO GO -- AND I
THINK IT IF YOU'VE EVER BEEN TO
A LANDFILL RECENTLY WE'VE GOT TO
DO SOMETHING.
AND NOT USING THESE RECYCLABLE
MATERIALS FOR OTHER PRODUCTS IS --
A COMMENDABLE FOR US TO TO GO
DOWN THAT ROUTE AND WHO WOULDN'T
ON WE WOULD HAVE BEEN DOWN THIS
GOING DOWN THIS PATH. FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO BUT WE ARE.
AND WE NEED TO START SOMEWHERE
SO.
I GUESS I GUESS THEY FOLLOW UP
MISTER CHAIR IS IS COULD THIS.
CITIES CAN THIS LEAD. TO TO
CONTAMINATED PENS THAT WE HAVE
IF THE IF THE INDIVIDUALS TO
HOMEOWNERS OUT DON'T.
HAVE PRACTICE THE BEST PRACTICES
I MEAN I KOW THAT'S A PROBLEM
WITH THE CURRENTLY WHAT WE HAVE
A CONTAMINATED AND WE JUST.
DUPLICATING THE SAME PROBLEM.
WITHOUT THE EDUCATION
[INAUDIBLE]
I MEAN.
SURE IF THE M. YOU GUESS YOU
COULD SAY THAT IS THAT THAT.
CONSUMERS ARE GONNA BE LAZY
THEY'RE GONNA BE LAZY AND WITH.
THE THE FACT IS UNIT IN. TWO
MINUTES ACTUALLY HELP HELP THE
EDUCATION SO.
YOU KNOW TO BE A BE A LOT EASIER
IF YOU'RE CONSUMER YOU'RE NOT
GONNA HAVE TO GAS AT WHAT IS IT.
WHAT GOES INTO WHAT BEEN AT WORK --
FORECAST WEATHER STEVEN
RECYCLABLE YOU'LL NOTICE
RECYCLABLE BECAUSE A GLASS
BOTTLE IS RECYCLABLE.
IS A IS A IS A DIRTY PIZZA
CARTON RECYCLABLE WILL NOW AND
IT SHOULDN'T GO ANY IT SHOULDN'T
GO IN EITHER BEEN AND SHOULD GO
IN THE GARBAGE BUT YOU KNOW --
AND AND JUST ON THE ON ON ON THE
STUDIES -- I I MEAN OBVIOUSLY
THAT THE WASTE INDUSTRIES GONNA
KNOW THIS BETTER THAN I DO --
THE THE WASTE INDUSTRY HAS KNOWN
THE PROBLEM OF OF OF THE AFTER
MARKET OF OF THE OF THE OF THE
CURBSIDE.
AMINATION PROBABLY GONNA FOR A
LONG TIME IT JUST HASN'T
MATTERED IT NOW MATTERS AND SO
IF THEY IF IF IF IF THEY WERE
PAIRED TO DEAL WITH THIS ON
THEIR OWN.
AND AND IN TWENTY TWELVE OR
TWENTY THIRTEEN WHEN THAT WIND
WHEN CHINA OPERATED THE YOU KNOW
PUT IN GREEN FENCE.
WE WOULD BE HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION BUT YOU KNOW THEY'RE
THEY'RE MOVING SLOW AND AND
NOBODY'S EXPECTING ANYTHING TO
HAPPEN OVERNIGHT NOBODY'S GONNA
IS EXPECTING ANYTHING GIVEN THE
DISADVANTAGES.
IS AN ENCOURAGEMENT TO FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION WITH THEIR HOLLERS AND
AND WITH THEIR MURDERS ON
CONTRACTS AND THEY'RE GONNA
RENEW OVER THE NEXT YOU KNOW TEN
FIFTEEN YEARS AND AND AND AND
IT'LL ALL IT'LL IT'LL SORT
ITSELF OUT OF THE LOCAL LEVEL
CAN SOME.
VERY MODEST BILL THAT ENCOURAGES.
YOU KNOW THE IDEA OF DAHLE FREE
RECYCLING IN EVERYBODY WILL DO
THEIR OWN STUDY WHEN THEY MAKE
THAT DECISION AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
[INAUDIBLE]
MR. THREE CHAIR IF IF AFTER THE
SALE IS OUR GUEST.
I'M SURE THAT THE WASTE
INDUSTRIES VERY GRATEFUL TO THE
GLASS INDUSTRY FOR HELPING US
FIGURE OUT OUR JOB.
OF LET ME SAY THIS IF ONE BILLS
OF MATERIALS RECOVERY FACILITY
TODAY TO MANAGE JUST MATERIAL
ONE'S GOING TO SPEND ON THE
ORDER OF TWENTY TO THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS ON AVERAGE.
THAT IS PAID FOR OVER A TERM
THAT APPROXIMATES TWENTY TO
THIRTY YEARS TO LESSEN THE
IMPACT ON RATE PAYERS.
THOSE FACILITIES ARE OPERATED
BASED ON PRE TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN PRE GREEN FENCE
TECHNOLOGY.
MASSIVE THROUGHPUT EXTRAORDINARY
CONTENT EXTRAORDINARY A
COLLECTION RESULTS OR AND
RECOVERY RESULTS BUT NOT AS GOOD
IF WE SLOWED EVERYTHING DOWN.
PICKED IT UP ITEM BY ITEM AND
SPENT TWO OR THREE HUNDRED BUCKS
A MONTH ON EACH HOUSE RECYCLING
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT WITH
THE EFFICIENCIES WERE BROUGHT TO
BEAR IS RESULT OF NINE THIRTY
NINE WE LOST A LITTLE SOMETHING
IN TERMS OF CONTAMINATION BUT WE
PICKED UP EXTRAORDINARY GAINS.
IN TERMS OVER OVERALL VOLUME IN
CHINA IN THE FAR EAST WERE
ACCEPTING ALL OF THIS JUST THE
WHAT.
WE WE PROCESS TO THE DEGREE THAT
THE MARKET WILL BEAR THE MARKET
BOARD UNTIL A YEAR AGO SO WE ALL
ACKNOWLEDGE WE'RE DIFFERENT
STATE OF AFFAIRS NOW WE'RE
ADJUSTING TO THAT.
BUT THE IDEA THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS GOING TO STEP IN
WITH A PREFERENCE OR INSTEAD OF
GETS ITS DECIDED.
BASED ON I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE
STUDY. ONE OF THE THREE STUDIES
CITED TO ME SAMPLE THIRTEEN OF A
HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN MERSON
CALIFORNIA REALLY.
ARE WE PREPARED TO GO THERE YET
ON THAT STUDY MILL VALLEY I WISH
I LIVED THERE WILL MOST
BEAUTIFUL PLACES IN THE WORLD.
BUT THE IDEA THAT THERE AT ALL
REPRESENTATIVE OF WHAT THE
INDUSTRY NEEDS TO DEAR WHAT
OTHER CITIES WITH DIFFERENT
CONSTRAINTS ARE GONNA BE ABLE TO
DO.
SLAP OPAL.
END OF THE STUDY OUT OF ONTARIO
CANADA.
I READ THE AT LEAST THE
EXECUTIVE SUMMARY THAT I'VE GOT-MY PEOPLE LOOKING AT IT.
UNDERSTAND ONE THING AND ALL
STOP TALKING [INAUDIBLE]
ENTREPRENEURS.
ISN'T THERE ARE LEFT IN THE
POSITION OF GREATEST RISK IF
THEY MAKE THE WRONG CHOICE.
THEY WANT MORE THAN ANYBODY SO
IT'S NOT EVEN JUST ALTRUISM ON
THEIR PART IT'S THE ECONOMIC
REALITY UP IF THEY DON'T DELIVER
THE OUTCOMES THAT ARE REQUIRED
THE LOSE THE CONTRACT THEY DON'T
GET TO REPAY THE BOND ON THE
FACILITY IT'S IS NO MORE
COMPLICATED THAN THAT.
IF THIS WERE THE ANSWER THEY'D
BE DOING IT FIVE HUNDRED PLUS
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE NOT YET
DOING IT.
SHOULD THEY MIGRATE TO THAT
PERHAPS LET'S HAVE A
CONVERSATION THAT STUDY BUT TO
START OURSELVES DOWN THE PATH
BECAUSE GLASS FEELS IT'S A GOOD
IDEA.
BY THE WAY THE DEFINITION OF
DUAL STREAMING HERE DON'T EVEN
MENTION GLASS THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT REMOVING PAPER.
AND SEPARATELY DEALING WITH THAT
PAPER DOES NOT AND TO
CONTAMINATE GLASS THAT'S NOT
THEIR ISSUE.
THERE ISSUES BOTTLE CAPS AND A
HOST OF OTHER THINGS WE CAN GET
CLEANER WE CAN DO A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS BUT WE'RE
JUMPING THE GUN HERE THE
EVIDENCE IS NOT IN THE BILL'S TO
THAT EXTENT.
PREMATURE THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR I'D LIKE TO MOVE TO
BILL AND I WOULD HOPE THAT THE
INDUSTRY THAT ONCE CLEANER
COLLECT COULD.
WORK WITH US TO GET THE SPIRITS
IN THE WIND INDUSTRY IN THE
BOTTLE BILLS.
ALL PARTICIPATING EQUALLY --
WORK AS A BETTER STREAM SO WITH
THAT ALMOST.
I KNOW THAT JOBS OFFICES WORKING
WITH OPPOSITION ON SNAPCHAT LE
LET RULING SOME ISSUES AND REYES
MEANING THAT WOULD CERTAINLY BE
HELPFUL ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
FACT THAT.
I THINK SOME OF YOUR CONCERNS.
ARE VERY LEGITIMATE BUT THEIR
THEIR BROADER THAN THE THE
BIGGER THE SCOPE OF THE BILL
THEN THE SCOPE OF THE WILL BILLS
WRITTEN SO -- WITHOUT I'M
CERTAINLY COMFORTABLE FOR THAT
MISSED MINIMIZED HER I JUST WANT
TO THINK OF THE REPRESENTATIVE
FOR THE RECYCLING INDUSTRY ON
THAT I THINK HE'S RAPPORT THE
CONCERNS THAT I WOULD HAVE FOR
MY SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY.
WE STARTED THE NUMBER.
RIGHT OUT WE WERE NEWLY
INCORPORATED CITIES.
BASED ON WHAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
DO WE'VE BEEN MEETING OUR
REQUIREMENT AND I'M CONCERNED
THAT WITH THE PRESCRIPTIVE
NATURE OF THE FROM THE AND
SENTENCE OF DEATH.
THAT COULD START TO CAUSE CITIES
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT RIGHT
NOW ABOUT THIRTY FOUR CITIES IN
ORANGE COUNTY THAT COULD BE
AFFECTED.
WITH FIVE NEW REQUIREMENTS AND
NOT MEETING -- DIVERSION SO
MAYBE A SLOWER PACE WITH SOME OF
THE CONCERNS THAT MR ANSWERS
ROUTE FORWARD -- REALLY MERIT --
CONSIDERATION AS THIS MOVES
FORWARD SO I WON'T BE SUPPORTING
IT TODAY -- BUT I WANT YOU KNOW
INCORPORATING WITHIN THE GAL
THIRTY YEARS AGO WHICH I WAS
VERY INVOLVED WITH WE'VE DONE A
HECK OF A JOB ON DEATH AND ARE
CITIES IN THE EDUCATION THAT'S
GONNA IS MEN INCREDIBLE.
SO WHERE EDUCATION NEED FOR THE
LAWN WE NEED TO GIVE THE
RECYCLING INDUSTRY A LITTLE MORE
TIME.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THE COST OF
INFRASTRUCTURE I THINK ABOUT THE
MATCH THAT I'VE VISITED.
THAT WOULD BE ON PUT ON RATE
PAYERS -- BECAUSE THAT'S THE WAY
IT WOULD HAVE TO GO AND SOME NOT
CONTINUE IN THEIR CONTRACTS
BECAUSE OF THAT.
SO THERE ARE CONCERNS
SIGNIFICANT ONES BUT SOUNDS TO
ME LIKE YOU'RE ALL AT THE TABLE
YOU'RE GONNA POUNDED OUT TODAY
I'M GONNA WAY ON THE SIDE OF MY
MY DISTRICT AND MY PEOPLE WHO
WOULD BE SIGNIFICANTLY AFFECTED
IF THIS.
CAME OUT SOMETHING IMMEDIATE HIM
DOWN THEY START -- WITH THEIR
CONTRACT THAT ARE COMING UP THEY
WOULD HAVE A LOT OF CONCERNS SO.
WITHOUT GETTING.
RIGHT THANK YOU.
IT'S STILL A LOT OF WORK TO BE
DONE -- BROADLY SPEAKING BUT AND
I WATCH ON LIKE LAUGH GOOD.
GOOD GOOD GOOD -- SO THE BILL'S
MOVE YOU MAY CLOSE -- I JUST
WANNA REMIND EVERYONE -- THIS
BILL ONLY REQUIRES CAL RECYCLE
TO CONSIDER.
WHETHER THE JURISDICTION HAS A
DUAL STREAM RECYCLING PROGRAM
SUCH AS THE EXTENT TO WHICH THE
JURISDICTION IMPLEMENTED
ADDITIONAL RESOURCE REDUCTION.
RECYCLING AND COMPOSTING
COMPOSTING ACTIVITIES OR THE
EXTENT TO WHICH THAT
JURISDICTION HAS MAY PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION CHOICES DRIVEN BY
CONSIDERATIONS RELATED TO OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES INCLUDING
CLIMATE CHANGE -- I UNDERSTAND
YOUR CONCERN A SENATOR -- I
THINK WE NEED TO MAKE A CHANGE
NOW START YOUR COMMUNITY MAYBE
DOING IT BUT WE HAVE MANY OTHERS
THAT WANT TO GET ON BOARD.
AND I THINK THIS IS A THE BILL
TO GET THEM THE FRAME WORK TO DO
GOOD TO GO FOR IT -- DO WE NEED
OTHER BILLS PROBABLY IN THE
FUTURE PROBABLY YES BUT THIS IS
THE THE BEGINNING SO I
APPRECIATE COMMENTS AND I SIMPLY
ASKED RIVALS.
ARE THOSE MOVED BY.
CENTER CASKEY -- IT IS.
I DO PASSED TO CENTER
PREPARATIONS OUT THE RIGHT I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S STILL SOME
WORK BEING DONE ON THE TENT
LANGUAGE AND AND OTHER -- SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB EIGHT
FIFTEEN THE COMMISSION IS DUE
PASSED THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
ALLEN HI ALLEN THANK BATES NO.
NO HILL.
INNER.
STERN DOLLY.
I CASKEY HI MY CASKEY I OKAY SO
WE LOOK ROLL OPEN ON THAT AND TO
PURSUE DIFFERENCE INVOLVEMENT
AND TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SOME MEMBER OKAY THAT'S FINE NOW
I THINK -- SUMMER CERVANTES IS
NEXT IN LINE -- WAS VERY PATIENT
WITH.
THE P. MOST PATIENT ONE HERE I
GOT TO SAY IS IS IN A RARE.
THOUGH SAYS AMERICA SURVIVE THIS
DID.
THEY DID GIVE WAY TO AS A MEMBER
KALRA THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
WAS VERY KIND OF YOU SOLICIT
YOUR HERE NEXT ITEM NINE THIS IS
AB SIX THIRTY NINE IN YOUR
POCKETS MEMBERS YES -- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND SENATORS LET ME
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS RECOMMENDED IN COMMON
THREE THE BILL ANALYSIS AFTER
SPEAKING WITH YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF AND THE STAFF IN THE
SENATE GEO WAS RECOMMENDED THAT
THE AMENDMENTS BE ADDED IN
APPROPRIATIONS.
I AB SIX THREE NINE I'M HERE TO
PRESENT TODAY AS WE KNOW THE
STATE IS CURRENTLY IN THE
PROCESS OF TRANSITIONING TO A
LOWER CARBON ECONOMY INCLUDING
THE TRANSFORMING.
INCLUDING TRANSFORMING THE
STATE'S GOODS MOVEMENT SYSTEM
WHAT CALIFORNIA HAS MADE
REMARKABLE PROGRESS ON REDUCING
HARMFUL GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
THE STATE HAS FAILED TO ADDRESS
THE IMPACT OF THESE ACTIONS.
ON CURRENT WORKERS AB SIX THREE
NINE REQUIRES ACALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCE BOARD WHEN UPDATING THE
G. H. G. SCOPING PLAN TRY DENNIS
FIND RECOMMEND ACTIONS TO
MITIGATE THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON
INCUMBENT WORKERS.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS ONE OF THE
STATE'S MOST PRESSING NEEDS THE
BILL ALSO ESTABLISHES A TASK
FORCE TO ADVISE THE STATE
AGENCIES ON POLICIES AND FUNDING
TO MITIGATE THE EMPLOYMENT.
I. IMPACTS OF TRANSITIONING SEE
PARK OPERATIONS TO ZERO AND NEAR
ZERO EMISSIONS SB SIX THREE NINE
WILL HELP CALIFORNIA DEVELOP AN
EQUITABLE GAME PLAN THAT
SUPPORTS AN INCLUSIVE ECONOMY.
AND UPWARD MOBILITY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS WATCH TV LOWER
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS MARVIN
BEING THE OTHER I REPRESENTING
AYALA W. YOU THE INTERNATIONAL%
LONGSHOREMEN AND WORKERS UNION.
FOR OUR WITH I THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRINGING
DOES MEASURE FORWARD.
AS HE AS AS SOME OF YOU KNOW
PORTS ARE -- THAT.
TARGETS FOR FULLY AUTOMATING I'D
TERMINALS. ONE TERMINAL WILL
PRIDE AT HUNDREDS OF WORKERS OUT
OF A JOB.
I WILL BE FINE THAT -- W.
SUPPORTS I'M ASKING OUR
ENVIRONMENTS WE WORK AND LIVE IN
THOSE ENVIRONMENTS WE WANT CLEAN
AIR WE SUPPORT -- CHOIRS GOAL OF
HAVING EQUIPMENT BE ZERO NEARS
YOUR MISSION BY -- TWENTY THIRTY
WE WE UNDERSTAND THAT WERE IN
THAT TIME WHERE.
WE CLIMATE CHANGE IS AFFECTING
US OUT WE THAT PUTS THE WORKERS
IN THE MIDDLE OF AT AT IN
ENVIRONMENT POLICIES AND
AUTOMATION WE THINK THERE'S A
MIDDLE GROUND HERE.
AND THAT MIDDLE GROUND IS THAT --
WHILE ITEM NATION IT'S COMING WE
CAN STOP BY AUTOMATION THERE IS
A MIDDLE GROUND WHERE STATE SOME
OF THE JOBS COULD BE
TRANSPORTATION.
I SOME OF THIS I WISH YOU COULD
DO THE MAINS FOR THE EQUIPMENT
AND KEEP SOME OF THE JOBS.
OR ARE WE NEED STATE FUNDING FOR
JOB TRAINING FOR THIS SO WE
THINK THAT FAMILY MEMBER BECAUSE
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IMPACTS
THE PORTS.
AND IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR OUR W.
YOU AS WE DON'T WANT COMMUNITIES
TO BE COMPLETELY AUTOMATED.
AND HOW THE DETROIT AND SOME
MORE PER COMMUNITIES WHERE YOU
DON'T HAVE BUSINESS ARE REAL
ESTATE AGENTS THEY COULD SELL.
OUT PROPERTIES TO HELP STOP
PROPERTIES TO FOLKS WE SUPPORT
THE BILL -- AND WE ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE [INAUDIBLE]
OKAY.
FIVE STAFF OKAY EXCELLENT --
OTHER FOLKS WANT TO RAISE
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL OR EXPRESS
SUPPORT.
HE WON ONCE A EXPRESS OPPOSITION
CONCERNS.
AN INTERNAL RODRIGUEZ FROM SAN
JOSE IN A SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
I ANYONE ELSE WANNA MAKE
COMMENTS BY THEN SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION.
THE MAN THAT MATTER IS NOW
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS THOUGHTS CONCERNS MOVE
BY OUR VICE CHAIR.
SEE NORTHERN CONSERVE QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY CLOSE SOONER.
MISTER CHAIR SENATORS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
OKAY -- SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL TO MOVE AYE RESTER.
ITEM NUMBER NINE EIGHTY SIX
THIRTY NINE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE GOVERNMENTAL.
ORGANIZATION.
ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE BATES RIGHT
BATES AYE HILL.
SKINNER STERN.
DOLLY.
DOLLY I LIKE TO ASK.
OKAY WILL BE THAT OPEN FOR OTHER
FOLKS THAT I THINK.
OKAY I THINK IS A MEMBER
FRIEDMAN I DIDN'T I YOU'RE HERE.
ACCORDING ITEM SEVEN THIS IS AB.
TWO EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR A COMMITTEE MEMBERS I A
FIRST WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND HIS STAFF FOR THE WORK THAT
THEY PUT INTO THIS BILL.
AB TWO EIGHTY FIVE UPDATES
CALIFORNIANS LONG TERM
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
DOCUMENTS TO INCORPORATE THE
STATE'S CURRENT GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION REDUCTION GOALS SUCH AS
SB THIRTY TWO AND OUR AIR
QUALITY GOALS.
WE HAVE A LOT OF OTHER AGENCIES
THAT IMPACT AIR QUALITY AND
EMISSIONS THAT HAVE BEEN --
BEING THOSE GOALS IN MIND WHEN
THEY DO THEIR PLANNING BUT
UNFORTUNATELY OUR TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR HAS BEEN GOING IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION WHEN IT COMES TO
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS WITH
EMISSIONS ACTUALLY INCREASING
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- THIS
BILL SEEKS TO MAKE SURE THAT ARE
PLANNING AGENCIES INCORPORATE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION AS PART
OF THEIR PLANNING PROCESS.
I'M THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE TOOK
INSTEAD OF TRANSPORTATION
REQUIRE THAT OP REPORT ON THE
PROGRESS THAT CAL CHANCES
CALTRANS HAS MADE.
I'M IMPLEMENTING PLAST
TRANSPORTATION PLANS.
IT'S MY CONTENTION THAT OUR
AGENCY SHOULD BE HELD. TO TASK
AND THEY SHOULD HAVE TO COMPLY
WITH THE GOALS THAT WE AS A
LEGISLATURE HAS SAT CALTRANS HAS
FAILED TO DO THAT AND THIS BILL
SEEKS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY DO.
I ENACT THE GOALS THAT WE HAVE
ALL -- ASKED OUR AGENCIES TO DO
WITH ME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AS
WELL BEAR IT WITH THE AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION.
I'M AND I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT THIS BILL AB TWO EIGHTY
FIVE HAS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING I'M WILL BEAR IT
WITH THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION SUPPORTS AB TWO
EIGHTY FIVE AS A COMMON SENSE OF
STATE. TO THE REQUIREMENTS IN
OUR STATE TRANSPORTATION PLANS.
ONE CESSATIONS TWENTY NINETEEN
STATE OF THE ERROR REPORT FOUND
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS SEVEN OF THE
TEN MOST POLLUTED.
IN THE UNITED STATES BY OZONE
AND THAT CLIMATE CHANGE IS
MAKING THE JOB OF CLEANING UP
OUR AIR THAT MUCH MORE DIFFICULT.
TRANSPORTATION SOURCES ARE THE
DOMINANT SOURCE OF ON HEALTHCARE
AND GREENHOUSE GASES IN
CALIFORNIA.
THESE POLLUTANTS CONTRIBUTE TO
ASTHMA ATTACKS CANCERS HEART
ATTACKS IN A WIDE AND GROWING
RANGE OF CLIMATE CHANGE HEALTH
IMPACTS.
AB TWO EIGHTY FIVE ENSURES THAT
THE STATE TRANSPORTATION PLANS
ACCOUNT FOR TREATMENT OF STATE
AND FEDERAL.
POLLUTION REDUCTION REQUIREMENTS
INTERSTATE GREENHOUSE GAS
STANDARDS.
GIVEN THE TRANSPORTATION CARBON
POLLUTION IS INCREASING AB TWO
EIGHTY FIVE REQUIRES AN
ASSESSMENT OF REGIONAL%
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY STRATEGIES
AND EVALUATION OF HOW THOSE
PLANS.
INTERACT WITH OUR OVERALL
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
THIS IS A CRITICAL ELEMENT OF
OUR TRANSPORTATION AND POLLUTION
REDUCTION PLANNING SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA AND MUST BE PART OF
OUR LONG TERM PLANNING PROCESSES.
AB TWO EIGHTY FIVE ALSO REQUIRES
CONSIDERATION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE CONCERNS WITHIN THE
PLANS IN RECOGNITION THAT MANY
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES.
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY.
USING DISPROPORTIONATELY AND
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY
TRANSPORTATION DECISIONS AND THE
ASSOCIATED AIR POLLUTION IMPACTS.
GIVEN THE URGENCY TO ALIGN OUR
TRANSPORTATION DECISIONS AND
INVESTMENTS WITH.
THE TREATMENT OF CLEAN AIR
PUBLIC HEALTH PUBLIC HEALTH
EQUITY ENVIRONMENTAL AND
MOBILITY GOALS WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE MEASURE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
YOUR MEMBERS TRUST BUCKLEY ON
BEHALF OF SOUTH BECAUSE IT CAN
BE IN SUPPORT.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS NIKITA CRIED
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
AARON TAYLOR ON BEHALF OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON IN
SUPPORT. ONE CALL WAS SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
HI IN SUPPORT.
YEAH QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR YES
FOR ME A MEMBER OF THE MEN ARE
YOU TAKING THE AMENDMENTS.
THAT WERE PROPOSED IN THE
ANALYSIS YES WE ARE OKAY THANK
YOU.
MISTER [INAUDIBLE]
SORRY.
I'M.
SORRY MADAM CHAIR OF A MARK OF
PREY ON BEHALF OF CHARGE POINT
IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE
[INAUDIBLE]
THEN UP.
THOSE WHO ARE HAVE CONCERNS OR
ARE OPPOSED [INAUDIBLE]
TEMPORE WORK [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
[INAUDIBLE]
ANY QUESTIONS.
THERE'S NOT MANY OF US HERE SO.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THIS I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU.
UP TO MORE MAYBE THEY WANT TO
COMMENT.
LATE ARRIVALS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
COMMENT ON THIS [INAUDIBLE]
LEGISLATION.
WE NEED WE DO NEED A MOTION.
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION YEAH
THEY HAVE.
ALL MOVED YEAH I'D LOVE TO MOVE.
IT'S BEEN MOVED -- TO CALL THE
ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TWO EIGHTY
FIVE THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALLEN.
BATES NO BATES NO HILL.
SKINNER STERN STERN HI DOLLY.
DOLLY NO WAY CASKEY.
I CASKEY AYE. TO TO TO TO IT'LL
BE ON CARL.
HAVE SOME OTHER MEMBERS PRESENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE FIFTEEN SIXTY YES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- FIRST OF ALL I
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF WORKING WITH ME
ON THIS BILL I WILL ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED ON PAGE
THIRTEEN AT THE ANALYSIS
CLARIFYING THE DEFINITION OF US
OF A BUS RAPID TRANSIT STATION.
THE CURRENT DEFINITION OF MAJOR
TRANSIT STOP EXCLUDES MANY HIGH
QUALITY TRANSIT OPTIONS AS A
RESULT AREAS ACROSS THE STATE
SERVE BY HIGH QUALITY TRANSIT DO
NOT.
QUALIFY FOR DIFFERENT LOCAL
INCENTIVES AND EXEMPTIONS TO
ENSURE THAT DEVELOPMENT
PARTICULARLY HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
IS MAXIMIZED NEAR MAJOR TRANSIT
UNDER CURRENT STATUTE THE ORANGE
LINE WHICH IS ONE OF LA MATTRESS
BUSIEST LINES DOES NOT QUALIFY
AS MAJOR TRANSIT DESPITE HAVING
DOES A KIT DESIGNATED LANES IT'S
SEPARATED FROM THE ROAD -- IT
HAS TRANSIT SECOND PRIORITY AND
ALL DOOR BOARDING IT BASICALLY
ACTS LIKE LIGHT RAIL FOR ALL
INTENSIVE PURPOSES IT'S LIKE A
LIGHT RAIL WITHOUT THE TRACKS --
BUT IT DOESN'T QUALIFY THE WAY
THAT MANY LESSER USE LIGHT RAIL
PROJECTS OR RAIL PROJECTS AND
LOT IN LOS ANGELES I'M DO.
AB FIFTEEN SIXTY REVISED REVISES
THE DEFINITION OF MAJOR TRANSIT
STOP TO INCLUDE BUS RAPID
TRANSIT AND DEFIES BUS RAPID
TRANSIT SPECIFICALLY TO
ESTABLISH GREATER STANDARDS FOR
HIGH QUALITY TRANSPORTATION AND
ALSO TO CLARIFY THIS ONLY WERE --
APPLIES UNDERLIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES TO THE STOP ITSELF --
WITH THE DEFINITIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE ADDED TO NARROW THAT
TO MAKE SURE THEY TRULY ARE HIGH
QUALITY SO IT'S NOT THE ENTIRE
LENGTH OF THE BUS AT THE STOP
ITSELF.
THIS DEFINITION IS NOT BEEN
UPDATED SINCE TWO THOUSAND THREE
AND IT'S TIME TO REFINE THE
DEFINITION OF MAJOR TRANSIT STOP
AND TO ALLOW AREAS THAT HAVE
MADE THE INVESTMENT IN THIS KIND
OF HIGH QUALITY RAPID TRANSIT.
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF EXISTING
INCENTIVES AND BENEFITS TO
CREATE MORE HOUSING IN THESE
DENSE URBAN AREAS.
WITH ME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT IS
STORED WALDMAN OF THE VALLEY
INDUSTRY AND AND COMMERCE
ASSOCIATION BETTER KNOWN LOCALLY
AS VIKA.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION THAT
WE KNOW OF AND IS NOT RECEIVED
ANY NO VOTES THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE --
AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
STATED I'M STORE WALDMAN
REPRESENTING BIKE -- WE
REPRESENT OVER FOUR HUNDRED
BUSINESSES AND NONPROFITS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY REGION.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK FOR THIS
COMMITTEE -- ON THE ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN SIXTY WHICH WOULD
HELP MAXIMIZE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT NEAR HIGH QUALITY
TRANSIT -- BY AMENDING THE
DEFINITION OF MAJOR TRANSIT STOP.
RECENTLY IN LOS ANGELES THE
VOTERS HAVE PASSED A MEASURE
CALLED JJJ -- WHICH INCENTIVIZE
TRANSIT ORIENTED COMMUNITIES --
AND IT -- ALIGNED WITH THE STATE
DEFINITION.
BUT IT FAILED TO INCLUDE.
BUS RAPID TRANSIT SO THIS IS A
CHANGE THAT WILL ALLOW US.
TO PORTABLE HOUSING ALONG THE
ORANGE LINE [INAUDIBLE]
I BEING HEARING -- DRIVE OUT.
THANK YOU SIR OTHER FOLKS WHO
WANNA.
VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE GOOD
MORNING YELLING HAVOC WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YOU.
GOOD MORNING DEBORAH CARL TO THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ENTRANCE WE
WAS CHARGER AMPLY WE'RE
PROVIDING TWEENER TESTIMONY THIS
MORNING SUPPORT ASH.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH YOUR
HONOR YOU'RE NOT A ON BEHALF OF
PHILLY METRO -- WE'VE BEEN
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THE AUTHOR.
WE THINK IT MAKES PERFECT SENSE
WE'RE VERY.
OF THE ORANGE LINE THE RECORD
BREAKING RIDERSHIP TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND PASSENGERS PER DAY.
AND WE THINK THE DEFINITION OF
MAJOR CRIMES ARE STOPPING UP
YOUR UPGRADED IN THIS WAY MAKES
PERFECT SENSE.
AND B. R. T. WE WE PLAN TO
REPLICATE THAT KIND OF SCCESS
CALVET.
THANK YOU OKAY.
I ANYONE ONE THREE OPPOSITION --
CONCERNS ABOUT.
ALL RIGHT TO THE MATTER IS
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTION SPOTS.
CENTER STERN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
A SEMINAR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD INTO THE SPONSORS.
PORTS LINE STARTS IN.
THE DISTRICT I REPRESENT I DON'T
KNOW PARK [INAUDIBLE]
AND FRANKLY.
YOU KNOW RIDERSHIP IS EXCELLENT
RIGHT NOW BUT I THINK IT'S ONLY
A BEGUN I THINK THAT WE'VE
ACTUALLY.
GOT A MAINSTREAM THAT LINE AND
MAKE IT.
PLACE THAT'S FINE AND EXCITING
AND SAFE WAY TO MOVE AROUND FOR
ANYBODY.
I WANNA GO DOWNTOWN AND I WANT
TO SIT ON ONE ONE FOUR FIVE AND
IF WE FIND A WAY TO START TO BE
BACK.
AND YES I'M CONNECTED ME THROUGH
THE WHOLE REGION HAVE A TRANSIT
BOARD ALSO GOING -- OVER THOSE
HILLS THAT FOUR FIVE QUARTERS IT
TO ME THIS IS. TO THE START OF
SOME AND I I'M NOT READY TO
CELEBRATE.
FULLY THE ORANGE LINE YET.
THE VISION I THINK THIS WILL BE
IMPORTANT PART OF IT -- SO I'M
I'M EXCITED SPORT THE BILL I I
DID WANT TO ASK ABOUT THE
THERE'S THERE NOW THIS IS
BROUGHT UP THIS OPTION ONE
OPTION TO ISSUE.
YES I AM ANY COMMENTS ON THAT IN
TERMS OF I I JUST NED TO GET MY
HEAD AROUND WHAT THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THE OF THE
OPTION NOW THE ARE IN THE BILL
RIGHT NOW LIKE YOU [INAUDIBLE]
FOR ANNOUNCES SAYS -- THERE'S NO
MINIMUM FREQUENCY REQUIREMENTS
WELL ACTUALLY THIS THAT MEMONS
THAT WE'VE TAKEN THERE'S FIVE
CRITERIA THAT THE STOP PASSED TO
ME.
SO IT HAS TO BE FIFTEEN MINUTE
HEADWAYS DURING PEAK TIMES IT
HAS TO BE ALL DOOR BOARDING IT
HAS TO BE SIGNAL PRIORITIZATION.
IT NEEDS.
TO THERE'S ONE THAT I THINK IS
ACTUALLY SLIGHTLY PROBLEMATIC
BUT IT HAS TO ALLOW FOR A
LOADING OF YOUR FARE BEFORE AT
THE STATION.
THE ONLY REASON I THINK IT'S
PROBLEMATIC AS WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY CHANGING TO WHERE
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT YOUR PHONE
WILL DO IT THROUGH AN APP WHICH
BE AT THE STATION.
SO I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED AS TO
THAT WERE SORT OF LIMITED
TECHNOLOGY BUT I UNDERSTAND THE
GOAL AND THERE WAS ONE OTHER
CRITERIA WHICH OF THE TOP OF MY
HEAD -- YEAH YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
BUS SHELTER SO IT'S PRETTY
STRICT IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
CRITERIA ARE FOR THE STATIONS
AND IF THERE'S A STATION THAT
FOR SOME REASON MAYBE.
MAYBE THEY SKIP IT IS LIKE I'M
NOT EXPRESSED OP OR SOMETHING
LIKE THE WAY THEY DO IN SOME
PRICING SOME STATIONS THAT ONE
MY COURT NOT.
BY BUT THE OTHER STATIONS WELL
DOES NOT A MENU IF THAT'S IF
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
YOU I DON'T HAVE ALL OF THOSE I
THINK THIS GROUP HERE VERY
HELPFUL BECAUSE I ALSO ON ON THE
VENTURA COUNTY CITED THE
DISTRICT.
THERE'S THERE ARE SOME
INTERSPERSED TRANSIT OPTIONS BUT
THERE ARE VERY FEW AND FAR
BETWEEN AND I WOULDN'T CALL THEM.
AT A MAJOR TREND I STOPPED THAT
WERE THING ABOUT HERE SO YES
ORANGE LINE.
YOU KNOW THERE'S A TODAY BY SAID
A SENIOR VALLEY THAT'LL HOKEY
AND YOU KNOW TO THE OXNARD LIKE.
THAT ACT SO IN TERMS OF THE
REFINED I THINK THAT'S THAT'S
HELPFUL JUST TO BE CLEAR THIS IS
AN IS IN AND HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL I HEARD I HEARD FROM MY
COLLEAGUES IT'S ALREADY BEEN.
SO.
THIS DEFERRED CHAIR THANK YOU
[INAUDIBLE]
I GUESS.
WHEN I FIRST READ IT DOES SEEM
LIKE AN INNOCUOUS BILL IT WASN'T
A BIG DEAL BUT I'M CONCERNED
THAT NO TRANSPORTATION GROUPS OR
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS HAVE COME
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING THE IDEA?
I WONDER WHY IS THAT SO.
YOU HAVE ANY IDEA.
I BUSINESS PEOPLE WANT TO HAVE
THE EXEMPTION BUT I DON'T SEE
ANY OF THAT NORMAL
TRANSPORTATION VIRAL GROUP SAID
I WOULD EXPECT.
TO COME FORWARD AFTER THEY DID
THE ANALYSIS.
YEAH THE POINT I WISH THAT THEY
WOULD.
IS YOUR GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
NEXT IS THAT WE CAN MARY
CLEARASIL THE WHOLE POINT OF
DOING TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT.
IS SO THAT YOU HAVE COULD YOU
CREATE CITIES ARE MORE.
ACCESSIBLE BY MASS TRANSIT SO
YOU REDUCE SPRAWL YOU ENCOURAGE
DEVELOPMENT AROUND YOUR MAJOR
TRANSIT STOPS SO.
WITHOUT THE LAND USE PIECE WE'RE
NEVER GOING TO HIT OUR MISSION
SCHOOLS WERE NEVER GONNA STOP
SPRAWL AND THE WHOLE IDEA OF
WITH THIS MEASURE IS TO
ENCOURAGE.
WHEN IF YOU'RE GOING TO DEVELOP
THE PLACE YOU'RE GOOD YOU SHOULD
BE DEVELOPING IS NEAR?
I'VE MASS TRANSIT WHERE IT'S
AVAILABLE PEOPLE WE'VE MADE
THOSE MAJOR INVESTMENTS.
AND SO -- THAT THERE IS THAT
CONNECTION.
I I MAYBE I MISSED IT BUT I
DIDN'T SEE THAT THERE'S
ASSURANCES THAT IT'S TIED.
TO A SMART GROWTH DEVELOPMENT OR
IT ALLOWS FOR THE TYPE OF
STREAMLINING THAT YOU WOULD GET.
WHAT'S CONSIDERED HIGH PRIORITY
TRANSIT.
SO FOR PURPOSES OF ANY OTHER.
DENSITY BONUSES THAT SORT OF
THING MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THIS WOULD ALLOW THAT CONNECTION.
I MEAN FOR WHAT IT'S WORTH.
I'M OPEN TO HELPING.
IF IT IF WE NEED TO HAVE A CLEAR
NEXUS TO GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION OR INTEGRATION WITH
THIS BE THREE SEVENTY FIVE
PLANNING OR TO THE YOU KNOW SORT
OF BROADER.
DMT REDUCTION TARGETS IN THE
REGION THAT THROUGH SKAGGS MAYBE
THERE'S SOME KIND OF CROSS
REFERENCE THAT WOULD BOLSTER.
WE CAN ACTIVITY THE CONNECTIVITY
YEAH I MEAN IT'S IT REALLY IS
THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL IS TO FREE
UP THESE. TO CALL THIS MAJOR
TRANSIT.
THERE'S A HIGH PRIORITY TRANSIT
DOES ENJOY SOME BENEFITS BY.
YOU KNOW SORT OF BY THE
LEGISLATURE BY LOCALITIES AND
CITY OF LOS ANGELES FOR INSTANCE
AND THIS WOULD ALLOW THE ORANGE
LINE AND I FAR AS I KNOW ONLY
THE ORANGE LINE AT THIS POINT.
TO QUALIFY BECAUSE IT IS SO
NARROWLY DEFINED SO IT WOULDN'T
BE DOESN'T I DON'T KNOW THAT
THERE'S ANY OTHER OR MANY OTHER
BUS RAPID TRANSIT THAT QUALIFY
AT THIS POINT.
BUT THIS MIGHT SPUR YOU KNOW
MORE DISCUSSION ABOUT HAVING
THEM IN AREAS WHERE WE FEEL.
THEY CAN BE OF BENEFIT IT'S IT'S
IT'S IT'S EXTENDING.
THE INVESTMENT OF THE MASS
TRANSIT TO NOW ALSO ENJOY THE
OTHER AND BENEFITS THAT HIGH
QUALITY TRANSIT OFFERS NEAR NEAR
HER RAIL STATIONS MAYBE THE
RIGHT VENUE THEN IS MAKING SURE
THE THE PLANNING PROCESS RUN
ORANGE LINE EXPANSION AND
DEVELOPMENT IS CLEARLY.
REDUCING EMISSIONS WHICH IS THE
WHOLE POINT OF YOU KNOW GETTING
MEASURE M. ARE AND EVERYTHING
OUT THERE.
TO GET THE VALLEY.
I'D LIKE TO SEE IT ON TRACK
[INAUDIBLE]
EVENTUALLY [INAUDIBLE]
BUT YES MAYBE MAYBE THAT'S
SOMETHING WE CAN WORK ON AS THE
BILL IF THE BILL MOVES FOR JUST
TO ARTICULATE IN A FINDING OR
SOME NEXUS THERE THEY CAN MAKE
IT CLEAR [INAUDIBLE]
OPEN THAT.
YEAH I'M.
THIS IS GOING TO HOUSING I WOULD
LIKE I'M GONNA STAY OFF AND I I
WANT TO HELP THE BILL TO MOVE
BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE.
I CROSS ALL T. ISN'T THAT THE
ICE ON THIS ONE SO NOT.
I WANT TO SAY ANYTHING ELSE
[INAUDIBLE]
OKAY.
I DO FOR YOU.
ACCEPTING.
DEMANDS IN WORKING WITH US AND
YOU KNOW I I I I THINK WE JUST
DIDN'T WANT TO GET WHERE SHE WAS
TRYING TO DO I'M.
I THINK AT THE SAME TIME.
YOU KNOW WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DIDN'T.
GO SO FAR BEYOND.
WHAT WE COMMONLY KNOWN TO BE A
BUS RAPID TRANSIT STATION
[INAUDIBLE]
AND TO TO PUT THAT IN THERE WAS
A RISK HERE THAT THAT WE WOULD
GET TO THAT WE WOULD START TO
CALL ANY.
IN A BUS STOP -- WHERE PEOPLE
ARE YEAH BY NINETY MINUTE NO
WOULD ONLY AGREE AND AND THAT I
JUST AND AND AND BY THE WAY IF
WE WANT TO HAVE A DISCUSSION
ABOUT WHETHER THAT OUGHT TO BE?
PART OF THE HOUSING.
YEAH I STREAMLINING MAKES LET'S
HAVE A DISCUSSION THAT'S KIND OF
WHAT.
OUR FRIEND THE CHAIR OF HOUSING
COMMITTEE WAS TRYING TO DO WITH
HIS.
ENORMOUS BILL BUT I'M.
WE WE ALL WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE STATUTE WAS ACTUALLY
BEING TRUE. TO TO TO WHAT WE
KNOW.
IS BUS RAPID TRANSIT RATHER THAN
THAN JUST REGULAR BUS STOP SO.
I WITH THAT I'M I DO APPRECIATE
YOUR WORK WITH OUR COMMITTEE AND
AND YOU'RE ACCEPTING OF THE
AMENDMENTS AND IN SPITE OF THE
FACT THIS YEAR WHILE MINUTES OF
OF THIS BILL I'M GONNA RECOMMEND
AYE.
I HAVE A VERY HIGH.
ON THIS BILL IN AND DONE IT
DOESN'T MOVED IN -- WITHOUT AYE
AYE AT SUCH A PLEASE CALL.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY AB FIFTEEN
SIXTY MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE HOUSING COMMITTEE.
ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE [INAUDIBLE]
I HILL [INAUDIBLE]
SKINNER [INAUDIBLE]
STERN.
HI DOLLY DOLLY I LIKE CASKEY.
WE'RE GONNA I THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND I'M I'M ACTUALLY BY THE
WOMEN ASKED TO BE.
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR YOUR AB.
TWO EIGHTY FIVE IF THAT'S
AMENABLE TO YOU WERE IN THE ROOM
WHEN WE FIND OUT HOW THEY HAD WE
WILL ALL HAVE ELECTIONS IN THE
SAID I HAD TO LEAVE SAUDI HONOR
CHERRY DISCOURTEOUS ACOSTA I
APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
EVERYBODY THINKS RIVER
DISSIPATION.
AND GO U. S. WOMEN.
STORE WILL BE THERE AT THE FINAL.
OKAY.
OKAY SO NEXT NEXT YEAR FROM
DECEMBER CHOOSE YOUR PRESENT
ITEM SIX A. B..
TWO OH SIX THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SENATORS AB
TWO OH SIX WOULD PROTECT
PROPERTY OWNERS FROM FRIVOLOUS
LAWSUITS IF THEY PARTICIPATE.
IN LEAD ABATEMENT LEAD PAINT
ABATEMENT PROGRAMS THIS ISSUE AS
SOME OF YOU KNOW COMES OUT OF A
LANDMARK LEGAL DECISION THAT
FOUND LEAD PAINT COMPANIES
LIABLE. FOR KNOWINGLY PROFITING
FROM PROFITS FROM PRODUCTS WITH
DOCUMENT HEALTH RISKS INCLUDING
A WIDESPREAD PUBLIC NUISANCE.
THESE COMPANIES ARE NOW REQUIRED
TO PAY FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS INTO A LEAD ABATEMENT
PROGRAM.
PHILIPPINE COMPANIES HAVE
SUGGESTED THAT TWO SENTENCES IN
PCOURT DECISION MIGHT LEAD TO
LAWSUITS AGAINST HOMEOWNERS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN ABATEMENT
PROGRAMS.
WHILE THOSE LAWSUITS WOULD BE
FRIVOLOUS THE THREAT OF A
LAWSUIT COULD DETER
PARTICIPATION SO THIS BILL WOULD
PROTECT PROPERTY OWNERS WHO
CHOOSE TO PARTICIPATE IN LEAD
PAINT ABATEMENT.
SUPPORTED BY CITIES AND COUNTIES
AROUND THE STATE THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS AS WELL
AS TENANT ORGANIZATIONS.
ENVIRONMENTAL AND HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS AND I WANT.
TO APPRECIATE THE UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN COMMITTEES
AND ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
THROUGH THIS PROCESS AND I'M
GONNA TURN IT OVER TO OUR
WITNESS.
JAMIE HEALING DELAY WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO CITY ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I REPRESENT THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN THE LEAD
PAINT.
LITIGATION THAT'S UNDER.
ONLINE THIS BELL AND ONE OF THE
IMPORTANT THINGS TO KNOW ABOUT
THIS LITIGATION IS IT'S BEEN
GOING ON FOR NINETEEN YEARS AND
WE ARE NOW AT THE FINISH LINE WE
HAVE.
A HEARING ON MONDAY TO HAVE A
FINAL JUDGMENT ENTERED IN THIS
CASE IT WOULD GIVE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE TEN
JURISDICTIONS FOR LEAD ABATEMENT.
BUT THERE'S A CATCH WE HAVE ONLY
FOUR YEARS TO SPEND THAT MONEY
AND TO THE EXTENT WE ARE UNABLE
TO SPEND THAT ON LEAD ABATEMENT
IT WILL GO BACK.
TO THE DEFENDANT LEAD PAINT
COMPANIES THAT BECAUSE THIS
NUISANCE AB TWO OH SIX IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT MONEY IS SPENT ON
LEAD ABATEMENT AND PROTECTS
FUTURE GENERATIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS FROM IRREPARABLE
LEAD POISONING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YES MA'AM.
GOOD MORNING DEBORAH CARL TO THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
WE DO BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
WILL PROVIDE SAFER HOUSING -- IT
ONLY PROVIDES AT THE MERE
PARTICIPATION ON THE PART OF A
LANDMARK IN THE COMMITTEE CANNOT
BE GROUNDS AE EVIDENCE FOR A
VIOLATION.
IT DOESN'T HOWEVER PROVIDE
IMMUNITY TO A LANDLORD WHO HAS
SUBSTANDARD HOUSING CONDITIONS
OR WHO HARMS TENANTS THROUGH THE
PROCESS.
OR WHO HAS PROVIDED SOME SORT OF
HARM PRIOR TO THAT IT DOES NOT
PROVIDE IMMUNITY FOR THAT.
SO WITH THAT WE BELIEVE IN WE
WOULD NEVER SUPPORT THOSE
COMMENTS WE WOULD ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
WOULD YOU REALLY NEVER IN
SUPPORT OF BILL. FOR MORE TO
MEET AN ABSOLUTE.
THE CODE ENFORCEMENT DEPARTMENT
VERY STRESSED ACTIONS WOULD NOT
SUPPORT THAT BILL.
CORRECT OKAY MISTER CHAIR.
I'M OF THE BILL WE WERE.
WE HEARD THE LEGAL DISTINCTIONS
AND JUDICIARY AND AS FAR AS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS I HAVE NO
OF NO CONCERNS ALMOST.
WE DO APPRECIATE THAT.
AND YOUR COUNTIES OTHER FOLKS
ONEROUS I SUPPORT FOR THE TELL
ME HOW THE CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION WE HAVE OVER
FIVE AND OVER HALF MILLION AT
THE STATE APPRECIATE.
THE OTHER BRINGS FORTH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ANNA BUCK ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE MORNING JEAN HEARST HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE VENTURA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN I'LL BE OFF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
MIKE WAS THE DISTRICT COUNCIL
SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES IN SUPPORT.
COMING WITH THE LA COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
THE FOR JUST CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITIES IN SUPPORT.
PROSECUTORS HERE IN THE OFFICE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
IN PART.
JENNIFER COMPUTER LOW ON BEHALF
OF THE MODERATE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
ALLOW YOU ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP OF SUPPORTING THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT OKAY OF FOLKS WANNA
RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JOHN
MOFFITT ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHICH THE
PRODUCT OF PROJECT OF CONAGRA
ENSURING SURE WHEN WILLIAMS TO
THE THREE DEFENDANTS IN THIS
CASE.
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL WE
THINK IT'S AN HONOR. TO SHOW A
VIOLATION OF OUR DO.
WITH RESPECT TO THE UNDERLYING
CASE -- YOU KNOW FROM FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW WE WE LOOK
AT THE BILL AND WE LOOK AT
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
POLICY AND HOW WE LOOK AT THESE
TYPES OF ISSUES IN THE PAST
WHETHER IT BE GROUND WATER
WHETHER IT BE.
TOXIC WASTE FACILITIES WHETHER
IT BE ANY NUMBER OF OTHER
CHEMICALS PCP.
YOU KNOW THE STATE TYPICALLY
SAYS LOOK WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
EVERYBODY LIABLE WE'RE GONNA
BRING THEM ALL AND WE'RE GOING
TO GET THIS THING FIXED AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA LT THEM FIGHT
AMONGST THEMSELVES AS TO AS TO
WHO.
IS GOING TO PAY HOW MUCH OF WHAT.
I WILL STIPULATE RIGHT NOW AS
WAS JUST MENTIONED THERE'S YOU
KNOW THIS CASE IS APPROACHING A
FINAL JUDGMENT MY CLIENTS ARE
GOING TO PAY.
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE FIRST DOLLAR
INTO REMEDIATION FUND WITH THIS
ISSUE IS ABOUT IS WHAT HAPPENS
AFTER THAT.
AND HOW IT IS THERE CONTRIBUTION
ON BEHALF OF HOMEOWNERS
LANDLORDS AND OUR MAJOR CONCERN
SLUMLORDS IN THIS -- IN THIS
STATE WHO -- SHOULD ALSO AT
LEAST NOMINALLY BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE.
FOR THE CONDITION OF SOME OF THE
HOMES THAT WILL BE REMEDIATED.
WE HAVE NO ISSUES WITH THE THE
PICTURE THAT EVERYONE HAS IN
THEIR HEAD OF THE HOMEOWNER
THERE THINKING UP.
WHO?
SHOULD BE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THIS REMEDIATION FUND NO ISSUES
WITH THAT BUT WE DO HAVE AN
ISSUE WITH SLUMLORDS.
AND THERE'S A DOUBLE WHAMMY HERE
THIS BILL GRANT THEM IMMUNITY
AND THEN THE UNDERLYING COURT
DECISION PUTS THEM FIRST IN LINE
FOR THE REMEDIATION FUNDS AND SO.
THERE'S CONCERN THERE ABOUT YOU
KNOW ARE THEY GOING TO SUCK UP
ALL THE FUNDS BEFORE THE FOLKS
YOUR THINKING ABOUT.
ACTUALLY CAN GET ANY.
LAST YOU KNOW I THINK FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW I DO WE DO
NOT WE UNDERSTAND THE THE
PURPOSES OF THE BILL REYES BY
THE THE SUPPORTERS AND THE AND
THE AUTHOR BUT THERE'S NO OTHER
WAY TO ADDRESS THIS.
WITH THIS BILL COULDN'T SAY
ANYONE ANY.
LANDLORD WITH TEN OR MORE HEALTH
CODE VIOLATIONS MUST PARTICIPATE
IN THE REMEDIATION PROGRAM.
THIS BILL COULDN'T SAY -- ANYONE
WITH TEN OR MORE HEALTH CODE
VIOLATIONS.
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF YOU KNOW
THAT'S OUT IN FORCING THE LOCAL
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODES.
MAY ISSUE A CITATION THAT
MANDATES THE REMEDY THAT THEY
HAVE TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS FOR
MEDIATION PROGRAM.
THIS BILL COULDN'T SAY SOMETHING
LIKE.
YOU KNOW.
HOMEOWNERS ARE PROTECTED
SLUMLORDS CAN GET SUED IN ANY
RECOVERY FROM THAT CAN BE
SOMEHOW SPLIT BETWEEN THE
PLAINTIFFS AND DEFENDANTS.
ARE MANY OTHER WAYS TO ADDRESS
THIS OTHER THAN GRANTING THE
BROAD IMMUNITY OF THIS BILL. FOR
THESE REASONS WERE OPPOSED TO
MAP IT ANSWER ANY QUESTION.
THANK YOU. FOR SHOULD ANY OTHER
FOLKS WANNA RAISE CONCERNS ARE
OF THIS VOTE.
OKAY TO THE MATTERS REFERRED ME
I I WOULD ACTUALLY LIKE -- TO
YOU KNOW WHAT WE DID WE DID LOOK
AT SOME OF THESE THESE KIND OF
FUN.
COMMUNITY ISSUES JUDICIARY SHE'S
OVER IN THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
AND NUMBER OF US WERE NOT.
WE'RE IN A DISCUSSION BUT I I I
DO THINK THAT YOU KNOW FOLLOWING
UP IN THE COMMENT WAS MADE BY
THE WITNESS IN SUPPORT THAT.
THEY WOULD NEVER SUPPORT
IMMUNITY FOR SOME WORDS I GUESS
THE QUESTION IS I LOVE TAKE LIKE
ASK THE AUTHOR ABOUT.
THEIR THOUGHTS ON THIS I THINK
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT --
THURMOND REAL SERIOUS CONCERNS
ABOUT THE WITH THE ROLE THAT THE
PAIN INDUSTRY.
HAS PLAYED IN THE PAST -- AND
INDEED SOME OF THESE YOU HAVE
PRODUCTS THAT HAVE BEEN SO THEY
REALLY HAVEN'T BEEN SAFE.
I'M OF COURSE THEIR MOST
DANGEROUS AND THOSE PROPERTIES
THAT ARE NOT WELL MAINTAINED.
I AND HOW HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THAT WHILE WE ARE HOLDING THE
PAIN INDUSTRY.
JUSTIFIABLY ACCOUNTABLE THERE
WERE ALSO MAKING SURE THE OTHER
FOLKS ARE NOT LEFT I'M OFF THE
HOOK.
WHEN THEY HAVE RESPONSIBILITIES
OF THE OUT OF THERE IN THIS AREA?
WELL ANSWER THE QUESTION IN A
COUPLE IS FIRST OF ALL -- WITH
WITH GREAT RESPECT TO THE
OPPOSITION -- THIS IS A VERY
NARROW COMMUNITY THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THAT'S BEING
CARVED OUT OF THIS BILL WE'RE
SIMPLY SAYING THAT IF A
HOMEOWNER WERE TO TAKE.
WERE TO AVAIL THEMSELVES OF SOME
DOLLARS FROM THIS FUN.
THEY COULD BE SUED FOR THAT
AMOUNT -- WE ADDED LANGUAGE AS
WE DISCUSSED AND SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. TO MAKE IT
VERY CLEAR THAT THIS LAW WILL
NOT ALTER ANY EXISTING
OBLIGATIONS ON HOMEOWNERS TO
MAINTAIN THEIR PROPERTY UNDER
APPLICABLE LAW OR OTHERWISE
LIMIT ATTENDANCE LEGAL REMEDIES
FOR ADDRESSING THE PRESENCE OF
LEAD PAINT ON A TWILIGHT SO.
WE MAKE IT VERY CLEAR THAT AGAIN
THE SLUMLORDS AS ENGAGE ABOUT
ACTIVITY ANYONE CAN GO AFTER
THEM.
EXCEPT WHERE IT'S RELATED TO
SIMPLY TAKING DISSIPATING IN
THIS PROGRAM.
AND I WILL TELL YOU THERE
THERE'S A REASON WHY THAT THE
TENANT ORGANIZATIONS AND WESTERN
CENTER OTHER ORGANIZATIONS AS
WELL AS ALL OF THE CITIES.
THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
ENFORCING LAWS AGAINST LANDLORDS
ARE SUPPORTING THIS BECAUSE I
KNOW HOW NEAR IT IS BUT THEY
ALSO KNOW THAT ONCE YOU OPEN UP
THE DOOR. TO SAY THAT THE PAINT
COMPANIES COULD POTENTIALLY
BRING EVEN ONE LAWSUIT AGAINST
ONE LANDLORD YOU DETER
PARTICIPATION THIS PROGRAM WHAT
THE THE PAIN COMPANIES ARE
TRYING TO DO.
IS TO SLOW DOWN THE RATE AT
WHICH THE FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS COULD BE USED OVER FOUR
YEAR PERIOD.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE ALL THAT
MONEY GETS OUT IN GEORGIA
RESTRICTIONS TO KEEP OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE AND I JUST WANT
TO ASK IF THE CITY ATTORNEY.
FROM OUR SEE IF YOU HAVE
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO ADD TO THAT.
YEAH I WOULD ADD.
I WOULD ADD THAT. TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE LEAD PAINT COMPANIES
WANT TO THREATEN TO SUE ANYONE
THOSE LAWSUITS WOULD BE
FRIVOLOUS AND WITHOUT ANY BASIS
IN LAW.
THE COURT OF APPEAL ALREADY HELD
IN THIS CASE THE EAD PAINT
COMPANIES WERE LIABLE FOR THEIR
BEHAVIOR THEIR BEHAVIOR OF
MANUFACTURING DISTRIBUTING AND
PROMOTING LEAD PAINT.
IN THE TEN JURISDICTIONS NO
LANDLORDS SLUM LORD OR OTHERWISE
PARTICIPATED IN THAT BEHAVIOR
AND BECAUSE OF THAT THE COURT OF
APPEAL ALREADY HELD IN THIS CASE.
THAT NO HOME OWNER IS A JOINT
PORT FEES ARE AND THEREFORE
COULD BE SUED SUCCESSFULLY FOR
CONTRIBUTION FIVE LEAD PAINT
COMPANY.
SO THE ONLY THING THE LEAD PAINT
COMPANIES WANT TO DO HERE IS
BRING FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS THEY
WOULD LOSE TO DETERMINE.
PATIENT IN THE PROGRAM SO THAT
THEY GET THEIR MONEY BACK ON THE
AND AND WE DON'T SPEND IT ON LET
IT BE.
OKAY MA'AM AYE SIR.
THE CONSTITUTIONALITY ISSUE.
DO YOU HAVE A LEAD COUNSEL IN IN
IN ON THAT.
THAT'S BEEN BROUGHT UP A COUPLE
TIMES AND ANALYSES MAYBE
DISCUSSION JUDICIARY BUT I WOULD
LIKE A IT WAS A RECORD HERE IT
WAS ADDRESSED BY THE ANALYSIS IN
THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
I'M THE THE LEGISLATURE IS
ALLOWED TO BOTH CREATE AND
EXTINGUISH CAUSES OF ACTION AND
SO THERE'S NO DUE PROCESS
PROBLEM WITH THE LEGISLATURE
EXTINGUISHING ACOSTA ACTION IN
THIS CASE.
IN DOUBTS FROM OUR LEAD COUNSEL.
I'M SO SORRY ABOUT THIS I I'VE.
BEEN.
THE ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS KEEPS
COMING OVER I'M SO.
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
OKAY WHEN WE I KNOW WHEN WE CALL
FOR A VOTE THIS.
IF YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
CONSIDERATION THIS COMMITTEE
THANK YOU. TO KEEP ITS COLOR.
ITEM NUMBER SIX A. B. TWO OH SIX
MOTION IS DO PASS.
HI ALLEN I I TELL.
SKINNER AYE STERN.
DOLLY BUT ONLY I AM WIECKOWSKI.
SB I'VE OKAY.
WE'VE HAD OPENED TO ADMIT THAT
MEMBERS ON SO WE'D LIKE THANK
YOU CENTERS SO MEMBER RUBIO
PLEASE -- COME FORWARD IN A
PASSED THE GAVEL TO THE
RESTAURANT [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH OKAY.
JEAN FIFTEEN ITEMS.
WELCOME AGAIN THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TODAY
I'M HERE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL.
TEN NINETY THREE WHICH WOULD
HAVE THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD DEVELOP FINANCIAL
CAPABILITY ASSESSMENTS.
ASSESSMENT GUIDELINES TO BETTER
ASSIST LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WHEN
DEVELOPMENTS DEVELOPING STORM
WATER PERMITS.
UNDER EXISTING FEDERAL LAW THE
CLEAN WATER ACT OR THE CW A
REGULATES DISCHARGES OF
POLLUTANTS INTO THE WATERS.
OF THE UNITED STATES AND
REGULATES QUALITY STANDARDS FOR
SURFACE WATER -- SEPARATE STORM
SEWER SYSTEM PERMITS OR MS FOR
PERMITS ARE A CRITICAL ASPECT OF
THE C. W. A. FOR PROTECTING
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE IN THE
ENVIRONMENT.
ALTHOUGH CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE
DEVELOPING THEIR STORMWATER
POLLUTANT SCHEDULES MANY
REMAINING NEED OF GUIDANCE AND
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE IN ORDER TO
DEVELOP ADEQUATE CONSISTENT AND
COST AND FORM PERMITS.
LET ME MAKE THIS CLEAR THERE IS
NO INTENT TO LESSEN THE CLEAN
WATER ACT REQUIREMENTS WITH THIS
BILL.
BUT RATHER HAVE THE STATE WATER.
BOARD DEVELOP GUIDELINES THE
CONSISTENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY
IMPLEMENT PENALTIES FOR ENTITIES
THAT ARE OUT OF COMPLIANCE.
WHICH IS NOT HAPPENING WITH THIS
CURRENT SYSTEM.
THE COST OF COMPLIANCE FOR ELLIE
COUNTY ALONE EXIT EXCEEDS TWENTY
BILLION DOLLARS.
CALIFORNIA'S OWN STATE AUDITOR
CONFIRMED IN HER MARCH.
ONE TWENTY FOURTH THE STATE
WATER BOARD HAS NOT ADEQUATELY
CONSIDERED THE COST OF LOOK TO
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
THAT ARE THEY WOULD ENCOURAGE
AND COMPLY WITH THE CLEAN WATER
ACT.
THE AUDITOR ALSO SITE STATE LAW
REQUIRING REGIONAL WATER BOARDS
INCLUDING TO INCLUDE ECONOMIC
CONSIDERATIONS AS A FACT.
DOUBLES YOU REQUIREMENTS WHICH
HAS NOT BEEN THE CASE IT IS ALSO
WORTH NOTING THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA DECLARED
STORM WATER.
AS THE STATE'S.
FISCAL OR FAN DUE TO THE NEED
FOR MORE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE IN
JURISDICTIONS STRUGGLING TO
COMPLY WITH THE PHYSICAL
REQUIREMENTS OF STORM WATER.
THAT'S WHY I AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT WAS INTRODUCED LAST
YEAR AND AB TEN NINETY THREE
THIS YEAR.
THIS YEAR'S BILL HAS SIMPLY BEEN
MODIFIED TO CHANGE THE DATE FROM
JULY FIRST TWENTY NINETEEN TO
JULY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY BOTH BLASTERS
MEASURE AND THIS YEAR'S MEASURES
HAVE RECEIVED BY PARKINSON'S
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
AB TEN NINETY THREE HAS
OPPOSITION AND HAS RECEIVED ZERO
VOTE NO VOTES THE SESSION.
I'M HERE TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT IT'S I HAVE A MAYOR PRO
TEM JOHN -- COUPLE SHIA.
OF THE CITY OF SIERRA MADRE AND
PAUL HUMOR WITH THE CENTRAL
VALLEY COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS
[INAUDIBLE]
IN SUPPORT.
YES GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'M JOHN COMPOSURE.
AND I REPRESENT THE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS AS
A SPONSOR OF AB.
TEN NINETY THREE THE BILL WOULD
DIRECT THE STATE WATER BOARD IS
HE ADMINISTRATOR OF STORM WATER
PERMITS IN CALIFORNIA UNDER THE
CLEAN WATER ACT. TO DEVELOP IN
RELEASED FINANCIAL CAPABILITY
ASSESSMENT GUIDELINES BY JULY.
TWENTY MODELED AFTER THE FEDERAL
GUIDELINES DEVELOPED BY THE
USEPA OVER THE PAST TWENTY YEARS.
THE STATE GUIDELINES ARE
INTENDED TO PROVIDE A THOROUGH
UNIFORM AND MEASURED APPROACH
FOR ASSESSING THE FINANCIAL
IMPACT OF STORMWATER PERMIT
COMPLIANCE.
AB TEN NINETY THREE REQUIRES
ONLY THE DEVELOPMENT OF
METHODOLOGIES FOR ASSESSING THE
LEVEL OF FINANCIAL BURDENS ON
COMMUNITIES.
OF CA GUIDELINES ARE INTENDED TO
HELP ESTABLISH REASONABLE
TIMELINES.
FOR COMPLIANCE ALLOWING TIME TO
SECURE GRANTS AND OTHER FUNDING
FOR POLLUTANT REDUCTION PLANTS.
AB TEN NINETY THREE DOES NOT
ALTER OR WAVE WATER QUALITY
STANDARDS IN ANY WAY.
AB TEN NINETY THREE IS REQUIRED
BECAUSE THE STATE AUDITOR'S
REPORT. TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
RECOMMENDED THE STATE WATER
BOARD SHOULD EXIT SS EXISTING
BECAUSE AND THE FINANCIAL
ABILITY OF LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO COMPLY.
BEFORE IMPOSING ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS.
THE ORDER AUDITOR NOTED THAT
POLLUTION CONTROL REQUIREMENTS
CAN NOT IMPROVE WATER QUALITY.
IF LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
UNABLE TO COMPLY WITH THEM.
COMPLIANCE COSTS ARE SIGNIFICANT
LA COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
WORKS IS ESTIMATED THE COST AT
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
COUNTY.
YEAH AND SIX BILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY.
THE US CONFERENCE OF MAYORS IS
COMPLETED IN AFFORDABILITY
ASSESSMENT OF MORE THAN THIRTY
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN IN A THIRD
OF THOSE CITIES 20% OR MORE
HOUSEHOLDS EXCEEDED EPA'S
THRESHOLD SPENDING.
INDICATING AFFORDABILITY BURDEN
PARTICULARLY FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
AB TEN NINETY THREE WILL PROVIDE
A RATIONAL AND UNIFORMITY IT FOR
A VALUE WAITING FINANCIAL
CAPABILITY TO ACHIEVE COMPLIANCE
WITHOUT JEOPARDIZING WATER
QUALITY.
WE APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO'S LEADERSHIP AND
INTRODUCING AB TEN NINETY THREE
AND URGE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THERE'SA SUPPORT I'M JUST HERE
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS OF PENSIONS.
ARE THERE ARE FOLKS AND NOT.
HEARING ROOM THAT ARE
[INAUDIBLE]
IN SUPPORT.
I'M SURE TO ME IT WAS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
GOVERNMENT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JOHNSON CLAIMED OFF THE COUNTY
SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT.
JULIE HALL THE CESSATION
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES HERE
IN SUPPORT.
THOSE IN OPPOSITION ANYONE HERE
IN OPPOSITION.
DON'T BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
WHY DID NOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I'M SORRY NOT THANK YOU --
ENTERIC JUST THE THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE REGION AS YOU.
HEARD THIS WOULD COST ABOUT OVER
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS AND FOR
MY ELEVEN COMMUNITIES THAT WOULD
COMPLETELY CORRUPT ALL OF THEM.
AND SO WE'RE LOOKING FOR FOR
SOME SUPPORT NOT JUST FOR MY
COMMUNITIES FOR ALL THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE REQUIRED TO
COMPLY WITH THEM AS FAR
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB TEN
NINETY THREE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ALLEN.
EIGHT FIVE EIGHT I HILL.
SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN.
DOLLY.
I AM I CAN SKI. THREE ZERO AND
THEY'LL PHONE CALL [INAUDIBLE]
JOIN US [INAUDIBLE] ONE YEAH.
GET FROM THOSE.
HE GOT THE SAME COLORS YOU HAVE
A LOT OF MEMBERS HERE BUT WILL
BE ON CALL THAT WE CAN COMPLETE
OUR I MEAN THIS IS WHAT YOU KNOW
ON FOR SIX BEFORE WE DO THAT WE
ARE.
ADDING AN ADDITIONAL --
COMMITTEE ON TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS AB.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT ARMED WITH
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENT -- I
WANT TO POINT OUT IN ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WORKED
OUT WITH THE AUTHOR THE
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENT PROVIDES
THAT IF THE STATE WATER BOARD
IDENTIFIES OPPORTUNITIES.
IT SHOW IT SHALL WHERE
APPROPRIATE ISSUE A WATER
TREATMENT OR DISTRIBUTION
OPERATOR CERTIFICATE.
BY RECIPROCITY OR A WAR
EXPERIENCE OR EDUCATION CREDITS.
TO PERSONS WHO PERFORM
COMPARABLE DO THESE WHILE
SERVING IN THE UNITED STATES
MILITARY SO WE'LL BE ADDING ON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA IS AB.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT ARE TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
DO YOU LIKE TO CALL THE ROLL
MADAM.
SECRETARY ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS NUMBER. ONE
ELEVEN TWELVE TWENTY ONE AND
TWENTY TWO AT ALLEN. EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT I KILL.
SKINNER AYE STERN.
DALI.
DALI IOWA CASKEY. THREE ZERO AND
WILL -- WHEN WE HAVE MEMBERS
BACK WILL?
THAT WOULD BE ON CALL I WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE A RECESS NOW WE WE
WILL RECONVENE -- AT ONE THIRTY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY ARE AND I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BUT HE O'DONNELL HERE.
WILL HAVE YOU UP FIRST TIME
SINCE YOU'VE BEEN SO PATIENT
WAITING.
THE CALL TODAY.
ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY AT 1:30
WHY DON'T WE GO AHEAD AND GET
THIS [INAUDIBLE]
PARDEE RESTARTED -- APPRECIATE.
REMEMBER BEING HERE SORRY WE
WANT TO LOOK AT YOU BEFORE --
BACK.
SO.
HOPEFULLY WE'RE GONNA MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE. TO GET DOWN HERE --
BUT YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AGAIN I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I LIKE TO START OFF BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AD
THINK THE CHAIR AND HIS STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK ON THE BILL THANK
YOU.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
ELEVEN NINETY FIVE WHICH DIRECTS
THE ERROR BE TO CONSIDER
ALLOWING OIL AND GAS COMPANIES
TO CLAIM AN INNOVATIVE
PRODUCTION METHOD CREDIT. FOR
USING RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS
DELIVERED BY A COMMON CARRIER
PIPELINE PROVIDED THE SOURCE
REDUCES METHANE EMISSIONS.
WITH IN CALIFORNIA.
THE LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD
RURAL CFS IS PRIMARILY DESIGNED
TO ENCOURAGE THE USE OF CLEAN
LOW CARBON TRANSPORTATION FUELS
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE PROGRAM IS ALSO INTENDED TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS DURING THE
ACTUAL PROCESS OF PRODUCING
TRANSPORTATION FUELS.
AS SUCH THE PROGRAM ALLOWS OIL
REFINING OPERATIONS TO GENERATE
LC OF AS CREDITS WHEN SWITCHING
FROM TRADITIONAL NATURAL GAS. TO
RENEWABLE NATURAL GRASS.
AB ELEVEN NINETY FIVE WOULD
DIRECT THE RB TO CONSIDER
EXPANDING THIS OPTION TO OIL AND
GAS PRODUCERS GIVEN A LARGE
AMOUNT OF NATURAL GAS.
REQUIRED BY ENHANCED WILL
RECOVER MESSAGE.
THIS MAKES THE PROCESS LESS
CARBON INTENSIVE WHICH IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE GOALS OF L.
CFS AND WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY
IS THE PALES.
WITH -- THE ON BEHALF OF THE THE
CALIFORNIA KIND OF BATON
ASSOCIATION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THE AU
PAIRS REPRESENTING STEP --
OBVIOUSLY STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THIS IS ALL ABOUT REDUCE
SEEN OUR MATH AND EMISSIONS
DURING THE EXTRACTION OF OF OIL
AND GAS.
WITHIN THIS IS GOOD FOR
CALIFORNIA WE TOOK AMENDMENTS IN
THE ASSEMBLY TO REQUIRE THAT
OFFSET HAVE HAPPENED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA -- SO WITHIN THIS A
GOOD POLICY WOULD LIKE A COPY
TAKE A SECOND LOOK AT IT WE'RE
GLAD TO TAKE.
OF THE SENATE AMENDMENTS --
GIVEN THE ALTERNATIVE -- SO WE
HOPE THAT HAVING TO VOTE FOR THE
BILL [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU -- OKAY CAN YOU ALSO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
AND THE ONE ONCE OR IS
OPPOSITION OR CONCERNS.
HE IS OVER THERE WITHOUT CHAMBER
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI LAUREN COLUMN WAS SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA -- WE APPRECIATED THE
AUTHORS FROM WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND THAT THEY'VE
ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS.
AT THIS TIME WE'RE STILL GONNA
STAY IN OPPOSITION -- I HAVE TO
BRING BACK THE AMENDMENTS TO OUR
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE AT THAT
POINT THEY MAY SUGGEST A CHANGE
BUT I CAN'T SEE THAT.
HAPPENING GOIG FORWARD.
AND JUST FOR COVERAGE IS THAT
BECAUSE THEY DESERVE A OPPOSE
THE CONCEPT OF THEY POSE A
CONCEPT AND THEY FIND THAT IT'S
JUST UNNECESSARY -- BUT YEAH AND
NOW WE KNOW WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
NOW GETTING A PLACE WHERE IT'S
JUST ABOUT ASKING ARE BE TO
CONSIDER.
RIGHT ISSUE AND THAT'S WHAT HOW
I'M GOING TO FRAME IT WHEN I
BRING IT TO THEM I JUST I
IMAGINE IN THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT I'VE HAD BACK AND FORTH
THEM ALREADY.
THAT THERE'S STILL THE POTENTIAL
THAT CAR WOULD SEE WOULD GO
FORWARD WITH THAT.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I EIGHTEEN OF US THIS IS HELPING
HIM TO JUST APPLIANCE WERE ALSO
HERE.
FRONT OF ARMS JUSTICE ALLIANCE.
SO -- WE WERE OPPOSE ORIGINALLY
IN THE BILL WITH THEM IS
OVERTAKEN AND THANK YOU FOR THE
AUTHOR FOR TAKING THEM.
AND WE DO ONE CARP TO CONSIDER
THIS -- BUT ALSO LOOKING AT WITH
THE REST OF THE PACKAGE AND I
JUST LOOKING AT THIS AS ONE ON
PEACE SO WE'RE GONNA BE REMOVING
OUR POSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OKAY JUST NOW.
THINK ABOUT IT HERE LATE SUPPORT
IS THAT GREAT GO FOR IT.
DID YOU CAN YOU CAN SPEAK IT
MIGHT.
HI NEED A QUORUM OF THE
COALITION FOR RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS WERE AT NONPROFIT TRADE
ASSOCIATION THAT REPRESENTS THE
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS --
INDUSTRY ACROSS NORTH AMERICA
AND WE'RE INSTRUCTS FOR THIS
BILL IT WOULD -- LEAD TO
NUMEROUS ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS
AND LEAD TO LOWER RELIANCE ON
FOSSIL FUELS AND IT ALSO LEADS
TO OF YOUR PAY PLANS BEING BUILT
SO WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
I THINK YOU'RE MUCH.
ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENTS ON THE
BILL FOR ANYONE OKAY -- THE ITEM
IS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE I DON'T
SEE A LOT OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HERE I DO APPRECIATE YOU.
TAKING THE MEMBERS I THINK IT
WAS IMPORTANT FOR US -- VERY
HAPPY FOR THIS TO BE PART OF THE
DISCUSSION I THINK IT'S WORTHY
OF CONSIDERATION SO -- I THINK
WE WERE CONCERNED ABOUT
REQUIRING IT -- UNDER THE OLDER
GENERATION SO WITH WITH THAT --
WITH THAT WITH THOSE AMENDMENTS
I'M CERTAINLY HAPPY.
TO SUPPORT ITS APPROVAL -- AND
IT WOULD GO OVER TRANSPORTATION
IF IT PASSES OUT TODAY.
SO -- WHAT WILL TAKE IN IT --
TAKE A MOTION WHEN WE HAVE MORE
MEMBERS HERE BUT A DEPRECIATED
AND I GOT TO GET OVER EDUCATION.
MR THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH YEAH
ALSO YOU EDUCATION LATER.
A GO.
ALL RIGHT -- OKAY.
WILL NOW ASK -- SIMMER SANTIAGO
TO COME FORWARD YOUR PRESENT ON
IMPORT THE LIKE AB -- ELEVEN
NINETY SEVEN WE START IS THE%
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR -- JUST TO
BE ABLE TO STREAMLINE -- SUPPORT
HOUSING -- THAT CAME IN AND AND
WAY OF HHH DOLLARS AND SEE LOS
ANGELS BUT ALSO KEEP DOLLARS --
THAT WE'RE GONNA FROM THE STATE
LAST YEAR IT BECAME MORE EVIDENT
HOW MORE IMPORTANT THIS -- BILL
BECAME ANOTHER WE SEE IN THE
HOMELESS NUMBERS ARE WITHIN OUR
REGION -- HIT I DON'T I DON'T
THINK IT WOULD SURPRISE YOU
WE'VE ALREADY IS ABOUT 16%
INCREASE IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES -- ABOUT A 12% INCREASE
IN THE COUNTY IT'S A WE BELIEVE
THIS BILLS MORE IMPORT THAN EVER
TO BE ABLE TO SEE FOR
STREAMLINED BOTH THE HE DOLLARS
AND THE H. H. H. DOLLARS ARE
BEING USED -- IN LOS ANGELES FOR
ON THE HOMES TO HOUSE THE
WOULD BE ABLE
WELL THANKS OKAY JUST JUST TO
CLARIFY ARE YOU TAKING THE
COMMITMENTS YES YOU KNOW I
APOLOGIZE YES I'M ABSOLUTE TAKEN
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND
THANK YOU IN THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR HARD WORK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
ENTER ENTRY WAS VALUE -- AND WE
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI --
WE THINK THE OTHER FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD -- THE PROBLEM
OF HOMELESSNESS IS ONGOING -- AS
THE AUTHORS MENTIONED -- WE'VE
SEEN IT UNFORTUNATE UP TICK.
IN THE TOTAL NUMBER OF FOLKS
THAT ARE HOMELESS OR HOMES
RUNNABLE IN OUR JURISDICTION
IT'S A TREND THAT'S HAPPENING IN
THE REGION AROUND THE STATE --
EVEN THOUGH WE'VE MADE PROGRESS
WITH THE RESOURCES THAT BEEN
PROVIDED BY THE STATE AND THE
VOTERS APPROVED LOCALLY ON WE'VE
HOUSE TWENTY ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE
IN LOS ANGELES.
THIS WILL HELP THIS WILL PROVIDE
VERY TARGETED HELP AS AMENDED --
WE GET CHALLENGES WITH THE MAYOR
CHALLENGE COUNCIL DISTRICTS TO
PUT SHELTERS ESPECIALLY
TEMPORARY SHELTERS IN EVERY PART
OF THE CITY SO YOU DON'T SEE A
CONCENTRATION. ONE PART OF LOS
ANGELES SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
WE SEE ARE BASED ON THE FUNDING
SOURCE OR ANY OTHER PART OF THE
PROCESS THAT THEY CAN -- USE
UNDER SEQUENCE SO -- THIS KIND
OF A TARGETED ASSISTANCE TO HELP
YOU STAY ON TRACK WITH THE
PRODUCTION OF THESE OF THESE
SHELTERS IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE SUPPORT
[INAUDIBLE]
COM.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT
CENTER WE'RE ON ITEM.
NINETEEN IN YOUR IN YOUR PACKET.
OKAY I DO FULL WHO FOLKS WANT TO
RAISE.
WHICH IS IT WILL PROVIDE
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
ANYONE WANT TO RAISE OPPOSITION
OR RAISE CONCERNS.
WE HAVE A VERY STRONG POSITION
FOR THE BILL -- THIS IS.
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE THAT ANY
QUESTIONS OKAY.
MOVED BY A ARE THE STEAM SENATOR --
SHE TAKING THE MAN'S -- YEAH
THIS IS A YEAH THIS IS A VERY.
AND CAREFULLY -- TARGETED.
TELL THAT ADDRESSES AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE WE KNOW WE ARE DEALING
WITH IN SPADES IN OUR IN OUR
DISTRICT AND AND MUST.
AND SO I'M CERTAINLY HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY -- WITH DEMANDS
AND I THINK IT WILL GO ON TO
OPERATIONS AFTER THAT SO THAT'S
REMOVED IF YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECT LAST RIVALED MISTER A
CHAIR HAND CENTERS THANK YOU
OKAY WHEN WE KALRA. TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
ALLEN HI ALAN.
BATES.
HELLO.
SKINNER STERN DALI.
DALI AYE AYE CASKEY.
OKAY THAT -- WELL THAT OPENED
THE CHECKS THAT I DIDN'T PROJECT.
OKAY.
WELL I THE WORD FOR MOST PATIENT
MEMBER GOES TO US IN A REYES WHO
WAS.
IN AND OUT MUCH THIS MORNING WE
WE DO APPRECIATE THAT AND WE
WILL LOOK KINDLY UPON YOUR BILL
AS A RESULT.
OF YOUR PATIENT FORBEARANCE.
HI THIS IS ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN
IN YOUR AGENDA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THAT
SENATOR -- TODAY PRESENT TO YOU
AB ELEVEN TWENTY THREE WHICH
ENSURES THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND HIS OFFICE RECEIVE
NOTICE OF PROP SIXTY FIVE
APPEALS.
PROP SIXTY FIVE THE SAFE
DRINKING WATER AND TOXIC
ENFORCEMENT ACT OF NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX REQUIRES A BUSINESS
THAT EXPOSES CONSUMERS TO
CHEMICALS.
LISTED AS CARCINOGENS OR
REPRODUCTIVE TOXICANTS TO TO
PROVIDE CLEAR AND REASONABLE
WARNING.
IN ACCORDANCE WITH PROP SIXTY
FIVE PRIVATE CITIZENS CAN
ENFORCE THE STATUTE IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST.
COMPLY THE CITIZENS MUST AND
THEN SEND A NOTICE TO AN ALLEGED
VIOLATOR AND TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL ADVISING OF THE ALLEGED
VIOLATION.
PRIVATE ENFORCERS MUST ALSO
REPORT TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE WHEN THEY FILE A
COMPLAINT OR SETTLEMENT.
THESE REQUIREMENTS ALLOW THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO EVALUATE
CLAIMS THAT ENSURED THAT PRIVATE
ENFORCERS CLAIMS HAVE MERIT AND
THAT PRIVATE LAWSUITS AND
SETTLEMENTS ARE IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE PUBLIC.
HOWEVER THERE IS NO REQUIREMENT
THE PRIVATE ENFORCERS OR
DEFENDANTS REPORT ANY OTHER PROP
SIXTY FIVE ACTIVITIES TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL INCLUDING WHEN
AN APPEALS FILED.
AS A RESULT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE MAYBE ON AWARE OF
PENDING APPEALS AND THE COURT OF
APPEALS ARE FREQUENTLY ASKED. TO
OPINE ON THE LAW WITHOUT THE
BENEFIT OF THE TERM ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE RISKING A
PRESIDENTIAL.
DECISION DAMAGING THE AG'S
AUTHORITY HE AUTHORITY TO
ENFORCE THE LAW.
AB ELEVEN TWENTY THREE OFFERS
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
ANY LITIGATION THAT COULD
ESTABLISH STATEWIDE PRESIDENT
REGARDING THE INTERPRETATION OR
APPLICATION OF PROP.
SIXTY FIVE IT IS ONLY
APPROPRIATE TO THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE BE AWARE OF
APPEALS REGARDING PROP.
SIXTY FIVE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS MONEY --
THERE BUT NOT THOUGH WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBER MY NAME'S MARIO
DE BERNARDO HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
SERRA WHO'S PLEASE.
TO SPONSOR THIS BILL THIS BILL
IS A A SIMPLE YET VERY HELPFUL
MEASURE FOR OUR ATTORNEYS WHO
WORK ON PROP SIXTY FIVE CASES.
EXISTING ALREADY PROVIDES ALL
SORTS OF NOTICE REQUIREMENTS FOR
LITIGANTS AT THE TRIAL COURT
LEVEL WHERE THEY NOTIFY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE AND IF
APPROPRIATE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE CAN GET
INVOLVED -- BUT THERE IS NO SUCH
LAW OR REQUIREMENT FOR NOTICE
FOR APPELLATE CASES AND SO.
THERE HAVE BEEN AT LEAST TWO
CASES RECENTLY WHERE WE DO NOT
HAVE CASES ON OUR RADAR BECAUSE
WE WEREN'T NOTIFIED OF THE
APPEAL.
AND NOT ALL -- PRIVATE ENFORCERS
ARE THE THE BEST ATTORNEYS AND I
MAY MISS REPRESENT THE LAWN THAT
MAY LEAD TO A AN OUTCOME WHERE
THE COURT ESTABLISHES PRESIDENT
THAT COULD BE HARMFUL TO STATE
INTEREST.
ARE THERE AREAS OF THE LAW -- WE
IN THOSE CASES HAVE FILED -- FOR
PETITION -- TO DE PUBLISHED THE
OPINIONS AND WERE SUCCESSFUL IN
DOING THAT WOULD MUCH RATHER DO
THAT -- NOT DO THAT AT THE BACK
AND BUT AT THE FRONT AND GET
INVOLVED IF APPROPRIATE TO
FILING AMICUS BRIEF AND HELP
GUIDE THE LAW.
AND SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
NOTIFIES THE AG WHEN -- PROP
SIXTY FIVE CASES ARE APPEALED
THE VERY SIMILAR PROVISIONS IN
STATUTE RELATED TO CALIFORNIA'S
ABILITY LAWS UNFAIR COMPETITION
SEE C&LT;C.CYAN&GT; AND FALSE CLAIMS.&LT;/C&GT;
SO THIS BASICALLY -- DOES WITH
THOSE LAWS PROVIDE IN TERMS A
NOTICE OF APPEAL.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
FOLKS WHEN IT.
IS EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL.
ANY OPPOSITION -- PEOPLE WONDER
IS CONCERNED.
OKAY I SEE MANY I AM IS BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS THOUGHTS
COMMENTS FROM THE MEMBER -- WE
DO APPRECIATE THIS I'M CERTAINLY
SUPPORTING IT HAD.
ARE YOU INTERESTED IN THE
COURTESY MOTION.
OKAY ALL RIGHT APPRECIATE THAT
SENATOR -- TAKE IT WITH A THIRD
OF ITS COLOR.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB ELEVEN
TWENTY THREE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ALAN
AYE ALLEN AYE BATES.
GILL SKINNER STERN DOLLY
[INAUDIBLE]
I CASKEY.
OKAY SO HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
THE MERCED ON WE DO APPRECIATE.
YOUR PATIENCE TODAY AND
ABSOLUTELY THANK.
BY SIMPLY SKIP BILL AND THANK
YOU TAKE THE RIGHT.
OKAY HOPEFULLY WE GET MORE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS DOWN WE DO SEE
A SERVER QUIRK SILVA THIS YEAR.
THE FEAR IF YOU SEE VISITORS A
COUPLE TIMES TODAY.
MAYBE ONCE.
WE LIKE SEEING YOU SO LET'S --
LET'S NOW TURN ITEM FOR YOUR
DENTIST THIS IS AB.
ONE FORTY THREE AND IT HAS TO DO
WITH TO COMMITTEES THE TWO
COUNTIES. THREE THREE ENTITIES
THAT HAVE JUST SO SIMILAR
ALAMEDA IN ORANGE [INAUDIBLE]
THE VERY.
WHAT AT THE SAME POLITICS?
MAYBE MAYBE MORE SO NOW ALL
RIGHT SO WILL -- WAS RECEIVING
QUE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
CONGRATULATIONS TO THE NEW
SENATOR STIR DOLLY -- WE I AM
HAPPY TO BE FREE SAID TEEN
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY THREE
WHICH EXPANDS EMERGENCY HOUSING
TO INCLUDE HOMELESS SHELTERS AND
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING --
THAT WOULD INCLUDE ORANGE COUNTY
THE COUNTY OF ALAMEDA AND THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE AS WELL AS
OTHER COUNTIES AND CITIES
ALREADY INCLUDED IN THIS CURRENT
LAW THAT DECLARING -- SHELTER
CRISIS.
AS WE KNOW OLD CALIFORNIA IS
FACING ONE OF THEIR MOST
CHALLENGING HOUSING CRISIS -- I
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE SEEN AND
SADLY.
JUST THIS LAST YEAR AN ORANGE
COUNTY WE'VE HAD NOW CLOSE TO
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY DEATHS
IN ORANGE COUNTY WITH FIFTEEN
THIS LAST MONTH OF MAY -- WE'VE
ALSO SEEN HOMELESSNESS RISE AND
MANY COUNTIES THAT ARE WORKING
VERY HARD TO PREVENT THIS OF AN
INCREASE.
BY 12% -- IN LOS ANGELES -- IT
NOW UP 216% SAN FRANCISCO UP AN
INCREASE OF 17% AND ALAMEDA --
HAS NOW JUMPED 2403% INCREASE
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS.
AND IN MY DISTRICT ALSO 42% --
SO WE KNOW THAT -- THERE'S NOT
ONE SOLUTION TO SOLVING THIS BUT
CERTAINLY INCREASE SEEN OUR
HOUSING WITH PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND BEING
ABLE TO GET THE MERCHANTS THE
SHELTERS BUILT.
BUILT IN A SHORTER TIME LINE --
COULD START -- TO MAKE SOME
BREAKTHROUGHS FOR THIS SO WITH
ME TODAY -- WE HAVE -- NICOLE
WARDER MEN ON OF ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF SERVICE SUPERVISORS AND
MONICA.
MONICA MILLER FROM ALAMEDA -- SO
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS NICOLE
ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
ONE FORTY THREE THE BILL WOULD
EXPEDITE THE PROVISION OF
SHELTER FOR THE COUNTIES AND-SHELTERED HOMELESS POPULATION.
HOMELESSNESS IS ONE OF THE MOST
URGENT ISSUES FACING THE COUNTY.
IN JANUARY THE COUNTY CONDUCTED
ITS HOMELESSNESS POINT IN TIME
COUNT SHOWING AN INCREASE OF 42%
IN THE HOMELESS POPULATION TO
ALMOST. 700058% OF WHOM ARE AND
SHELTERED.
THE COUNTY HAS BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OFEMERGENCY SHELTERS
WITHIN THE SYSTEM OF CARE.
INCREASING THAT NUMBER BY
110021% BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AB ONE
FORTY THREE WOULD PERMIT THE
COUNTY GREATER FLEXIBILITY FOR
THE PROVISION OF SHELTER.
WHILE REQUIRING THE COUNTY TO
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE ON THE
STATE OF HOMELESSNESS AND
HOUSING.
BALANCING BOTH LOCAL AND STATE
GOALS THEREFORE THE COUNTY URGES
AN AYE VOTE ON AB.
ONE FORTY THREE MISTER CHAIR
SENATOR MONICA MILLER
REPRESENTED THE COUNTY OF
ALAMEDA AND WE TO SUPPORT AB ONE
FORTY THREE IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT THAT THIS
IS.
BUILDING UPON A MEASURE THAT
WENT THROUGH INTO 200-017-8930
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER PHIL TEEN --
IT'S A PILOT PROGRAM THEY WANT
TO SEE IF IT WORKS I THINK ALL
THE COUNTIES AND THE CITIES THAT
ARE INVOLVED IN IT WANT TO MAKE
SURE.
THAT IT WORKS WITH THE ALSO TO
MAKE SURE THEY HAVE ALL THE
TOOLS IN THEIR TOOL BOX TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
ON AS HE SOMEONE MENTIONED -- WE
JUMPED UP 43% WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE POINT IN TIME COUNT IF
YOU'RE NOT FAMILIAR WITH THAT
IT'S ONE DAY.
SO YOU'RE MISSING THOSE THAT
MAYBE GOT A HOTEL THAT NIGHT
MAYBE WERE ABLE TO COUNT SERVE
THAT NIGHT EXCITER AS WE KNOW
THAT THAT IS NOT EVEN AFTER
REFLECTION.
OF WHAT OUR HOMELESSNESS
POPULATION LOOKS LIKE AND
ALAMEDA COUNTY WE SUCCESSFULLY
PASSED ON A BOND TO ABA HELP
BUILD UPON ON PROVIDING SHELTERS
EXCITER WE ALSO HAVE TO TAKE.
THE PARKING ORDINANCE OF PEOPLE
CAN PARKING THEIR CAR SAFELY AND
ON IN DESIGNATED AREAS EXCESSIVE
THIS JUST GIVES US GET ANOTHER
TOOL IN OUR TOOLBOX AND THEN.
AT THE END WE WILL HAVE TO
REPORT BACK TO THE STATE TO SEE
DID THIS BILL WORK DID DID THIS
PROGRAM WORKS THAT'S GOING TO
GIVE YOU.
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR.
A REALLY GOOD SNAPSHOT OF WHAT'S
WORKING ON IN OUR COUNTIES AND
FOR THAT THOSE REASONS WE ARE
TONIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THIS WAS ONE OF MY
SUPPORT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS JEAN HEARST YOU'RE
SAYING WE HAVE FOR THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NOTES HERE ON BEHALF
OF LOS ANGELES CITY MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI SUPPORT.
AARON TAYLOR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
OKAY -- ANYONE WANT TO RAISE
OPPOSITION CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL.
I SEE NINE THE MATTERS BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE TO MOVE --
QUESTIONS FIVE ISSUES OKAY.
I'M REMOVED I'LL TAKE THAT AS A
CLOSE A LIST OF RESET YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU OKAY GREAT
WELL I'M TRULY SUPPORT AND AND
AND I GUESS THE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
ASPECT WAS CALLED.
ADAM NUMBER FOUR AB ONE FORTY
THREE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ALLEN HI ALLEN HI
BATES.
FILL.
SKINNER STERN DALI.
DALI AYE AYE CASKEY.
OKAY THANK YOU RIGHT HERE WHAT
WE'RE WILL HOLD THE RELEVANCE OF
THEIR NUMBERS COUNTY THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
OKAY -- SO WE SHOULD CALL SOONER
GLORIA AND WE SHOULD ALSO BE
CALLING THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THIS IS IS LESTER BATES ON OUR
WAY.
IF YOU HAVE EVER THOSE ARE.
AFTER LEARNING THIS IS BATES
COMING -- FIFTY EIGHT IF THE
NAVY HAS ON CONSENT OKAY I'M
SORRY THAT'S RIGHT.
SO GONZALEZ AND BLOOM OKAY WHEN
WE OPEN THE ROLE ON A VERY SIDE
AND SO THAT WE CAN ALLOW THE TWO
MISSED OUT ON SO WHEN WE START
WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WELL I HAVEN'T ACTUALLY.
INTERNET -- SO.
THE SECOND IS A CRITICAL CONSENT
CALENDAR -- ITEMS NUMBER ONE
ELEVEN TWELVE TWENTY ONE AND
TWENTY TWO ALLEN HI ASIDE AND
THREE SIXTY DEGREE CS ONE FORTY
TWO REALLY NEAT LEAD ACID
BATTERIES.
YOU'RE LAYING ON OKAY THAT'S
RIGHT -- ITEM FOR QUIRK SILVA WE
JUST DID AND FIVE CRISTINA
GARCIA IS USE MATTRESS.
YOU WERE ABLE TO OKAY LET'S KEEP
LOOKING -- I THINK IT IS A VOTE
FOR THE FRIEDMAN BILL.
WITH THIS ITEM SEVEN THIS IS A
BETWEEN FIVE FRIEDMAN TOUGHER
TRANSITION PLAN.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TWO EIGHTY
FIVE THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
CHAIR AT NOT VOTING IT HAS A
VOTED AT FASTER VOTED NO ALLEN
HI ALLEN HI.
HILL SKINNER [INAUDIBLE]
OKAY.
NOW ON THE QUIRK BILL ON THIS IS
NOT ACTUALLY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER BATES BUT BUT WE DAM CAST
A VOTE YET.
AT THAT POINT.
OKAY FIRST.
OKAY SO IT'S LONG WEEK ONE CALL
ROLAND -- ANIMATE.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWO NINETY
TWO THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WATER COMMITTEE.
I AM ALLEN.
ALLEN HI BATES HILL SKINNER.
STERN.
DOLLY DOLLY II WHY CASKEY.
OKAY WE'LL HOLD THAT OPEN AS A
TWO ZERO VOTE AT THIS POINT.
ALL RIGHT -- THEN BRINGS US.
TO ADD YOUR COURAGE BILL THIS IS
ITEM FOURTEEN A. B. -- EIGHT
FIFTEEN IN EVERY WAY SPECIAL
PLANS.
YOU'RE SAYING ON THAT ONE OKAY
NO PROBLEM -- THEN LET'S GO TO
KALRA IS -- ITEM.
SEVENTEEN THIS IS THE BOB SMALL
PLASTIC BOTTLES LODGING
ESTABLISHMENTS.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
YES THAT'S ALREADY MACASKILL
TASK YEAH -- YOU'RE NOT OKAY.
SO DOLLARS NO NO VOTER NO.
THE NUMBER YOU VOTING NO AND YOU
NEED TO VOTE OKAY I HAVE TO VOTE
ON THE BLANCA RUBIO BILL.
THE TEN NINETY THREE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN AB TEN NINETY THREE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
AT MEISTER VOTING AYE ALLEN
ALLEN AYE HILL.
STERN AYE CASKEY [INAUDIBLE]
OKAY.
OKAY THAT'S FOUR ZERO THE KALRA
BILL IS NOW [INAUDIBLE] TO TO
LET'S DO THE O'DONNELL BELL.
THAT ONE NEEDS A MOTION.
OKAY THIS ITEM -- EIGHTEEN AS
AMENDED -- THIS IS AB ELEVEN
NINETY FIVE O'DONNELL.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN A. B.
ELEVEN NINETY FIVE THE MOTION IS
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE.
SENATE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
ALLEN HI ALLEN HI BATES.
GILL SKINNER.
STERN.
DOLLY.
DALY AYE AYE CASKEY.
OKAY SO THAT'S TWO ZERO SO FAR
WILL HOLD THAT OPEN.
AND I THINK THAT'S IT FOR THAT
OKAY GREAT [INAUDIBLE]
CONCERN [INAUDIBLE]
OKAY
.
HI LET'S BRIEFLY RECESS UNTIL --
THE THANK YOU WE'RE GOING TO
BRIEFLY.
RECESS.
UNTIL WE GET -- AN OFFICE.
AND PLEASE BE INTENSELY YEAH
[INAUDIBLE]
YEAH
WELL [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT WE ARE GOING.
TO RECONVENE OUR ROBUSTLY
ATTENDED COMMITTEE -- TODAY HERE
AT Q..
AND UNFORTUNATELY.
OUR MEMBERS ARE EITHER
PRESENTING OR AND OR OR IT AND
BUDGET OR AND AND THINKING SO
HERE WE ARE -- BUT WE'RE GONNA
HEAR ITEM TWENTY THREE THIS IS
AB.
SEVENTEEN THIRTY AND YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN WHEN I MISTER
CHAIRMAN AT AB SEVENTY THREE
WHAT EXTEND THE DEADLINE FOR THE
SANTEE SSOCIATION GOVERNMENTS
TO FINALIZE A NEW REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLAN BY TWO YEARS.
HISTORICALLY SANDBAG HE'S BEEN
CRITICIZED FOR NOT PRIORITIZING
AND INVESTING IN AN UP PUBLIC
TRANSIT BIKE AND PEDESTRIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE.
HOWEVER OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS
AGENCIES GONE THROUGH DIPLOMATIC
CHANGES WITH DRAMATIC NEW
LEADERSHIP [INAUDIBLE]
AS IN.
WHEN SENATE WE AND TO WORK ON
THE UPDATED RTP FOR TWENTY
NINETEEN IT BECAME CLEAR THAT
THE CURRENT?
PERCENT TARGET EVEN THOUGH
MEANINGFUL CHANGE HAS OCCURRED
AS A RESULT OF THE RECENT
SCANDALS AND BOARD RESTRUCTURING
AND NEW EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
LASTING CHANGE TO DEVELOP THE
RIGHT TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM IN
SAN DIEGO REGION DOES NOT HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT.
IT'S CREDIT IT'S CRUCIAL FOR OUR
REGION.
THAT RATHER THAN TRY TO SLAP A
BANDAID ON TO THE PROM AND
PRETEND EVERYTHING WILL BE OKAY
WE TAKE THE TIME TO MAKE DRASTIC
CHANGES NECESSARY IN ORDER TO
MEET NEXT.
IN FACT EXCEED THESE GOALS AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY WILL GIVE US
THE TIME TO MAKE THIS RIGHT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NIGHT OUT.
IF YOU.
HI WHAT EXACTLY DIRECTOR FOR
SANDBAG -- WE ARE SPONSORING AND
AND THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS -- AS
SHE MENTIONED WE DO NEED THE
TIME TO FINISH -- WORKING ON OUR
NEXT MAJOR UPDATE OF OUR
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION PLAN SCS --
THAT 90% IS AMBITIOUS AND WE'RE
UP TO DEVELOPING BASICALLY WORLD
CLASS TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM THAT
INVESTING PUBLIC TRANSIT
PROVIDES MEANINGFUL OPTIONS TO
THE CAR -- LOOKS ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION BASICALLY -- MEET
ME TO EXCEED SIX H. G. TARGETS
IN THE MEANTIME WE NEED -- TO
ALSO PREPARE FEDERAL UPDATE TO
THE PLAN SO THAT FEDERAL FUNDING
DOESN'T LAPS AND WERE ABLE TO
CONTINUE THE PROJECTS ARE IN
PROGRESS WE HAVE SOME MAJOR
PROJECTS UNDER WAY LIKE A TWO
BILLION DOLLAR MID COAST.
QUARTER TROLLEY UP --
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT IT'S ABOUT
HALFWAY THROUGH THAT'S RELIANT
ON ABOUT BILLION DOLLARS WITH
THE FEDERAL FUNDING WE HAVE SOME
IMPROVEMENTS TO OUR NORTH COAST
COASTAL CORRIDOR AND INTERSTATE
FIVE WHICH ARE VITAL GOODS
MOVEMENT ON TO WIN THE MIDDLE
MIDDLE.
OF PREPARING A AND ARE TO BE
UPDATE FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT -- WE'D LIKE TO RELY
ON THE TWENTY FIFTEEN PLAN AN E.
I. R. WHICH BASICALLY HAS THE
SAME PROJECTS AND PROGRAMS WERE
JUST MAKING UPDATES TO PROJECT
CALLS.
SOME MINOR SCHEDULE UPDATES AND
BASICALLY OUR FINANCIAL
ASSUMPTIONS THAT WOULD LIKE TO
RELY ON THAT REQUEST A ONE TIME
SEQUEL EXEMPTION SO WE CAN
SUBMIT THAT FEDERAL PLAN -- AND
AND MOVE IT THROUGH THIS BILL
HAS BROAD SUPPORT FROM THE
CITIES -- IN THE COUNTY -- FROM
LABOR ENVIRONMENTAL BUSINESS AND
COMMUNITY GROUPS AND NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION SO WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DRIVE OUT.
THANK YOU I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WERE TOP ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO
WE ALSO ARE CO SPONSORS OF THE
MEASURE.
THE CITY -- HAS EMBARKED UPON --
A FAIRLY AGGRESSIVE -- CLIMATE
ACTION PLAN OF THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS WE SEE SANDBAGGING WE KNOW
THAT SANTA I GUESS A INTEGRAL
PARTNER IN ORDER FOR US TO MEET
OUR CLIMATE ACTION GOALS OVER
THE NEXT -- DECADE OR OR LONGER.
WE HAVE BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE NEED FOR REFORM IN
TRANSITION AT STANDARD HAVE BEEN
SUPPORT OF OF THE AUTHORS BILL
PRIOR BILLS -- TO TO REALLY
INSTITUTE THAT REFORM WE PLAY AN
ACTIVE ROLE AT THE SANDBAG --
BOARD LEVEL.
AND AND AND AGAIN SEE OURSELVES
AS PARTNERS THIS MEASURE THIS
BILL IS IMPORTANT FOR US TO
REALLY GET IT RIGHT WE THINK
HURRIEDLY PUTTING TOGETHER -- ON
OUR TP.
A A REPORT OR A PLAN AND IN SCS --
DOESN'T SERVE ANYBODY'S PURPOSES
WELL WE NEED TO TAKE THE TIME TO
DO IT RIGHT.
I'M TWO YEARS IS -- WHILE IT
MIGHT SEEM LIKE A LONG TIME IT'S
REALLY NOT A LONG TIME IN TERMS
OF THE PLANNING PERSPECTIVE --
SO WE THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT
FOR US TO MEET OUR CLIMATE
ACTION GOALS.
DRIVE UP TO KEEP.
HI FOLKS HONOR OF EXTRA SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL. FOR THE CITY OF
AND ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THE ONE SIX WAS OPPOSITION OR
CONCERNS.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE LORRAINE IS ALL
BILL WITHOUT ANY OPPOSITION.
IT'S GOING TO BE.
USED TO IT.
ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT WELL THAT'S
A SEE IF THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS --
I I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
BILL AND AND AND I WAS VERY
TARGETED IN.
YOU GET SOME BEFORE THESE ARE
WORKING ON RIGHT THERE IT'S AN
EXCEL -- I'M SURE THE SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
AND WHEN WE HAVE.
OTHER MEMBERS WILL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION AND ASK FOR IT TO BE
PASSED OVER TO CENTER
PREPARATIONS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [INAUDIBLE]
I APPRECIATED.
WE NEED.
TO GET A COMPATIBLE
.
I NOT JUST ELECTED TO THE
COUNCIL AND HERE CHECK OUT THE
CAPITAL FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER.
SO YOU'RE VERY WELCOME HERE BIG
ROUND OF LESTER'S CASTMEMBER
MARANDA.
SO WHEN I WAS A IN MY PRESENCE
DEMOCRAT HIGH SCHOOL HE WAS OUR
VICE PRESIDENT HE REALLY RAN THE
SHOW.
SO IT'S GOOD.
TO SEE GREG I'M GLAD TO SEE
VALLEY SPORTING A BEARD.
IT'S A IT'S IT'S TAKEN AWHILE
BUT YOUR YOUR YOU KNOW.
IT'S GOOD IT'S GOOD.
SO ARE YOU IS GONNA GET JOKES.
RODENTICIDE JOKES IS A NOT A
FUNNY TOPIC I GUESS NO WORK.
WE'RE GONNA GET THAT HANDLED SO.
HERE WE GO ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION IS CALLING FOR ME ALL
RIGHT SO I'M GONNA GO OVER THERE
AND I'M IN IT.
UNFORTUNATELY -- LEAVE YOU BUT
WE HAVE NOTHING TO HEAR NOW
ANYWAY.
WELL WE'LL RECESS OF TEMPORARILY
AGAIN
--
OKAY LET'S RECONVENE
THE SENATE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE AND LET'S GIVE OUR
AN OPPORTUNITY TO ADD ON THE
VOTES THAT HAVE BEEN CAST SO FAR.
SO LET'S START WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SYNCING COUNTER
SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL US AT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE
ITEMS NUMBER ONE ELEVEN TWELVE
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY TWO AT
HILL.
HELLO I STERN [INAUDIBLE]
STERN HI.
WE ARE STILL WAITING -- FOR BOB
CASKEY OKAY.
THE NEXT ITEM IS COOPER'S.
THE BILL AS SIGNIFICANTLY
AMENDED THIS IS AB ONE TWENTY
SIX CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE PROJECT.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB ONE TWENTY
SIX THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE ACCEPTED A MEN'S AND
DROPPED THE INCOME CAP. FOR
FOLKS.
CHAIR VOTING I BY STRUGGLING NO
HILL.
HILL AYE SKINNER [INAUDIBLE]
I CASKEY.
THAT'S FOUR ZERO I JUST SAW THE
AUTHORED A SIMILAR BLOOM WALK IN
SO WHY DON'T WE TAKE HIS BILL
WILL CONTINUE WITH THE REST OF
THE ROLE.
WE GET MORE MEMBERS BUT YOU'RE
VERY WELCOME.
AND YOU MAY PRESENT WHEN READY
THIS IS A ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
FOUR IN YOUR JENNA MEMBERS THIS
IS AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT RELATING
TO PESTICIDES AND THE SENATE.
MAYBE ONE READY GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SOME ANTI
COAGULANT RODENTICIDE BECAUSE
ANIMALS TO BLEED OUT INTERNALLY
AND ALSO DISRUPTS THEIR IMMUNE
SYSTEMS NATURAL ABILITY TO FIGHT
OFF INFECTIONS AND AFFLICTIONS
SUCH AS MANGE.
AND THREE MAJOR OUTLINED STUDIES
CURRENTLY BEING CONDUCTED IN
CALIFORNIA.
RODENTICIDE HAVE APPEARED IN
EVERY TISSUE SAMPLE TAKEN FROM
WILD ADULT.
LIONS AT LEVELS HIGH ENOUGH TO
BE OF SERIOUS CONCERN AND IN
ANOTHER STUDY REGARDING THE
ENDANGERED.
PACIFIC FISHER IT'S BEEN SHOWN
NOT TO HAVE NEGATIVE IMPACTS.
ON A IT HAS SHOWN THE NEGATIVE
IMPACTS AND THREATS THAT
RODENTICIDE POSE AND ITS
CONTRIBUTION TO THAT SPECIES
NEAR EXTINCTION.
AND JUST LAST WEEK ON JUNE
TWELFTH A NEW STUDY CAME OUT ON
THE ENDANGERED SAN JOAQUIN KIT
FOX POPULATION.
THE STUDY FOUND THAT RODENTICIDE
EXPOSURE COMBINED WITH LAND
DEVELOPMENT ARE NEGATIVELY
IMPACTING THAT POPULATION.
THIS IS NOT A NEW ISSUE AND IN
FACT SINCE THE LATE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE OF SEVERAL
DOWNSIDES THAT RHODE ISLAND
SIDES ARE HAVING.
ON ALL WILDLIFE IN THE STATE AS
A RESULT OF THESE WARNINGS IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION ENACTED REGULATIONS
TO RESTRICT THE USE.
OF SECOND GENERATION
ANTICOAGULANT RODENTICIDE.
IN THE HOPES OF DECREASING THE
NON TARGETED DEATHS.
BUT THESE REGULATIONS HAVE NOT
RESULTED IN A DECREASE IN
SECONDARY WILDLIFE POISONINGS
INSTEADTHEY STAYED CONSTANT.
OR HAVE INCREASED IN SOME
INSTANCES.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
PROHIBITS THE USE OF SECOND
GENERATION ANTI COAGULANT
RODENTICIDE THROUGH OUT THE
STATE.
AND ALSO PROHIBITS THE USE OF
FIRST GENERATION ANTICOAGULANTS
ON STATE OWNEDPROPERTY.
THERE ARE EXEMPTIONS FOR
AGRICULTURAL AND FOOD PROCESSING
USES IN THE BILL.
NEW ENVIRONMENTALLY RESPONSIBLE
AND MORE HUMANE MEANS OF
CONTROLLING RODENT POPULATIONS
ARE INCREASINGLY BEING
SUCCESSFULLY IS BY THE HOUSE
MANAGEMENT INDUSTRY.
INCLUDING ACCORDING TO THE
OPPOSITION A NEW ANTI COAGULANT
RODENTICIDE THAT DOESN'T
PROCESSED AFTER THE TARGETED
ANIMAL HAS INGESTED.
MY OFFICE AND SPONSORS ARE
WORKING WITH LIFE SCIENCES AND
WILL HOPEFULLY HAVE A RESOLUTION
TO THEIR ISSUE SOON.
AND WE'RE LOOKING TO GO INTO THE
POISON CONTROL OPERATORS
REQUESTED LANGUAGE.
ARE THAT WE HAVE TO OF I ONLY
RECEIVED IN -- AND CONCEPT AT
THIS POINT.
I WITH ME TODAY ARE LISA OWNS
VIANI WITH.
RAPTORS ARE THE SOLUTION -- ONE
OF MY FAVORITE ACRONYM.
RATS OF A AND DR LORETTA.
MEYER -- THE CEO OF THANK YOU A
PEST MANAGEMENT COMPANY
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU -- YES TRUE IT'S TOUGH
FOR THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIANS TO
HEAR.
THE RAPTOR OF THE ERA.
YOU HAVE SUPPORT FROM TORONTO.
THAT SAID GAME.
WE WERE ALL CALIFORNIANS A
MOMENT OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN ALAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY MY NAME
IS LISA OWNS THE ANI AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF RAPTORS ARE
THE SOLUTION IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT IN TWENTY
ELEVEN A NEIGHBOR CAME RUNNING
TO MY HOUSE SECURING THE BODIES
OF TWO YOUNG COOPER'S HAWKS.
THEY HAD DROWNED IN HIS YOUNG
SON SWIMMING POOL BLEEDING TO
DEATH.
HIS SON WAS TRAUMATIZED BY
WITNESSING THIS AS WAS HE TESTS
REVEALED THAT THE HAWKS HAVE
BEEN POISONED AFTER EATING
POISONED RESIDENTS.
QUESTIONS FOUND IN THEIR LIVERS
WERE SECOND GENERATION ANTI
COAGULANT SO STRONG THEY ARE
MARKETED AS ONE FEEDING KILLS.
I QUICKLY DISCOVERED THAT
SECONDARY POISONING WAS A
STATEWIDE PROBLEM AFFECTING ALL
OF THE BENEFICIAL WILDLIFE THAT
HELP US CONTROL RESIDENTS
NATURALLY.
OWLS HAWKS EAGLES BOXES MOUNTAIN
LIONS BOBCATS AND MANY OTHERS.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN DUE TO THE
DANGER THESE PRODUCTS POSE TO
NON TARGET WILDLIFE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION REMOVE THEM FROM
CONSUMER SHELVES.
WHATEVER SCIENTIFIC DATA
COLLECTED SINCE THAT TIME SO THE
PROBLEM HAS NOT IMPROVED.
BECAUSETHE PEST CONTROL
INDUSTRY CONTINUES TO USE THESE
PRODUCTS WIDELY.
STUDIES SHOW THAT POISON RODENTS
ARE PREFERENTIALLY PREYED UPON
BECAUSE THEY'RE SIX SLUGGISH AND
EASIER TO CATCH.
RODENTS GO INTO POISON BAIT
BOXES AND COME BACK OUT TOXIC
TIME BOMBS FOR WILDLIFE.
STUDIES IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN BY UC
DAVIS U. C. L. A. AND THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF SCIENCES
FOUND THAT 70% OF NORTHERN
SPOTTED OWLS A THREATENED
SPECIES.
TESTED POSITIVE FOR ROB BASIN
MORE THAN 85% OF CALIFORNIA
MOUNTAIN LIONS BOBCATS AND
PACIFIC FISHERS HAVE EXPOSED TO
THESE DANGEROUS POISONS.
THE PRESENCE DO NOT IMMEDIATELY
KILL THESE ANIMALS THEY CAN HAVE
SUB LEGAL IMPACTS INCLUDING
AFFECTING THE IMMUNE SYSTEM.
THIS MEANS THAT WILDLIFE ARE
LESS ABLE TO FEND OFF TO SEE
DISEASES LIKE MANGE.
RIGHT PRISON HAS SO SUCCESSFULLY
INFILTRATED OUR ECOSYSTEMS IT
MIGHT BE CONSIDERED OUR NEW DDT.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT AS A
COMMON SENSE BILL TARGETED THE
VERY WORST OF THESE POISONS
DESPITE ISINFORMATION SPREAD BY
THE PEST CONTROL INDUSTRY THIS
BILL CONTAINS A CLEAR EXEMPTION.
FOR USE DURING ANY TYPE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY.
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY THANK YOU I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DOCTOR
LORETTA MAYOR AND I'M THE CHIEF
SCIENCE OFFICER AND FOUNDER.
OF SENESTE TACK OF PUBLIC
BIOTECHNOLOGY COMPANY FOCUSED ON
HUMANE ANIMAL POPULATION.
MANAGEMENT MY BACKGROUND IS IN
REPRODUCTIVE TOXICOLOGY IN
ENDOCRINOLOGY I'M ALSO JOINED
TODAY.
WITH SCIENCE COLLEAGUES
SPECIALIZING IN EVOLUTIONARY
BIOLOGY POPULATION DYNAMICS AND
RODENT FIELD BEHAVIOR AND
DEVELOP DEPLOYMENT CONDITIONS.
WRITING ROUTE POPULATIONS ON
RHODEN DISEASES WITHOUT SCARS IS
AN INHERENTLY LOSING BATTLE.
AS CARS ARE LETHAL THEY SUSPEND
THE COAGULATION SYSTEM WHERE THE
VITAMIN K. PATHWAY.
CAUSING ANIMALS TO BLEED OUT
OVER DAYS MAKING THEM OFF BARGER
CONTRACT PRAY.
FURTHER THE LEAN THE HALF LIFE.
OF THESE COMPOUNDS WHICH CAN BE
MONTHS LEADS TO PERSISTENCE OF
THE POISON WITHIN DEAD RATS IN
THEIR PREDATORS.
THE RESULTS RANGE FROM RAPID
DEATH.
WHICH MIGHT BE EXPERIENCED BY
RAPTORS OR BIOACCUMULATION
WITHIN THE PREDATOR.
WHICH MIGHT BE EXPERIENCED BY
MOUNTAIN LIONS AS WE'VE SEEN.
PART.
THE INCONVENIENT TRUTH FOR ASK
OUR STRATEGIES IS THAT.
YOU'LL NEVER KILL THE MALL.
AND ALL THOSE THAT DO NOT DIE.
OUR ASKAR RESISTANT.
AND CAN BREED UP TO FIFTEEN
THOUSAND PROGENY OR POPS.
AIR PER YEAR.
UTILITY CONTROLLERS OF CONTROL
STRATEGY VALIDATED BY A
CONSORTIUM OF INTERNATIONAL
SCIENTISTS OVER THE LAST THREE
DECADES.
AND IT WILL NOT LEAD TO DEAD
INFECTED CARCASSES WILL NOT
KILLED PREDATOR SPECIES ARE LEAD
TO RESISTANCE.
WHAT WILL TARGET THE ROOT
PROBLEM AND THE ROOT CAUSE OF
THIS PROBLEM?
IS REPRODUCTION.
RATS THE CONSUME THESE PRODUCTS
SUCH AS CARTER PASSED WHICH OUR
COMPANY MAKES.
STOP READING IMMEDIATELY AND
32406% REDUCTION IN RODENT
POPULATIONS AND CONTINUED
REDUCTIONS.
WHICH CAN BE MANAGED BY
MECHANICAL OR EXCLUSION
PRACTICES.
THE HALF LIFE OF THE ACTIVE
INGREDIENTS IN THIS PRODUCT IS
LESS THAN FOURTEEN MINUTES.
AND IT'S CLEARED BY THE ANIMAL.
THEREFORE IT DOES NOT
BIOACCUMULATE.
IT'S ALL YOUR FAVORITE THINGS
SWEET SALT AND FAT.
IN A NANO PARTICLE.
THAT'S ATTRACTIVE AND HIGHLY
PALATABLE IT'S ENGINEERED SO
THAT THE A. I. CONCENTRATIONS
ARE BELOW POINT 0009%.
COUNTER PASSES REGISTERED BY THE
EPA AND THE CALIFORNIA DPR.
AND CAN BE USED AS DIRECTED TO
CONTROL RODENTS AS PART OF ANY.
INTEGRATED APPROACH OR AS A
MAINTENANCE TOOL.
WE HAD WE MUST.
MUST ADVANCE BEYOND THE
STRATEGIES OF THE PAST CENTURY.
WE'VE BEEN KILLING THESE RATS
FOR CENTURIES.
AND WE MIGHT TRY A DIFFERENT
APPROACH BECAUSE IT IS JUST
UNCONSCIONABLE TO ME.
THAT THE AMERICAN EAGLE COULD BE
CALM THE PROVERBIAL CANARY IN
THE MINE.
AND THE MINUS OUR PLANET.
SO WITH THAT WE SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT AND
I AND MY COLLEAGUES WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH.
OKAY LET'S HEAR FROM FOLKS WHO
ONE EXPRESS SUPPORT FROM ABOVE.
RICHARD CHARTER THE OCEAN
FOUNDATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
READY WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN SUPPORT ALSO
REGISTRY SUPPORTS THE CLEAN
WATER ACTION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ON A SIDE TRIP IS A LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHARLES WATSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY MELTED IN SUPPORT I HAVE.
JEAN HEARST HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE VENTURA COUNTY
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CALEY I'M AN
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE STUDENT
HERE AT SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY AND I'M IN SUPPORT.
SELECT.
HI MY NAME IS PAUL DENNING A
FROM DISTRICT.
THIRTEEN AND IT YEAH THANKS
THANKS JERRY -- AND I'M TOTALLY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS THANK YOU.
COOL HAT.
I AM NOT IN THE CLAIM AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL FOR THE
ANIMALS THANK YOU.
BUT I AM ALSO BERNARD I'M FROM
DISTRICT SIX AND SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
YES WE WHICH ARE YOUR AUNT'S WE
GO LAKERS -- HERE'S A US TO
SUPPORT THE BILL ON BEHALF OF
THE HUMANE SOCIETY WOULD I
STATES AND THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES.
AND ALSO TO REPORT THAT -- THE
CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS HAS
RECENTLY ADOPTED A SUPPORT
POSITION OUR LETTERS FORTHCOMING
GREAT THANK YOU.
IT'S A FAIR AFRICA OVER THE
PLANNING CONSERVATION LANGAN
SUPPORT ALSO REGISTERING SUPPORT
FOR NATIONAL WILDLIFE FEDERATION
AS THEIR STATE AFFILIATE ACTORS
ARE THE SOLUTION AND WAS A
FEMALE.
QUOTE THANK YOU.
MY LARGER GOES FROM SAN JOSE AND
SUPPORT.
NICHOLAS SACKETT SOCIAL
COMPASSION LEGISLATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER FEARING
ON BEHALF OF THE MOUNTAIN LION
FOUNDATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MORNING CAM BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS OF LA RIVER AND THE
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT AND SUPPORT.
WHEN THE BRAMBLE REPRESENTING IN
DEFENSE OF ANIMALS STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU?
JANET PREVEZA BE PRESENTING THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
RAPTORS ARE THE SOLUTION.
AND THERE'S A THIRD.
THE OVER A PROJECT PIETY SORRY
AB JUNKIE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
FEDERAL GENERAL COUNSEL WITHOUT
LÏNG FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
FOR CALLING CLUB CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
AFTERNOON JENNIFER KENNEDY --
WITH THE HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE
UNITED STATES REPRESENTED EL
DORADO COUNTY AND STRONG SUPPORT
AND JUNIOR YES THANK YOU.
HELLO THERE ERIN HELGI ON BEHALF
OF PROJECT COYOTE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY.
AND HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE UNITED
STATES IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
ANA TOMLINSON PROJECT HIGHER
WOODY AND CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
WILDLIFE REHABILITATED AS IN
STRONG SUPPORT RAT POISON KILLS
MORE THAN RATS [INAUDIBLE]
MR.
I'M STEVEN SCHUSTER I'M GONNA
LUCHAR BIOLOGISTS FROM NORTHERN
ARIZONA UNIVERSITY -- MY STUDIES
INDICATE THAT -- TOXINS LIKE RAT
POISONS STRONGLY LEAD TO THE
EVOLUTION OF RESISTANCE WITH
SOMETHING THAT'S A MAJOR ONGOING
PROBLEM.
THAT'S THE SIDES ARE CONSTANTLY.
REQUIRED TO KEEP RED POPULATIONS
AND CONTROL.
FERTILITY CONTROL AS THE OFFICE
THAT IS TO REDUCE BUCKLEY.
SO I STRONGLY OR ALLOW THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP IN
SUPPORT ON AND ON BEHALF OF THE
HUMAN ELEMENT IN THIS TALK TO
FISH THANK YOU.
OKAY WE HAVE A TWEENER HERE.
GONZALEZ WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY DOES NOT HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION ON THE BILL AT
THIS TIME BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR RECOGNIZING OUR
CONCERN AROUND.
INVASIVE SPECIES ON FRAGILE
ISLANDS -- IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF
A SPECIFIC UNIQUE SITUATION FOR
PLACES LIKE THE CHANNEL ISLANDS
OR IN OUR CASE SANTA CRUZ-ISLANDS WHICH IS ACTUALLY OWNED
AND OPERATED BY THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY -- WAS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE AUTHOR
HAS ACCEPTED AS AN ANSWER JUST
THANKING HIM AND WE'RE NOT CHAU.
THANK YOU.
HOPEFULLY THAT'LL BRING YOU ON
THE SUPPORT.
OKAY OKAY YOU HAVE ACCEPTED
MEMBERS IS THAT RIGHT MISTER
OTHER YES.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
OKAY I THANK YOU ALL RIGHT NOW
LET'S HEAR FROM FOLKS WHO WANT
TO REGISTER UP POSITION TO THE
BILL.
MAYBE WE CAN YEAH WE WE GIVE A
MISSED ONE OF THE SEATS IN WHICH
YEAH.
GO TO THE CITY OKAY YOU COULD
SAVE IT WILL HAVE.
TO WHAT A GREAT YEAH YEAH.
STATE.
THIS WILL BE LIKE A OKAY I SEE
HERE [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
YOU CAN GO FIRST ON YEAH OKAY --
ACTUALLY THANK YOU MISTER.
MR MEMBERS I AM DOMINIC MARIN
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE PEST
CONTROL OPERATORS OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE'RE HERE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL -- AND THERE ARE AT
LEAST THREE PUBLIC POLICY
INTERESTS AT WORK HERE WITH THIS
BILL.
FIRST IS THE PUBLIC POLICY
INTERESTS OF KEEPING RAT POISON
AND OTHER POISONS OF THE
WILDLIFE POPULATION.
WHICH IS AN INTEREST THAT THE P.
C. O. C. SHARES AND HAS
CONSISTENTLY STATED.
TO THE AUTHOR MISTER BLOOM IN
THE MULTIPLE YEARS THAT WE'VE
HAD A DIALOGUE ON THIS ISSUE
GOING ON WITH HIM.
THE SECOND POLICY ISSUE IS THE
CONTROL OF COMMENSAL RODENTS
STATED CALIFORNIA WHICH WE WOULD
ARGUES A PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES
WELL.
WITH A VERY SERIOUS CONSEQUENCE
SHOULD THAT NOT BE TREATED IN
THE RIGHT MANNER IN THAT WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN IN LOS ANGELES RAT
OPERATIONS YOU EXPLODE.
WHICH ISN'T GONNA GET BETTER
WITH OF GLOBAL WARMING AND
ELSE'S LEADS TO COOK
COMMENSURATE DISEASES SUCH AS
TYPHUS AND AND PLAGUE AND THINGS
OF THAT NATURE.
THE THIRD PUBLIC INTEREST IS THE
INTEREST OF THE REGULATORY
APPARATUS THAT EXISTS ALREADY TO
ADDRESS THESE MATTERS AND THE
PAST CONTROL OFFERS A CALIFORNIA
HAVE BEEN REGULATED SINCE LATE
THIRTIES THEY HAVE INVITED
REGULATION IN THE PAST ARE NOT
AFRAID OF REGULATION.
AND THEY'VE NOT RUN FROM THIS
ISSUE AND DENIED ITS EXISTENCE
IN ACT WE HAVE HAD AN ONGOING
DIALOGUE WITH MR BLOOM.
OVER MANY YEARS OVER THIS ISSUE
AND HAVE TRIED TO FIND SOME.
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION -- TO
THIS AND WE STILL THINK WE CAN.
I WILL SAY THAT -- WHAT YOU
HEARD FROM THE PROPONENTS OF THE
BILL IS YOU KNOW?
SOME OF IT IS QUITE VERY TRUE IN
MAINE YES IF YOU ARE FINDING RAT
POISON IN -- PLACES THAT IT
SHOULDN'T BE BUT YOU WOULD ALSO
KEEP IN MIND THAT THERE IS ALSO
A TALE ASSOCIATED WITH THE
PRIVATE USE AND NON COMMERCIAL
BUT THE RESIDENTIAL USE OF RAT
POISON.
THESE MATERIALS ARE ALSO
AVAILABLE OVER THE INTERNET FOR
SALE HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
EASILY OBTAINED.
SO THERE'S AN ILLEGAL -- CHANNEL
OF MARKETING AND COMMERCE INTO
THE STATE THAT DEFIES THE LINE
THAT I THINK CONTRIBUTES A LOT
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT SPOTTED
DOWN PARTICULAR WE LOOK TO THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
WHICH IS THE TAURUS -- FOR THEIR
USE OF MATERIALS THAT MIGHT NOT
BE ON LABEL AND SO.
WE FEEL THAT THERE IS AN
APPROPRIATE PLACE.
THESE MATERIALS AND A CONTROL
STRATEGY THAT DOESN'T JUST LEAN
ON ONLY RAT POISON LEANS ON
SANITATION MEANS ON EXCLUSION
AND LEANS ON FERTILITY CONTROL
AS MENTIONED BY THE WOMAN TO MY
DOCTOR.
MY LEFT ARM AND I WOULD EVEN SAY
THAT I TOOK A QUICK LOOK AT HER
THE WEBSITE FOR HER COMPANY.
AND THEY HAVE A AID SORT OF
HIERARCHY OF OF CONTROL
STRATEGIES AS PART OF AN
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT
STRATEGY THAT ALSO INCLUDES.
RAT POISON RECRUITS CHEMICAL SO
THEY DON'T LEAN SOLELY ON
FERTILITY CONTROL IT IS PART OF
A SUITE OF DIFFERENT TOOLS
NECESSARY TO CONTROL RATS.
AND WHAT MY CLIENTS ARE SAYING
IS.
SECOND GENERATION REGINA SIDES
FOR AS LONG AS THEY ARE ROUTE
INTO AND UNTIL WE HAVE A BETTER
ALTERNATIVE.
IS AN IMPORTANT PART OF THAT
SUITE OF TOOLS THAT WE WOULD NOT
LIKE TO LOSE BECAUSE IS A
SOPHISTICATED THING TO CONTROL
RATS ESPECIALLY ON THE CAMPUSES
LARGE AS YOU'D FIND IN SOME OF
THE BIOTECH.
OR ANY LARGE AREA IT DOESN'T
INVOLVE A WE'RE JUST GONNA STICK
BAIT BOXES OUT ALONG THE
BUILDING IT INVOLVES IDENTIFYING.
THE PRESENCE THE POPULATION THE
LOCATION OF THE BOROUGHS EITHER
LURING THOSE RATS AWAY FROM THE
BURROUGHS AND AWAY FROM THE
BUILDINGS THAT COULD BE AFFECTED
OR IF THEY'RE NEAR THE BUILDINGS
ARE IN THE BUILDINGS.
LORING ABOUT IN GETTING THEM OUT
INTO THE OPEN SPACE WHERE THEY
CAN BE MORE.
APPROPRIATELY ADDRESSED IT'S NOT
A HAPHAZARD I'M GONNA THROW A
BIG BOX DOWN AND OR AT LEAST IT
SHOULDN'T BE INTENSELY IT'S NOT
WITH.
HOPE THAT POISON TAKES EFFECT
AND YOU KNOW THE RATS STOCK SO
THERE'S A LOT OF THOUGHT THAT
GOES INTO IRAQ IN COMMENSAL
RODENT CONTROL THERE'S A LOT OF
A AYE AYES SOPHISTICATION
BELIEVE IT OR NOT.
IT'S REQUIRED BECAUSE YES
RESISTANCE IS AN ISSUE BUT
YOU'RE ALSO DEALING WITH A
HIGHLY INTELLIGENT ANIMAL THAT
IF YOU SEIZE.
IT'S A BROTHER SISTER WALK INTO
A BOX AND NOT COME OUT BECAUSE
IS DEAD WELL ANGLE ON THE BOX OR
IF IT'S BROTHER SISTER WALKS
INTO THAT BOX AND GOES BACK TO
THE BERLIN DIES.
THEY'RE GONNA LIKE SENSITIZED --
TO WE SHOULDN'T GO INTO THOSE
BOXES SO YOU REALLY HAVE TO BE.
SMARTER THAN A RAT WHICH IS
PROBABLY WHY I'M NOT A OF PEST
CONTROL OPERATOR -- SO I MEAN
IT'S JUST YOU JUST IT'S IT'S NOT
IS SIMPLE AS LET'S GET RID OF
THIS MATERIAL AND WILL FIND
REPLACEMENTS FOR THE RATS.
THERE WILL BE SOME DAY SOMETHING
THAT WE MOVE BEYOND THEN THE S.
CARS BUT WHAT WE'RE ASKING IS
FOR THE TIME BEING LET US HAVE
AN EMERGENCY USE PROVISION.
NOT THE ONE IN THIS BILL BECAUSE
THAT DOESN'T HE OF THE RIVER
WE'VE GOT RELYING OFFER FOR A
DOESN'T WORK BECAUSE AS FOR OFF
LABEL USE FOR INVASIVE SPECIES.
AND MY FOR FOLKS HAVE TRIED IT
AND THEY'VE NOT BEEN SUCCESSFUL
AND IT'S JUST TOO CUMBERSOME.
AND WE HAVE WORKED WITH THE
AUTHOR WE HAVE PUT SOME
PROPOSALS OUT THERE WE'VE EVEN
PROPOSED TO CREATE A A FUNDING
STREAM OUT OF THE INDUSTRY. FOR
ENFORCEMENT -- AND APPARENTLY
WE'VE HAD SOME CROSSED SIGNALS
ALONG THE WAY WHERE THERE WAS
SOME MISPERCEPTION OF WHAT WE'RE
INTENDING TO DO.
AND SO I WOULD JUST SAY THAT ON
BEHALF OF THE PEST CONTROL
OPERATORS WE LIKE TO KEEP THE
DIALOGUE GOING WITH THE AUTHOR.
WE'D ALSO LIKE TO MAINTAIN THIS
MATERIAL FOR USE IN VERY LIMITED
AND CONTROLLED CIRCUMSTANCES.
AS TO BE DETERMINED BY THIS
COMMITTEE THE NEXT COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE AFTER THAT OR DPR WITH
THEIR PARTICIPATION AS WELL SO I
WOULD AND MY TESTIMONY THERE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON ALL OF IRAQ RIGHT WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION -- WE HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF REPRESENTING THE
ENTIRE CROSS SECTION OF THE
BIOTECH MEDIC MEDITECH AND LIFE
SCIENCES INDUSTRY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
I TO INDUSTRY THAT EMPLOYS
ROUGHLY THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS IS INCREDIBLY
DIVERSE NOT ONLY IN THE TYPES OF
MEDICINES THAT WE MANUFACTURE.
AND RESEARCH BUT ALSO IN THE
GEOGRAPHIC LOCATIONS OF OUR
FACILITIES -- EVERYWHERE FROM
URBAN AREAS AND SENATOR HILLS A
STRICT -- GREATER LA OCEANSIDE
FREMONT -- AND UP AND DOWN THE
STATE.
WE HAVE CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL
FOR ONE PRIMARY REASON AND THAT
REASON IS.
FEDERAL DRUG DRUG ADMINISTRATION
REQUIRES VERY STRINGENT.
OF OUR FACILITIES -- PART OF
THEIR INSPECTIONS REQUIRES A
PEST CONTROL MANAGEMENT PLAN --
AN IBM PC IS DOMINIC REFERRED --
TO WE HAVE LIMITED TOOLS AT OUR
DISPOSAL TO CONTROL RODENT
POPULATIONS WITHIN FACILITIES
THAT ARE REQUIRED TO BE
INCREDIBLY STERILE -- SOMETIMES
THAT HAVE AIR PURIFICATION
STANDARDS IN THE PARTS PER
MILLION -- AND SO REMOVAL OF THE
USE OF SECOND GENERATION
ANTICOAGULANTS IN.
LIMITED USE TODAY ADMITTEDLY --
WOULD TAKE AWAY ROUGHLY FIVE OF
THE TEN TOOLS IN OUR TOOLBOX TO
COMBAT THESE ROADS.
AND SO WE HAVE ENGAGED WITH THE
SPONSORS FAIRLY EARLY -- IN THE
AUTHORS OFFICE AND WE'VE ASKED
FOR AN EXEMPTION TO THIS BILL
THAT WOULD COVER MEDICAL WASTE
GENERATORS AND WAR FACILITIES
THAT ARE REGISTERED WITH THE FDA --
THE OTHER CHALLENGERS SOME OF
THE INSPECTIONS THAT WE HAVE --
FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS THE THE
EUROPEAN UNION JAPAN THE
JAPANESE EQUIPMENT AT THE AT THE
OUR FACILITIES ARE INSPECTED.
SOMETIMES TWICE EVERY MONTH
SOMETIMES ONCE A MONTH SOMETIMES --
THESE INSPECTIONS ARE RANDOM --
AND IN MOST CASES PARTICULARLY
FOR THE MANUFACTURE OF VERY
DELICATE -- MEDICINES THAT ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE INJECTED IN HUMAN
BEINGS BIOLOGICS -- ONE SINGLE
EVIDENCE OF RAT INFESTATION
RODENT INFESTATION -- EITHER
DROPPINGS HAIR -- WOULD BE CAUSE
FOR THE FDA TO SHUT US DOWN.
SHUTTING DOWN OF THE SILLY LIKE
THAT IT TAILS ALL KINDS OF
DOWNSTREAM ISSUES -- DELIVERY
AND MANUFACTURE MEDICINES AND SO
WE'RE INCREDIBLY CONCERNED NOT
BECAUSE WE ARE ADVOCATING FOR
THE USE OF SGA OURS -- BUT ONLY
BECAUSE WE WOULD LIKE TO BE
EXEMPTED SO THAT IN SITUATIONS
WHERE THE USE OF THESE PRODUCTS
IS CALLED FOR AND DOM TOUCHED ON
IT AND I THINK WE'VE.
HEARD A LOT ABOUT THE FACT THAT.
CONTROLLING ROAD POPULATIONS IS
NOT EASY WE USE MULTIPLE TYPES
MULTIPLE.
WE USE A LOT OF DIFFERENT.
TOOLS.
AND AGAIN TAKING AWAY HALF OF
THOSE TOOLS BE VERY POP
PROBLEMATIC FOR OUR MEMBER
COMPANIES -- AND SO -- BARRING
AN EXEMPTION FOR THE LIFE
SCIENCES AND AS A REFRESHER THE
DIVERSITY OF OUR MEMBERSHIP
COVERS BY PHARMACEUTICAL
MANUFACTURERS MEDICAL DEVICE
MANUFACTURERS ACADEMIC AND
RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS SMALL AND
MEDIUM SIZE START UPS -- IT'S A
LUXURY IN A CURSE TO BE THAT
DIVERSE SO OUR ABILITY TO FIND
THAT EXEMPTION HAS BEEN
CHALLENGING -- WE HAVE NOT YET
REACHED A POINT WHERE WE ARE
COMFORTABLE -- WITH AN EXEMPTION
THAT SATISFIES OUR ENTIRE
MEMBERSHIP CERTAINLY WILL
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE OFFICE
OFFICE AND WE APPRECIATE NOT
ONLY.
HE AND HIS STAFF COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS -- THE SPONSORS I
THINK WE'VE ALL REALLY TRIED TO
DEFINE THE PROBLEM THAT I'M.
TRYING TO HOPEFULLY ARTICULATE
FAIRLY CLEARLY IS -- THE
DIVERSITY MAKES THAT CHALLENGING
ONLY BECAUSE OUR CODE SECTIONS
ARE VERY CLEAR -- IN CONCISE
WAYS OF CAPS LADY ALL OF THAT SO --
AGAIN ORGAN ADVANCEMENT I WOULD
REQUEST TO KNOW ABOUT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU OTHER FOLKS WHO
WANNA REGISTERED OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON COOKING OR
SOMETHING HAVE TO THE HOUSEHOLD
AND COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS
ASSOCIATION ALSO POST.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE LARA NO AND HE
JUST ON BEHALF OF WESTERN PLAN
HEALTH ASSOCIATION AND RISE IN
OPPOSITION.
FIRST AND JUST LIKE WITH
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL ALSO
OPPOSED.
DONNA CAP KHIMIK YOU CAN'T CAN'T
ASSOCIATES ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ALSO OPPOSE.
ELEONORA FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE STATE --
REPRESENTS ACT.
BECAUSE EVERY.
YEAH THAT'S WHAT THAT THIS
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOE ACURA
BEHALF OUR CLIENTS ENGINE TO
OPPOSE [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS.
TRAVIS OF ANI -- CLERK PRESS
CONTROL.
IN OPPOSITION.
PARTY ZERO ACCORD PRESS CONTROL
I RESIDENTIAL AND COMMERCIAL
PEST CONTROL TECHNICIAN I WORK
IN THE FIELD EVERY DAY DOING
THIS -- IN MY PROFESSIONAL
OPINION IF WE REMOVE THESE TOOLS
IT WOULD CAUSE A PUBLIC HEALTH
RISK -- WE NEED THESE TOOLS
EVERY DAY IN THE FIELD
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
I'M BOB YOUR B. C. E. I'M A
VECTOR BIOLOGIST AND I AGREE
WITH THEM.
WE ALREADY HAVE A TYPHUS
OUTBREAK IN LA.
OWLS AND HAWKS ARE NOT PRAYING
ON THESE BECAUSE THEY DON'T LONG
THAT'S IT.
I ALWAYS DO COME INTO THE CITY
AND ATTACK PEOPLE WE'VE SEEN IT
IN NEW JERSEY.
THIS BAN ON THIS RODENTICIDE
THAT HOUSE AN ANTIDOTE.
IS THE WRONG THING.
WE WOULD BE LEFT WITH THINGS
WITH NO ANTIDOTE.
AND THAT'S PLEASE.
NOW ON THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OKAY.
THE ITEM IS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS THOUGHTS -- ISSUE
SINISTER [INAUDIBLE]
DID YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OR NOT
BUT NOT A VICE CHAIR PLEASE
[INAUDIBLE]
ALL RIGHT -- THANK YOU BRING IN
A BILL FORD BEEN AT THIS A LONG
TIME.
I'M.
I'M A LITTLE TROUBLED BY HEARING
BY SOME OF THE CONCERNS I'VE
HEARD BECAUSE THE BILL.
IN PRESENT FORM.
DOES SEEM TO MAKE SOME
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR THE KINDS OF
CONCERNS THAT YOU MAY HAVE I'M
HEARING THAT YOU'RE SAYING.
IF PRESENT WORKABLE.
THE FACT IS WE'RE GONNA EXTINCT.
A BUNCH OF POPULATIONS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WHO.
WHO WHO WANTS THAT VOTE TO BE ON
THEIR HANDS -- WE LOST P. FORTY
SEVEN P. TWENTY TWO WE ALMOST
LOS P. FORTY FIVE GOT HE WITH
MANGE TEMAS SURVIVING A WILDFIRE
JUST TO GET HIT WITH RAT POISON
AND DIE.
SO WE SOME STARK CHOICES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I A WITH ALL DUE RESPECT YOU
KNOW.
THIS THE THE THE CHATTER AROUND --
NOT BEING ABLE TO DO YOUR WORK
ADEQUATELY FOR THE SENSITIVE
FACILITIES.
I HAVEN'T SEEN THE DATA COME OUT
YET FROM LICENSES INDUSTRY THAT
SAYS YOU SAID HALF TAKING HALF
OF OUR TOOLS AWAY MINERS IS
YOU'RE NOT ACTUALLY USING THESE
TOOLS VERY OFTEN AT ALL.
I TALK TO ENGINE IS BASED IN MY
DISTRICT -- ONE BIG STAR IN THE
FACILITIES IN THE STATE --
THEY'RE NEUTRAL ON THE BILL
BECAUSE THEY'RE DOING THEIR JOB
WITHOUT THE USE THESE ARE DENNIS --
SO I JUST I NEED.
THE THE ROOM THE ROOM OR PART OF
IT.
IS IS DANGEROUS BECAUSE WE CAN
ALL TALK ABOUT TYPHUS AND
OUTBREAKS -- I THINK WE CAN
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT -- MAN IS
IS AS YOU POINTED OUT YOURSELF.
I WE DON'T REALLY EVEN HAVE A
REFINED APPROACH SO WE OPEN THE
DOOR WIDE OPEN AND SAY JUST
ANYBODY WHO'S REGULATED BY THE
FDA IT SEEMS.
DANGEROUS BECAUSE WHAT YOU'RE
GONNA END UP DOING IS THEM
PUTTING THESE IMPORTANT LIFE
SCIENCES FACILITIES WHICH ARE
THE BACKBONE OF OUR COMMUNITIES
AND SAYING YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE
NOT ACTUALLY PART OF THIS
COMMUNITY WE DON'T CARE IF WE GO
KILL OFF A BUNCH WILDLIFE FRIEND
ARE PLEASE BECAUSE WE'RE SPECIAL.
AND WE'RE DIFFERENT YOU KNOW
EVERYONE HAS TO JUST ACCEPT THAT --
I CAN'T SWALLOW THAT PILL - AND
WE APPRECIATE YOU ALL AS
PARTNERS AND WE KNOW THE
ECONOMIC VALUE BUT THERE'S GOT
TO BE A MORE REFINED APPROACH --
I KNOW YOU GUYS BEEN WORKING
HARD ON IT AND I THINK.
I'VE I'VE HEARD FROM THE AUTHOR.
VERY OPEN TO WHATEVER KIND OF
TAILORED SOLUTIONS.
I THINK YOU'VE COME A LONG WAY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IN -- GETTING HIS
BILL IN SHAPE -- AND I'M AFRAID
THAT IF WE KNOW MOVE THIS
LEGISLATION THIS YEAR.
AND IF WE KEEP KICKING THE CAN
DOWN THE ROAD.
THAT WE ARE GOING TO EXTINCT.
OUR CRITICAL POPULATIONS.
OF COOPER HAWKES START THERE BUT
WORK YOUR WAY DOWN.
IF WE EXPECT NOT LINES ON OUR
WATCH.
SHAME ON US SO MOVE THE BILL AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME AND
APPRECIATE.
SOME CASKEY SO.
MAYBE I'LL SWALLOW THAT PILL I
CAME IN LATE BECAUSE OF THE
BUDGET SO I'M NOT IT'S NOT CLEAR
MY MIND WHERE THE AUTHOR IS ON
THIS.
BIOTECH.
OUR CONCERN IS HER NO LANGUAGE
THAT'S BEING AMENDED TODAY OR WE
DO NOT HAVE LANGUAGE TODAY WERE
IN DISCUSSIONS WITH WITH THE
INDUSTRY AND WERE WILLING TO
CONSIDER THAT -- THE THE CONCERN
THAT THEY HAVE -- WE WANT AS
NARROWLY -- CAFTED OF LANGUAGES
AS POSSIBLE AND WE'RE JUST NOT
THERE AT THIS POINT.
IS WITH THE WORD WILL THIS BE
SIMILAR TO THE EXEMPTION
LANGUAGE FOR WINERIES AND
BREWERIES THAT WE HAVE.
I COULDN'T SAY.
I MEAN I KNOW WE HAVE THOSE
EXEMPTIONS THAT EXCESS SO I I
JUST.
YOU KNOW THIS IS A BIG DEAL MY
DISTRICT SO I HAVE A LOT OF YOU
KNOW.
BY THE BY THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
SIDE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
BALANCE THAT WE ADDRESS ON IT --
ALL RIGHT SO.
YOU KNOW.
WE'RE WE'RE INTENDING -- TO TO
GET THERE BUT I THINK BIOTECH IS
A LOT DIFFERENT FROM -- FROM THE
WINERY INDUSTRY.
AND SO WE WANT TO KEEP OUR
LANGUAGE AS NARROWLY FOCUSED AS
POSSIBLE.
I SENSE SKINNER.
I JUST WANT TO SEE VERY RULING
STAND.
I UNDERSTAND YOU WANT TO KEEP
THE LANGUAGE NERO.
BUT YOU ARE WORKING WITH.
COME UP WITH SOMETHING.
WHERE WE ARE?
MAC IN THIS BILL WOULD GO NEXT
TO APPROACH.
NO THE NATURAL SOURCES -- NOW TO
RESEARCH SO YOU WOULD HAVE THE%
ABILITY TO CONTINUE THIS
DISCUSSION AND POTENTIALLY AN
AMENDMENT THERE.
YES THAT'S CORRECT.
AND THE OBGYN WERE WORKING WITH
THE OPPOSITION AS WELL -- WE
HAVEN'T GIVEN UP ON REACHING.
I TRYING TO REACH AN AGREEMENT
TO THAT BUT THE FACT.
THIS IS A BALL IT'S BEEN KNOWN
AS A CENTER STERN -- I REFLECTED
UPON.
THIS IS SOMETHING HAS GONE BACK
AND FORTH FOR SEVERAL YEARS NOW
WE HAVE MEANT.
TO REACH THAT POINT -- BUT IT'S
NOT FOR LACK OF EFFORT AS AN
ENGAGED IN THAT.
LIST -- AN HONEST DIALOGUE THERE
ARE SOME FUNDAMENTAL
DISAGREEMENTS ABOUT -- FOR FOR A
WHETHER OR NOT PUBLIC.
HEALTH EXEMPTION.
IS SUFFICIENT TO COVER HER THE
OF CONCERNS OF THE INDUSTRY WAY
MAINTAIN THAT IT IS.
BUT TOM WERE HAPPY TO MAINTAIN.
OF THE DIALOGUE BATON GOING
AFTER WERE -- IF WE NEED TO
INCLUDE ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE WILL
CERTAINLY TRY AND FIND THAT
LANGUAGE.
I'M I APPRECIATE THAT.
IT'S NOT ALWAYS.
HEARING BILLS THAT SOMETIMES
HAVE A LOT OF OPPOSITION MYSELF.
AND WE'RE AND I WORK VERY HARD.
WITH.
YEAH IS THAT.
YOUR IMPACT BY BILLS BY.
AND I CAN'T ALWAYS GET.
OFF OPPOSITION.
SOMETIMES I CAN GET THEM TO
NEUTRAL BUT I WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ADD YOUR COMMITMENT.
TO CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION TO
SEE IF THERE WAS A SWEET SPOT
THAT COULD BE LANDED ON WITH THE
LIFE SCIENCES BY.
THE ANSWER IS EMPHATICALLY YES.
I HAVE. TO TELL ME I'M
[INAUDIBLE]
I IN SUPPORTING THE BILL AND I'M
EVEN WILLING TO MOVE IT.
AND I THE THE DIFFICULTY IS WE
FROM TESTIMONY BOTH BY THE
EXPERTS AT THE TABLE IN BY THE
OTHER FOLKS WHO CAME TO THE MIKE
IS THAT [INAUDIBLE]
THIS -- LIKE A NUMBER OF EITHER
PESTICIDES OR TO SAY CHEMICALS
USED TO DEAL WITH A PROBLEMATIC
AS SPECIES.
THEY'RE NOT SPECIFIC.
AND IN I LIVE IN A VERY URBAN
NEAR BERKELEY.
AND THEIR OVER THE COURSE OF THE
LAST IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD ALONE IN
THE LAST EIGHT YEARS.
COUPLE BLOCKS FOR ME THERE WAS --
OVER A COUPLE YEARS IN THE SAME
THREE I COOPER SOCK YES NOW IT
DIDN'T NECESSARILY MEAN IT WAS
THE SAME COOPER STOCK.
BUT THERE WAS -- AGAIN OVER A
COUPLE OF YEARS IN THIS SAME
TREE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD COOPER
STOCK NOW.
AND THEN ABOUT -- FIVE YEARS AGO.
THE ALL OF THE FLEDGLING
FLEDGLINGS OF THAT COOPER SOCK
AND THE MOTHER.
WERE FOUND DEAD WITHIN A BLOCK
OF THE NEST.
AND THEY WERE ALL FOUND.
DEAD.
YOU'RE EITHER A WADING POOL.
SOME SOURCE OF WATER BECAUSE OF
COURSE WHAT HAPPENS WHEN.
THE BIRDS WILL EAT THIS -- ROAD
SIDE IS THAT THE THE SO THIRSTY
AND DATE BUT THEY CAN'T OF
COURSE SATISFY THE THIRST IN THE
SO THE FOLLOWING YEAR.
THERE WAS ANOTHER COOPER SOCK
NEST AND ONCE AGAIN.
THE ENTIRE -- AGAIN I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THE MAIL BUT THE THE
MOTHER OF AN OFF PLEDGE LINKS.
IT WAS ALL THE RAGE.
AT THAT POINT THE CITY OF
BERKELEY BEGAN TO PUT OUT A AYE
NEWS BULLETIN TO THE NEIGHBORS
BASICALLY.
INDICATING THAT YOU KNOW YOU
MIGHT WANT TO THINK TWICE.
BEFORE YOU USE THESE FOR NET.
BECAUSE OF THIS IMPACT
-- THEN WE STARTED SEEING IT
IMPACTING -- BELIEVE IT OR
NOT THEY'RE GREAT HORNED OWLS
NESTS IN BERKELEY AND PARNELL
NOW AND IT BEGAN TO IMPACT
OTHER SPECIES OF BIRDS SO
WHILE THE CITY OF BERKELEY AND
DID NOT TAKE ANY ACTION TO --
MANDATE THEY BEGAN TO ALERT
NEIGHBORHOODS AND -- ALERT IN
THERE IN THE BULLETIN THEY SEND
OUT TO ALL OF US IS RESIDENTS
LETTING PEOPLE KNOW THAT THIS
WAS HAPPENING AND OF COURSE
SOME PEOPLE STOP USING IT OF
MY MATCH AND SOME OTHERS NOT
NOW MY OWN HOUSE -- LAST YEAR
HAD WRESTLING AT NO LIKE MOST
LEGISLATORS ON HERE MOST THE
MOST THE DAYS THE WEEK I'M
HERE AND MOST NOT ALWAYS BUT
MOST -- PAST OPERATORS THEY
DON'T COME ON THE WEEKEND SO
IT'S MY HUSBAND THAT HAD TO
CALL TO DEAL WITH THE RATS AND
I DIDN'T REALLY HAVE ANY TIME
TO INTERACT WITH THEM AND SAY
MAKE SURE THEY DON'T USE THOSE
ANYWAY HE THIS CALL THE -- TEST
OPERATOR PASSED OPERATOR GAME
BUT IN FACT DIDN'T EVEN ASK MY
HUSBAND WHETHER HE WANTED THE
RODENTICIDE USE ARE NOT USED
BUT BUT IN TRAPS SEALED THE
PLACE FOR THE RATS WERE COMING
IN BUT IRONICALLY WHILE WE ALL
IN OUR RAP THE RAP FROM WITH
ELIMINATED WELL MY HUSBAND
ALL THE BEST OPERATOR TO DEAL
WITH AND THE OPERATOR DID
NOT USE THE RODENTICIDE EVEN
THOUGH MY HUSBAND DIDN'T DIRECT
STOP THERE SO YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE A LOT A LOT OF YEAH ALL
AROUND YOUR PROPERTY AND IN
YES WHICH WE DO WE LIVE IN
A THREE MY HUSBAND DIDN'T
TEXT ME OR ANYTHING IN THE BY
ASKING WE WANT YOU TO SPRAY
FOR THE SERVICE RATE OR YEAH
BUT HE DIDN'T USE ANY TYPE OF
POISON OR THEIR OUT OF TOWN
VERY FASCINATING ANYWAY --
I JUST INSTEAD IS THAT
LIKE SO MANY THINGS THE
RODENTICIDE NOT JUST KILL THE
ROAD SO I SUPPORT THE BILL
BUT I ALSO REALLY APPRECIATE
MET MEANT TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH -- LIFE SCIENCE
INDUSTRY TRY TO SWEET SPOT
AND I'M WITH IT WITH THE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
-- I MEAN I I AGREE I MEAN I
THINK WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
WE CAN'T LET THIS CONTINUE --
AND IN LIVE WITH THE EFFECTS
OF THAT BUT BUT I AM IN AND
CERTAINLY I'M GOING TO JOIN
THE CHORUS OF THE INDUSTRY AND
AND THE DISTRICT I REPRESENT
CERTAINLY IS THE BIRTHPLACE
OF THE FILE LIKE SCIENCES
INDUSTRIES I I GUESS WHAT I'M
YOU'RE USUALLY ONE OF THE TIME
A BILL GETS TO THE SECOND HOUSE
SENATE'S WORKING THROUGH WE
GET REALLY CLOSE TO SOMETHING
IN AND THAT'S WHAT I'M HOPING
THAT WE'RE WE'RE HEARING
HERE AND THAT WE WILL SEE
A SOLUTION TO THAT IN AND
DAY THE ABILITY TO TO RESOLVE
THE ISSUE AND -- I I THINK
FROM WHAT I'VE HEARD THERE
IS THAT COMMITMENT BUT AT THE
I THINK WE HAVE TO GET THERE
AND BACK I I'VE I GUESS WHAT
I'M LOOKING FOR IS A STRONG
NGOR COMMITMENT THAT THERE
WILL BE A SOLUTION THE HONDA
AN EMPHATIC YES AND IN FACT
THIS IS GETTING THERE THAT'S
GOOD WHICH I APPRECIATED I
MEAN THAT'S REALLY THE CONCERN
I THINK WE HAVE WE DON'T
WANT TO YEAH YOU KNOW SOLVE
ONE PROBLEM CREATE ANOTHER
ESPECIALLY IN AN INDUSTRY
THAT'S SO CRITICAL TO TO OUR
OUR LIFE BASICALLY AND THE AND
OUR NEXT GENERATION SO -- OF TO
BE SUPPORTING THAT IN LOOKING
FORWARD TO THAT SOLUTION AND
THE NEXT COMMITTEE THANK YOU
MEMBERS I SO SHARED YOU KNOW
HELLO EXPERIENCE MAY I ACTUALLY
HAVE A HER RECITE APPLICATORS
BUT IT IN MY POCKET I I USE IT
FOR OUR PART AND M.
EDUCATED BY EVERY OTHER YEAR
I HAVE TO GO DO CONTINUING
EDUCATION I I I HAVE THE SAME
ONE THAT THE GUY THAT HAS A
CLARK STICKER ON IS I I USE
THE SAME STUFF SO I'VE BEEN ON
THAT END OF IT I ALSO WANT TO
SHARE THAT WE'VE SEEN UP TICK
IN ROAD INTO SIDES BY SINCE
WE'VE -- LEGALIZE MARIJUANA
WE HAVE A LOT OF GROWTH OF
MARIJUANA NOT ONLY IN THE ROLE
AREAS WHERE WE'VE REALLY SEEN
A LOT OF USE OF PESTICIDES
HERBICIDES ILLEGALLY DONE NOT
BY SOMEBODY WHO'S LICENSED OR
JUST THEY WANT TO KILL THESE
ROADS TO REALLY LIKE THEIR
PLANTS AND -- IT'S ALSO IN THE
IN THE URBAN AREAS YOU'D BE
SURPRISED OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
YOU KNOW GROWING SIX PLANTS
IN THE BACKYARD AND HAVING
PROBLEMS WITH PASSED COMING IN
AND SO THAT THAT'S IMPACTING
THE WILDLIFE AS WELL SO WE
WE REALLY HAVE SOME TOUGH
CHALLENGES HERE AND THERE'S
NOBODY I BELIEVE THAT WANTS
TO SEE THE YOU KNOW THE THE
MOUNTAIN LION EXTINCT BUT I
I WANT ALSO SHARE WITH YOU SO
THEN IT'S BEEN VERY FRUSTRATING
ME IS THAT WE BURN OF A MILLION
AND A HALF ACRES LAST YEAR
SIX HUNDRED FORTY ACRES A
SQUARE MILE SO DO THE MATH WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF SQUARE MILES
OF LAND DESTROY AND THERE'S A
LOT OF WILDLIFE AND THEY'RE A
LOT WHILE AT THE CAN GET AWAY
DOZEN WHICH DIRECTION TO GO
AND THESE FIRES RESPONDING AND
AND I AT THE PRESSURES FOR ME
AS WE I THINK WE WERE I MEAN
I KNOW THAT IT'S GERMANE TO
YOUR BACKYARD IN JOSHUA TREE
I'VE I'VE I'VE SAT THROUGH
THE HEARINGS ON THE SIDE BUT
IN THIS JOB I'M I GET REALLY
FRUSTRATED THE FACT THAT WE
DON'T ALWAYS FOCUS ON THE LOW
HANGING FRUIT OUT THERE THERE'S
OTHER WAYS TO TO GET THE JOB
DONE AND MAYBE SO I JUST WANT
TO SHARE THAT FRUSTRATION
BECAUSE I DID A BILL THIS
YEAR TO QUANTIFY THE AMOUNT
OF WILDLIFE AND HABITAT WE'VE
LOST DUE TO CAUGHT CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES NOT ONLY ON PRIVATE
LANDS BUT FEDERAL LANDS AS
WELL AND IT GOT HUNG UP IN THE
OTHER HOUSE AND DIDN'T GET OUT
THERE BECAUSE YOU KNOW THERE'S
A LOT OF MONEY TO STUDY THAT
AND I REALLY APPROPRIATIONS
AND AND IT'S FRUSTRATING TO
ME BECAUSE I WANT TO KNOW THAT
NUMBER I WANT TO KNOW WHAT
WORKS SO WE CAN FOCUS ON THERE
IS THAT WE'RE REALLY DESTROYING
WILDLIFE AND HABITAT AND AND
OUR WATER COLLEGES AND THEN
WE CAN HAVE AN ARGUMENT WE
CAN HAVE WE CAN HAVE A DEBATE
EDUCATED DEBATE SO -- ON THIS
ONE I I KNOW THAT A LOT OF THE
-- SITTER IT'S IT'S EMOTIONAL
DRIVEN IT'S YOU KNOW THERE IS
THIS BRINGS OUT THE BEST IN
PEOPLE YOU SEE THAT WHAT THEY
REALLY CARE ABOUT AND I AND
I COMMEND THAT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHO I WORKED WITH
CLOSELY ON AND HE'S BEAT ME
EVERY TIME AND AND ON MOST OF
THESE BILLS -- BUT WE REALLY
NEED TO EDUCATE THE PUBLIC
AT THE END OF THE DAY WHAT
THEY'RE USING THESE IT WE DO
NEED THESE TOOLS THESE TOOLS
IN OUR CULTURE THESE TOOLS TO
I MEAN YOU CAN HAVE BUBONIC
PLAGUE OUTBREAK IN YOUR CHANGER
YOU'LL CHANGE YOUR ATTITUDE
TOWARDS AND WE START SEEING
LIVES LOST HUMAN LIFE AND SO
I JUST CAUTION THAT -- WE NEED
TO REALLY NOW THIS DOWN AND I
I KNOW THE AUTHOR PERSONALLY
IS IS COMMITTED YOU THAT AND
-- I'M A LAYOFF I ACTUALLY
VOTED NO AGAINST IT IN IN
NAM THE ASSEMBLY I'M A LAYOFF
TODAY JUST TO SEE HOW YOU
DOING THAT I KNOW IT'S GONNA
GET OUT I JUST WANT TO SHARE
THOSE THOUGHTS BECAUSE THERE'S
A LOT OF FRUSTRATION WITH I
I CARE ABOUT THE MOMENT YOUR
OTHER WHILE AT AND YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING TO IT
YOU CAN'T MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND
I WILL SAY I MEAN THE CASE
OF THE DIVINE PLAGUE OUTBREAK
THERE IS A PUBLIC HEALTH OPTION
HERE THAT COULD BE RESERVE
PUBLIC HEALTH EXCEPT CORRECT --
AND THERE'S ALSO AN AG THE --
EXEMPTION -- THAT'S -- THAT'S
BUILT INTO THE LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL AND -- BUT IF I MIGHT
MISTER CHAIR JUST VERY BRIEFLY
-- AYE AYE -- IDENTIFY VERY
STRONGLY WITH THE SENATOR'S
POINT BECAUSE SAID MY DISTRICT
HAS BEEN AFFECTED BY FIRE AS
WELL -- MOST RECENTLY WITH
THE WORLD'S A FIRE IN THE
AREA OF BURNS FREQUENTLY BUT
WERE AFFECTED BY BOTH PROBLEMS
BECAUSE WE HAVE SUCH A STRONG
URBAN INTERFACE TO A -- A
WILDLIFE AREA THAT IS VERY
DRAINED -- I THINK WE ALL READ
STORIES ABOUT TO THE -- --
WILDLIFE AND -- OUTLINES AND
-- AND IN MY DISTRICT THAT ARE
AFFECTED BY THIS SO THERE'S
A VERY -- I THINK STRONG
INCLINATION BY ME AND OTHERS TO
EXPLORE BOTH OF THOSE PROBLEMS
BUT I THINK THEY ARE DISTINCT
PROBLEMS BUT YOU'RE CERTAINLY
RIGHT TO UNDERSTANDING
THE EXTENT TO WHICH FIRE
IS AFFECTING WILDLIFE IN
THE STATE IS SOMETHING
THAT WE SHOULD MUCH BETTER
THANK YOU COULD EVER KNEW WE'D
BE ON THESE COMMITTEES WHERE
WE HAVE OUR MIND STRETCH IN
OUR HEART EIGHTEEN A I NEITHER
EITHER SIDE BECAUSE -- WHEN
I THINK MANY OF US SAW THAT
JOB HE TWENTY TWO RIGHT PAGE
ARTICLE ON WAS KILLED AND ALL
OF THAT REALLY TAKES A TOLL
ON I THINK OUR WHAT WE BELIEVE
TO BE OUR MORAL RESPONSIBILITY
BUT I THINK IN THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE WE HAVE ONE ON BOTH SIDES
SO I'D LIKE GASTON MISTER ASKED
ON IT THE DOLLAR YOU SUGGESTED
THAT THERE NEEDED TO BE A FEW
MORE -- EXEMPTIONS AND I'D
LIKE YOU TO ELABORATE BECAUSE
WHAT I'M GONNA DO A LAYOFF I
PROBABLY LINO ON IT BECAUSE
THEY THINK IT'S CRITICAL ARE
THAT A BETTER BALANCE CAN BE
ACHIEVED -- AND THAT WILL BE
A DIFFICULT NO VOTE FOR ME IF
I WERE TO TAKE THAT BECAUSE OF
MY DE TURN IN AND CARE ABOUT
ANIMALS NOT JUST THE WILDLIFE
AND THE EXTINCTION BUT OUR
LOCAL ANIMALS AND I'VE HAD A
FEW OF MY CAT TOYS AND NEVER
KNEW WHAT IT WAS BUT IT'S A
PRETTY GRUESOME THING TO WATCH
THEM GO THROUGH IT SO YOU HAVE
THOSE ON OUT THERE IN THE WILD
LANDS THAT ARE GOING TO THIS
AND THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET TO THAT
AREA WHICH YOU KNOW WE DID WE
LOST OUR OUT POISONING SO ON
SHARE WITH ME YOUR THOUGHTS ON
A LITTLE BROADER -- EXCEPTIONS
THAT NEED TO BE THEY WERE
TAKEN OR INVISION -- BECAUSE
MISTER BLOOM ESTÁ AND I THINK
AN INCREDIBLE JOB SO FAR --
CHEERING I THINK THE OCEAN
PASSION THAT WE HAVE ON THE
ONE SIDE AND TRYING TO BALANCE
OUT WITH I THINK THE PREGNANT
RIGHT NOW THE SIDE THAT IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO PUBLIC
HEALTH YEAH I MEAN OTHERS SERVE
BECAUSE THANK YOU SENATOR I
MEAN IT DO YOU KNOW YOU'VE
GOT A CHRIS CHARISMATIC MEGA
SPECIES HERE ABOUT MILES WHICH
EVERYONE REALLY APPRECIATES
AND ENJOYS PERFECTLY THEY
SCARE ME TO DEATH -- ABOUT
MOUNTAIN BIKER FOR -- BAKER AND
THEY'RE JUST SPEAKING CATS IN
THERE I LOVE HIM THE BEAUTIFUL
BUT THERE WHEN ONE OF YOU
ALONG WITH ONE
SO YOU'RE THE EXCEPTION THING
IN A WERE ALL SCRAMBLING FOR
EXCEPTIONS RADIO EXAM THE
EXAM EXAM THAT IS IT SEEMS
LIKE IT IN OUR FULL TOOL IN
THIS INSTANCE AND I THINK MY
CLIENTS LOOK AT IT FROM THE
POINT OF VIEW OF WELL HOW
DO WE LIMIT THE USE IT'S NOT
THE EXCEPTION YOU KNOW LET'S
EXEMPT THIS FACILITY HERE THIS
ENVIRONMENT -- THAT ENVIRONMENT
IT'S MORE ALONG THE LINES OF
HOW DO WE LIMIT THE USE IN
THE LIMIT THE BIO AVAILABILITY
OF THE AVAILABILITY OF THESE
MATERIALS TO WILDLIFE FOR THE
ANIMALS THAT WILDLIFE AND THAT
IS THROUGH A A IT'S A PROCESS
RIGHT IN IT IN THE EARLIER I
DID MY BEST TO DESCRIBE SORT
OF HOW THE PROCESS OF EXCLUSION
EXTERMINATION WORKS IN AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE YOU'RE TRYING
TO KEEP THE COLOSSAL RODENTS
AWAY FROM THE BUILDING BY YOU
KNOW LURING AWAY FOR BUILDING
BEATING OUT PASSED THE BOROUGH
YOU KNOW SORT OF CREATING
FORAGE FOR THEM THAT IS AWAY
FROM THE AREA THAT YOU WANT TO
PROTECT FROM THAT TO RODENTS
AND SO IN THAT INVOLVES NOT
JUST THE THE THE BAIT THAT'S
A ESTAR BUT IT ALSO INVOLVES
OTHER MATERIALS INVOLVES
TRAPPING DETECTIVE PRESENCE NO
NOT EVERY BIG BOX YOU LOOK AT
HAS POISON IN IT AND SO IT'S
IT'S IT'S A IT'S THE SYSTEM OF
EXCLUSION AND AND CONTROL YOU
KNOW IT ALSO INCLUDES YOU KNOW
-- REPRODUCTIVE DESTRUCTION AND
SO I THINK WE'LL I DON'T LOOK
AT IT AS WHAT THE EXCEPTION
SHOULD BE I LOOK AT IT FROM
WHAT'S THE PROCESS THAT SHOULD
BE IN PLACE IN ORDER TO LIMIT
THE USE TO ONLY THOSE INSTANCES
OR TO THOSE INSTANCES WHERE
THEY ARE NECESSARY TO KNOCK
DOWN A GROWING POPULATION OR
POPULATION IT IS GOT OUT OF
CONTROL I WOULD ARGUE THAT
THE POPULATION IN DOWNTOWN
LOS ANGELES AT SOME POINTS
HAVE GOTTEN OUT OF CONTROL
AND I WILL BET YOU A DOLLAR
TO A DONNA THAT THE ONE OF THE
METHODS ARE USED TO CONTROL
THOSE MUSCLE RODENTS WAS
PROBABLY A NASCAR OR SOME RAP
WAYS THEY'RE DESIGNED TO KILL
THE WORD WE'RE NOT RUNNING
AWAY FROM THAT THAT'S THAT'S
THEIR MAIN PURPOSE -- AND
SOMETIMES YOU NEED TO KNOCK
USES MATERIALS TO KNOCK DOWN
POPULATION SO THAT YOU CAN
THEN DEPLOY THE OTHER LESLIE
FOR LESS TOXIC NON CHEMICAL
-- METHODS FOR EXCLUSION AND
CONTROL AND SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE SAYING IS GIVE US THE
TOOL LET US USE IT IN A VERY
LIMITED SENSE LET'S LET'S AGREE
ON WHAT THAT LIMITED SENSE IS
AND THEN WE CAN MOVE FORWARD
AND AND HOPEFULLY YOU KNOW AND
WE FEEL FOR A FAIRLY CONFIDENT
GIVEN THAT AND ALSO LET'S NOT
OVERLOOK THE ILLEGAL USE OF
ASPECT OF THIS EITHER I DON'T
THINK WE CAN DO THAT YOU KNOW
AND ALLOWS US ONE MORE THING
AND I'LL SHUT UP SQUARE WHICH
IS -- WE HAVE AN AGENCY THAT
IS TOTALLY DEDICATED TO THIS
WHICH IS THE DEPARTMENT ASIDE
REGULATION THIS MATERIAL THIS
CAR IS UNDER REEVALUATION
PRESENTLY AT DPR IN THE THAT
OUT AND AND OUTCOME OF THAT
WILL BE NEW RESTRICTIONS ON
THE USE OF THESE MATERIALS
AND NEW PRACTICES AND LICENSE
CONDITIONS THAT WILL IN LARGE
PART RESTRICT THE USE OF THESE
MATERIALS IN LOTS OF DIFFERENT
ENVIRONMENTS SO THE THAT'S THE
BEST ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION
I APOLOGIZE AND SO CAN I
SAY SOMETHING NICE TO THIRTY
SECONDS TO FALL FROM THIS POINT
ON THE TOP OF SURPLUS FROM
BOTH YOU BRIEFLY JUST FOLLOW
UP WITH DOMINIC SAID WHEN WE
EXAMINE THIS BILL -- YOU KNOW
IS REALLY A QUESTION OF DOING
GATES RETURNING GAUGE THE THE
TARGET OF NON TARGET WILDLIFE
YES OF THESE ABOUT MIND IS
TRAGIC WE HAVE MEMBER COMPANIES
IN THE ANIMAL MEDICINE AND
A LOT OF OUR FACILITIES ARE
CHOSEN TO VOLUNTARILY LIMIT
THEIR USE OF SECOND GENERATION
AT THAT POINT AND IF THEY
CAN USE ALTERNATIVE METHODS
THE CHALLENGE WE'VE HAD IS
-- WHILE WE HAVE MEMBERS IN
SENATOR STERN DISTRICT MEMBERS
AND CENTER SCANNERS DISTRICT
HAVE YOU BELIEVE NOT USE THESE
WE ALSO HAVE SOME -- INCLUDING
ONE OF THE WORLD'S TOP FIVE
MANUFACTURERS OF MEDICINE ABOUT
THIRTY FIVE MINUTES SOUTH OF
HERE IT IS ADJACENT TO ONE OF
THE LARGEST COMMERCIAL BURST
IN THE WORLD THE BREWERY CAN
USE THEM AND RIGHT ACROSS
THE STREET OUR FACILITY COULD
NOT TO WORK WE'RE GRAPPLING
A LITTLE BIT WITH THE
RATIONALIZATION FOR CERTAIN
EXEMPTIONS WHILE LIMITING --
EXEMPTIONS FOR OUR GUYS A RULE
FOLLOWER RIGHT I MEAN THAT
THESE THESE ARE PRODUCTS THAT
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
VERY LIMITED USE VERY LIMITED
APPLICATION STRICT REGULATION
ABOUT FIFTY FEET FROM THE
BUILDING I MEAN THIS OUR GUYS
FOLLOW THE RULES INCREDIBLY
SORRY ABOUT THE ACCIDENTAL
INGESTION OF THESE THINGS
BY WILDLIFE PROBABLY NOT AND
SORRY BEEN ON THE POINT THAT
OUT THIS BILL DOESN'T GO AFTER
THE ILLEGAL SALE IT DOESN'T GO
AFTER THE LEGAL USE IT DOESN'T
GO OUT LEGAL OVER USE AND
PERHAPS MOST IMPORTANTLY --
I'M NOT A BIOLOGIST BUT WE'RE
EXEMPTING CERTAIN INDUSTRIES
THAT ARE PROBABLY FOR MORE
IMMEDIATELY ADJACENT TO WEAR
THESE WILDLIFE POPULATIONS
THAT'S KIND OF THE RUBBER OUR
GUYS IS THEY KEEP COMING US
AND SAYING WE GET IT YOU'RE
TAKING AWAY A TOOL WHEN THAT
VERY SAME TOOL IS ALLOWABLE IN
INDUSTRIES THAT HAVE LESS OF
A RISK IF THEY WERE TO HAVE AN
INFESTATION WE CAN'T CLAIM THE
PUBLIC EMERGENCY IS BY THE TIME
IT GETS TO EMERGENCY WE'VE BEEN
SHUT OUT WE'VE GOT OUR BIGGER
PROFITS AND SO THAT'S KIND
OF THE THE PLEADING ARGUMENT
ON OUR END IS WE GET IT WE'RE
THE CONCEPT OF THIS BILL WE
SUPPORT ONE HUNDRED PERCENT
-- AND IN THE EVENTUALLY RIGHT
INTO ME TO CUT YOU OFF BUT I
MEAN ARE BY TECH BROTHER IN
ARE GOING TO DEVELOP HOPEFULLY
ALTERNATIVES PLEASE BETTER WAYS
OF DOING THIS HOPEFULLY WE'LL
FIGURE THIS PROBLEM OUT BUT
RIGHT NOW TO DAY IT IS ONE OF
THE TOOLS IN THE TOOL BOX THAT
WE HAVE TO RELY ON IF WE HAVE
A PROBLEM IT NEEDS TO BE DEALT
WITH QUICKLY EFFECTIVELY AND
IN A MANNER THAT WE CAN CONTROL
ALRIGHT I THINK WHAT WE'VE
HEARD TODAY IN WHAT IS
ABSOLUTELY PARAMOUNT TO
EVERYONE TO UNDERSTAND IT IS
A QUESTION OF BALANCE WE MUST
STRIKE A BALANCE I WORK VERY
HARD IN MY INDUSTRY FOR I AM
NOT A PEST MANAGER WE WORK FOR
THE PAST MANAGEMENT INDUSTRY
TO GIVE THEM OPPORTUNITIES WE
ALSO INTRODUCE A GREAT DEAL
OF SCIENTIFIC BACKGROUND IN
STUDY I BEGAN IN THE BIOTECH
INDUSTRY HOWEVER IT SCRIPTS
RESEARCH IN LAHORE YEAH WE HAD
VERY FEW RATS EVERYTHING WAS
A CLEAN ROOM AND I THINK THAT
IF WE WERE TO GATHER AND A
SPECIAL LEE WITH THE LEADERSHIP
YOUR -- WITH ASSEMBLYMAN BLOOM
WE WILL BE ABLE TO STRIKE IT
WHAT HERE'S THE PAIN THAT WE
ALL HAVE TO FACE FROM TIME TO
TIME WHAT IS THE FIRST STEP
IS THAT FIRST STEP GONNA COME
FROM CALIFORNIA I GUARANTEE YOU
IT'S NOT GONNA COME FROM OHIO
AND I DIDN'T MEAN TO OFFEND
ANYONE THEIR ARMS SAYING IT IS
LEADERSHIP IT IS A KNOWLEDGE
BEING IT IS MOVING FORWARD
AS A GROUP ALL OF US WORKING
TOGETHER AND WE'D BETTER TAKE
THAT FIRST STEP WE HAVE BEEN
ON THE JURISDICTIONS THAT
HAVE -- IMPLEMENTED SOMETHING
SIMILAR TO THIS WELL WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO TO SEE THE
RESULTS IN THE IMPACT I DON'T
THINK SO I THINK WE'RE IN
THE LEAD HERE OKAY SENATOR
FAR WE HAVE BEEN THERE VINCE
IS CITIES RIGHT AND DO WE
KNOW WHAT THE RESULTS HAVE
BEEN IN THE CITIES THAT HAVE
DONE THIS IN TERMS OF PUBLIC
HEALTH IMPACTS ON THE RIGHT
YEAH WELL YOU KNOW WE --
WE'VE WE'VE HEARD SEVERAL
TIMES THAT LA HAS -- IS IS
AN EGG EXAMPLE THAT SHOULD BE
HELD UP LA IS ACTUALLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN LOS ANGELES RIGHT
NOW IS AN EXCEPTION -- IT'S
AN EXCEPTIONAL CIRCUMSTANCE
-- AND -- MAYOR GARCETTI JUST
TODAY HAS ANNOUNCED THAT HE IS
TAKING STEPS TO DEAL WITH THAT
SITUATION WHICH MEANS CLEANING
UP TRASH AND HAVING A NEW
APPROACH TO MAKING SURE THAT --
AREAS OF DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES
OUR FREE OF TRASH AND THAT IS
IN EFFECT -- -- PROBLEM AND
GOING AFTER IT AT ITS SOURCE --
AND THAT'S WHAT WE ALL NEED TO
DO TO CONTROL PASS BUT IF I IF
I MIGHT MISTER CHAIR -- RESPOND
VERY BRIEFLY TO SENATOR BATES
WHO VERY CLEARLY ASKED FOR --
-- WHAT WITH THE EXCEPTIONS
BE WOULD EXEMPT WHAT WHAT EXIT
WITH AN EXEMPTION LOOK LIKE
AND THE RESPONSE THAT CAME
BACK WAS WHAT WOULD RATHER
TALK ABOUT SOMETHING ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT LIMITING
USE AND -- AS I WAS LISTENING
TO THAT CONVERSATION WHAT I
WAS HEARING AS WE'D LIKE TO
IDENTIFY WHAT IN OUR INDUSTRY
TO BE CONSIDERED BEST PRACTICES
I TAKE IT AS A GIVEN THAT
IN THE PAST CONTROL INDUSTRY
THEY'RE ALREADY EMPLOYING THIS
ISSUE'S BEEN GOING ON FOR YEARS
SO I BELIEVE THEY'RE ALREADY
EMPLOYING WHAT THEY BELIEVE OUR
BEST PRACTICES BUT THE PROBLEM
WE'VE IDENTIFIED HAS NOT GONE
AWAY IT HAS EITHER MAINTAINED
OR INCREASED AND ITS SEVERITY
AND SO THE BEST PRACTICE THAT
THE INDUSTRY WOULD LIKE TO
FOLLOW IS NOT WORKING FOR
THIS PROBLEM AND THAT'S WHY
WE'RE HERE TODAY NOW WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED EXCEPTIONS THAT WERE
WILLING TO WORK ON WITH VARIOUS
PARTS OF THE INDUSTRY YOU
HEARD ME SAY THAT WE WILL --
WORK HARD ON THOSE TO ACHIEVE
ACHIEVE A COMPROMISE I'M AND
YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT THAT
WE WILL DO THAT SURE IF I MAY
JUST TO BE CLEAR AND IS A VERY
BRIEF TO MR BLOOM'S POINT WE
DID OFFER AS AN EXCEPTION TO
MR BLOOM AS AN AMENDMENT AS A
CONCEPT OF IN A MOMENT AND IT
WAS REJECTED BY HIM AND THE --
PROPONENTS IN THAT EXCEPTION
WOULD HAVE BEEN A FARM TO FORK
WHAT WE CALL THE FARM TO FORK
EXCEPTION WHICH IS ALL THE WAY
FROM THE FARM TO A COMMERCIAL
OR KITCHEN AREA WHERE IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO YOU EXCLUDING
KEEPRITE TIMELY FOR HERE WAS
A THAT WAS TOO BROAD YEAH I
BELIEVE IT THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT
SO MY POINT WASN'T THAT I WANT
A BROADER THING BECAUSE I WANNA
TALK PROCESS MY POINT WAS THAT
I WE HAVE OFFERED EXCEPTIONS
THERE IS CONCERN AT EVERY
EXCEPTIONAL LONG THE WAY YOU
HEARD FROM OTHER PEOPLE ASKING
FOR AN EXCEPTION THAT THEY
COULD BE TOO BROAD AND WHAT I
AM SUGGESTING IS IS THAT THERE
MIGHT BE A WAY TO TIGHTEN IT
DOWN NOT TO THE EXCEPTION WHICH
I THINK IS AN ARTFUL BECAUSE IT
COVERS LARGE SWATHS OF LAND BUT
THROUGH THE PROCESS IN WHICH
THESE MATERIALS ARE DEPLOYED
AND THE CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER
WHICH THEY'RE DEPLOYED WHICH
IS A RESPECTIVE OF LOCATION
TYPE BUSINESS ALL RIGHT THAT
WAS THE THE SPIRIT BEHIND WHAT
I SAID IT WAS NOT TO FIND A
BROADER EXCEPTION FOR THIS
BILL TO WRITE RIGHT NOW -- IS
ANYBODY WHAT ARE THE RULES AS
TO WHO CAN ACTUALLY APPLY THE
THURMOND DECIDES BEGINNING
WITH ME LICENSE PEST CONTROL
OPERATORS ONLY YOU CAN ONLY
BE DONE BY WAS A TWENTY FOUR
TRY AS A TWENTY FOURTEEN IS
A HOMEOWNER I CAN'T BUY IT
ONLINE SURELY I SHOULD BE ABLE
TO I COULD I SHOULD BE ABLE
TO YEAH -- -- SO BUT SO THAT
WOULD SUGGEST THE KIND OF MODEL
YEARS TALKING ABOUT AND YET WE
STILL HAVE OUTLINES DYING SO IF
WHAT'S GOING WRONG HERE I MEAN
IF I GET I GET THAT ARGUMENT
IF WE WERE STILL ALLOWING YOU
TO BE OFF THE SHELF BUT AGAIN
A LITTLE BIT BEYOND MY SCOPE
FROM A MICROBIOLOGY STANDPOINT
BUT IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING
THAT SOME OF AFTER THE COLLAPSE
THE ON THAT MOUNTAIN LINE
-- SOME OF THE COMPOUNDS
ARE FOUND WERE NOT OBTAINED
LEGALLY OR ILLEGALLY IN THE
CITY CALIFORNIA SOME OF THEM
CAME FROM OTHER COUNTRIES I'M
EARLY SOUTH OF US SOME OF COME
FROM OTHER STATES WERE STILL
LEGAL TO PURCHASE THESE THINGS
THERE'S NO RESTRICTION ON
BY YET ANOTHER STATE DRIVING
ACROSS AND ILLEGALLY USING
IT OR OVER USING IN THE CITY
CALIFORNIA SO I NO RESTRICTION
ON THAT BUT THAT WOULD BE THAT
WOULD BE COVERED IN THIS BILL
NOW FOR SPENT AN ISSUE WAS
BUT I THINK HE FOR SPECIFIC
POSSESSION WOULD BE ILLEGAL
NOW UNDER THIS BILL IT'S GOING
OF COURSE WELL GOOD FOR IS
ANY IN POSSESSION WOULD BE
ILLEGAL UNLESS YOU'RE ALREADY
EXEMPTED AG WINERIES SAUDIS
BUT I MEAN THAT IS THE IN
GO BACK TO THE POINT I MADE
EARLIER AND I'M GONNA GET
DIVORCED HIS NAM SAID IT TWICE
-- RIGHT ACROSS THE STREET
FROM ONE ANOTHER YOU'VE GOT A
MAJOR MANUFACTURING FACILITY
FOR DRUGS AND THEN ACROSS THE
STREET A MAJOR BREWERY ONE
IS EXEMPTED AND THE OTHER IS
NOT -- THE THE THE MIGRATORY
PATHWAYS OF THESE ANIMALS ARE
THEY REALLY MAKING A U.
TURN AFTER EATING THE GOOD
STUFF HERE THE BAD STUFF HERE
THEY'RE PROBABLY NOT THEY'RE
INCREDIBLY CHASING ONE ANOTHER
SO IF ONE IS USING LEGALLY EVEN
AND CONTROLLED ENVIRONMENT AND
THE OTHER ONE IS PROHIBITED
FROM USING THERE IS THERE
IS SOME FUNDAMENTAL SORT OF
THERE'S SOME FRICTION THERE AND
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE AMENDMENTS
NOTED THE ANALYSIS AGAIN
PERSONAL TEN AND RESTRICTED
USE ON THE ISLAND OF CATALINA
PERFECT SENSE IS THAT'S AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO ONE VERY SPECIFIC
THING TO TO DOMINIC'S POINT
-- NUMBER BUT RIGHT NOT MINDS
LEVEL SO YEAH OKAY WHAT IT IN
THE ATTIC WAS WORTH HAVING A
FREE DISCUSSION ON THIS BECAUSE
IT THE ISSUES ARE DIFFICULT
I I WILL I WILL SAY I DO I'M
VERY MUCH RESPECT THE AUTHOR
NOT ONLY FOR HIS -- LONG TERM
COMMITMENT TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE BUT ALSO BECAUSE
OF HIS I EVEN KEELED AND FAIR
APPROACH TO -- TO TRYING TO
COME UP WITH WITH SOME SOME
REASONABLE POLICY SOLUTIONS AND
SO I'M HE'S MADE THE COMMITMENT
TO SEVERAL MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH -- SOME OF THE VOICES IN
OPPOSITION TO SEE WHAT WHETHER
WE CAN REALLY GET TO ADDRESS
ALL THE ISSUES HERE BUT FIRST
AND FOREMOST -- WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE AND I THINK YOU'VE
HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR FROM THE
COMMITTEE THAT WE'RE REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE CURRENT
STATE OF AFFAIRS OF THE GUARDS
TO -- TO THESE POISONS IN THE
IMPACT THEY'RE HAVING ON OUR
ECOSYSTEM WRIT LARGE AND SO
ON AND WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING
I'M I'M CERTAINLY HAPPY TO TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AND IT'S
GONNA GO NATURAL RESOURCES HI
AND THE BEFORE THE WORK ON THIS
AND BUT BUT I I I WILL I WILL
I DO APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
INDULGENCE IN IN IN HERE HAVING
THIS OPEN ENDED DISCUSSION
ABOUT A NUMBER OF VERY
DIFFICULT ISSUES ASSOCIATE WITH
THE SPELLING -- SO IT'S THE
MOVE BY CENTER STERN I -- WOULD
LIKE TO GIVE THE OTHER NUMBER
-- I'M SORRY SAYS MOVE BY
CENTERED SKINNER HE SAID IT THE
OKAY WELL THEY CAN DO IT SOME
MORE SIXTY FIVE FOR THAT BUT
AT LEVEL OF OUR BESSEMER TO TO
GET THEM TO TO TO CLOSE THAT
YOU'RE THE LEGISLATURE THIS IS
A GREAT FIGHT TO HEAR YEAH BUT
-- I APPRECIATE THE DIALOGUE
WILL KEEP TALKING JERRY DOESN'T
GET THEM THE MOTION TO OKAY
I'M SORRY A SON OF A BETTER
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE BEFORE THIS GETS OUT
YES OKAY THANK YOU PLEASE CALL
TWENTY FOUR AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS
DO PASS AS AMENDED SENATE
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER
COMMITTEE ALLEN HI ALLEN I
BATES HILL HILL AYE SKINNER I
STERN STERN AYE BELLY I CASKEY
OKAY THAT'S FORTY ZERO SO THAT
HASN'T EFFORTS TO GET OUT I
THANK YOU THANK YOU EVERYONE
THANK YOU FOR PRESERVATION AND
VERGE OF EVERY YEAR OKAY SO
LET'S NOW GIVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
VARIOUS ITEMS LET'S START
WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR
CONSENT CALENDAR CONSISTS OF
ITEMS NUMBER ONE ELEVEN TWELVE
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY TWO
SIX ZERO WELL LIKE OWSKI HI
I OKAY THAT'S OUT SEVEN ZERO
UNANIMOUS ALL RIGHT THAT'S
A GOOD THING RIGHT SO LET'S
NOW GO TO ITEM TWO THIS
IS A SOMERS COOPER'S BILLS
WE HAVE YOU DOWN AS AN I.
S. BUT WE DO THAT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR BRAIN
NEVER DID IT RIGHT FOR
IT THEN WE DO IT BEFORE
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
OKAY ALL RIGHT WE'RE NOW GOING
TO I DON'T TO COOPER'S BILL
-- THIS ONE WAS SIGNIFICANTLY
AMENDED DOES TO PASS TO AS
AMENDED TO SENATE TRANS I WE
GOT RID OF THE INCOME CAPS
-- SO THIS AB ONE TWENTY SIX
ITEM NUMBER TWO AND NUMBER
TWO AB ONE TWENTY SIX THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
THE SENATE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE CHAIR VOTING I VICE
CHAIR VOTING NO FOUR ZERO
SKINNER SKINNER HIGHWAY CASKEY
OKAY
FIVE TO ONE WE'RE
GOING TO CLOSER ON THAT
OKAY THAT'S THAT'S OUT
LET'S NOW GO TO CRISTINA
GARCIA IS LEAD ACID
BATTERIES SB ONE FORTY TWO
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB ONE FORTY
TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE CHAIR
VOTING I BATES HELLO NO I
SKINNER I STERN EARN AYE
DOLLY I KOWSKI CASKEY AYE
OKAY WILL CLOSER ON THAT THAT
HAS ENOUGH WAS TO GET OUT
THANK YOU FOR NEXT RUNNING A
A NUMBER FOR THIS ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB ONE FORTY THREE QUIRK
SILVA AS WELL ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB ONE FORTY THREE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CHAIRED VOTING I TWO ZERO
BATES BATES AYE HILL HILL
AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE STERN
STERN AYE CASKEY CASKEY AYE
OKAY THAT'S SEVEN ZERO LET'S
GET OUT NEXT WE HAVE PRISONERS
YES AB ONE EIGHTY SEVEN USE
MATTRESS RECOVERY RECYCLING
ACT ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS
DO PASS AS AMENDED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
AT CHAIR VOTING I AM VICE
CHAIR VOTING HI THREE ZERO HILL
HILL AYE SKINNER I STERN STERN
I WAY CASKEY THE CASKET HI
SEVEN TWO ZERO ALL RIGHT NEXT
WE HAVE AB TWO A SIX CHOOSE
BILL ON LEAD BASED PAINT ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB TWO ZERO SIX THE
MOTION IS DO PASTURE VOTING
I VICE CHAIR VOTING HI BILL
NO I STERN EARN I SEVEN TWO
ZERO THAT IS OUT OKAY THANKS
WE HAVE SOME MEMBER FRIEDMAN'S
KEPT TELLING TRANSITION PLANS
AB TWO EIGHTY FIVE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB TWO EIGHTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CHAIRED VOTING I PLACER VOTING
NO ILL ILL I SKINNER I OKAY
THAT'S FIVE TWO TWO THAT'S
OUT NEXT WE HAVE CORKS AB TWO
NINETY TWO WILLING TO RECYCLE
WATER TITLES IN TERMS ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB TWO NINETY
TWO THE MOTION IS DO PASSED IN
THE SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER COMMITTEE CHAIR
VOTING I TWO ZERO EIGHT HI
HI HILL HILL AYE SKINNER I
SKINNER TURN STERN I Y.
CASKEY CASKEY I YES SEVEN TWO
ZERO THANKS TO GO TO CERVANTES
THIS IS AB SIX THIRTY NINE ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB SIX THIRTY NINE
THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS TO
THE GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE AT CHAIR VOTING I'VE
BY SERVING I THREE ZERO HILL
HILL AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE
STERN STERN AYE WHY CASKEY
WE HAVE SIXTEEN ZERO
THEN NOW BRINGS US TO
KALRA AND THIS IS -- THE
BECAUSE MEDICS BILLION AS
AB SIX FORTY SEVEN ITEM
NUMBER TEN AS AB SIX FORTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED THE SENATE
LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT COMMITTEES M.
TRAVELING I THREE ZERO
EIGHT HELLO HILL AYE
SKINNER I STERN TURN I
OKAY THAT'S SIX HERE THAT IS
OUT MEMORIES NOW TO CHRISSY
CHRISSY IS AB SEVEN FIFTY SIX
PM IS THE WATER RELATED ONE
GIVE US ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
AB SEVEN FIFTY SIX THE MOTION
IS DO PASS AS AMENDED THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CHEN VOTING I'D THREE ZERO
HELLO I SKINNER
I STERN STERN AYE
OUT
WE NOW GO TO ITEM FOURTEEN
THIS IS AB EIGHT FIFTEEN
AGUIAR-CURRY DUAL STREAM
RECYCLING PROGRAM ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN AB EIGHT FIFTEEN THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CHAIR
VOTING AYE AYE SIR VOTING NO
TWO ONE KILL KILL AYE SKINNER
SKINNER AYE STERN STERN I
FIND ONE THAT IS OUT
I NEXT WE GO TO AB TEN
NINETY THREE BLANCA RUBIO
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT TEN NINETY THREE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CHAIRED VOTING
I VICE CHAIR VOTING I FOUR
ZERO TELL HILL AYE STERN
STERN IOWA CASKEY SKINNER
OKAY
YES AB ELEVEN TWENTY THREE ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN A.
B. ELEVEN TWENTY THREE OF
THE MOTION IS DO PASS TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CHAIR VOTING I'VE ONE ONE
EIGHT NO NO HILL I SKINNER
SKINNER AYE STERN STERN AYE
AYE CASKEY HI OKAY FIVE TWO
TWO ALL RIGHT NEXT WE HAVE THE
KALRA BILL AB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO
THIS IS THE PLASTIC BOTTLES
THE LITTLE BOTTOM RIGHT YEAH
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB
ELEVEN SIXTEEN TO MOTION IS DO
PASSED IN THE SENATE GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE CHAIR
VOTING AYE AYE SIR VOTING
NO TWO TWO HELLO I SKINNER
SKINNER AYE STERN STERN
THAT IS FORTY THAT IS OUT
NEXT WE GO TO I'M SORRY
FIVE FIVE TWO -- O'DONNELL'S
O'DONNELL SPELL ONCE
AGAIN SIGNIFICANT AMENDED
HE TOOK ALL THE MEN'S
YES AND SO THIS ONE SO
NOW THEY'RE BASICALLY
ASKING ON CARD TO CONSIDER
AB ELEVEN NINETY FIVE THIS ITEM
EIGHTEEN ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN
AB ELEVEN NINETY FIVE THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO SENATE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE CHAIR VOTING I TWO
ZERO EIGHT ALL RIGHT BATES
AYE HILL HILL AYE SKINNER
I SEE HOW ACTION WOULD TOOK
OFF OPPOSITION I'M SIERRA CLUB
CAME IN AND SAID OBVIOUSLY
THEY'RE VERY HAVE AT THE
MOMENT THEY HAVEN'T AND THEY'VE
GONE BACK TO THEIR FOLKS
FACT YOU WANT TO START BY
SHE STILL SAYS IT WASN'T SURE
HOPEFULLY NOT SCORED
YES SOME BUT BASICALLY WHAT
THURMOND STAYED WERE WERE TO
ASK THE INSTEAD OF REQUIRING
CARP TO YOU KNOW TO ASK THESE
QUESTIONS ABOUT I'LL SEE IF
PASSED IT JUST ASK THEM TO
CONSIDER SO I GET THIS YOUR
CLUB'S MAIN CONCERN I THINK
IS CONCEPTUALLY DON'T LIKE
FRAME OF THE BILL WHICH I
TOTALLY UNDERSTAND BUT IT
BUT YOU KNOW IT IT JUST PUTS
THIS INTO THE MIX THAT CAR
CAN CONSIDER THE CARD SHOULD
CONSIDER BUT THERE'S NO
PRESCRIPTIVE I'M AN ASSOCIATE
YOU KNOW IT OPEN FOR YOU
CAN THINK ABOUT COME BACK
TO IT -- CONTINUE STERN
STERN I Y. CASKEY THE CASKET
I OKAY WE'RE WILL HOLD THAT
OPEN FURS US INITIALLY TO
CONSIDER -- AB ELEVEN NINETY
SEVEN THIS IS -- SANTIAGO
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN AB ELEVEN
NINETY SEVEN THE MOTION IS
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CHAIRED VOTING I TWO ZERO
EIGHT ALL RIGHT BATES AYE
HILL TILL I SKINNER SKINNER
AYE STERN STERN I Y.
CASKEY WITH CASKET I OKAY SEVEN
ZERO THAT IS OUT LET'S NOW GO
TO FRIEDMAN A BILL A FIFTEEN
SIXTY ONCE AGAIN AND SOME
A MAN'S WORD SOME SICKENING
ANSWER TAKEN NO OPPOSITION
TO THAT BILL ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY AB FIFTEEN SIXTY THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO SENATE HOUSING COMMITTEE
CHAIR VOTING I BY STRUGGLING
I FOUR ZERO TILL TILL I
SKINNER INNER I LIKE ASKING
OKAY SIX ZERO LET'S NOT GO
TO GONZALEZ IS BILL AND THIS
IS SANDRA WELL YEAH I WAS
ONLY ONE HERE SO I WASN'T
ABLE THAT WE WILL TAKE A AT
A MOTION IT WAS A WONDERFUL
EXAMPLE OF A LEARNING IS ALWAYS
BILL WITH NO OPPOSITION HI
SO IS MADE BY CENTER SKINNER
THIS IS A LEARNING AND SALAS
ITEM TWENTY THREE AND GLORIA
BILL WAS ON CAN SAID HE TOOK
SOME AMENDS AND WE'RE ABLE TO
GET ON I CAN TALK ABOUT THAT
IF YOU LIKE BUT SKINNER MOVES
THE BELL THANK YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THE GONZALEZ BILL
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ITEM TWENTY
THREE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ALLEN
HI ALLEN I BATES BATES AYE
HILL HILL AYE SKINNER SKINNER
AYE STERN STERN HI DOLLY I
CASKEY CASKEY I OKAY WELL
WELL I YOU KNOW THAT DOLLY
HAVE ASKED YOU TO VOTE ON THAT
I THINK YOU KNOW THEY OPEN
VOTE SAID HE WAS LAYING OFF
ON SEVENTEEN THIRTY AS A
SIDELINE I'M IS ALSO JUST
OKAY
I'M SORRY
NUMBER THAT OKAY THERE INSIDE
WHEN WE'RE DONE -- WITH --
THAT'S THAT'S STANDS THAT'S OUT
OKAY SO DONALD AB ELEVEN NINETY
FIVE OKAY THE SKINNER NINE OKAY
OKAY -- SO I THINK ALL THE
MEMBERS IN CAN LEAVE I WILL
JUST WAIT TO HEAR BACK FROM
DOLLARS ONCE AND ON TO THE CAN
ALSO I THINK OTHERWISE EVERYONE
IS YEAH WE GET OKAY THANK YOU
CHAIR MERECE YOUR GOOD MAN
LONG
I'M A ROBUST THE AGENDA
ON JULY THIRD AS WELL
MUCH MY BASEMENT IS FOR FOLKS
WHO ARE HERE TO HEAR THIS
ADDITIONAL MOMENT PROVIDES IT
IF THOSE THEY WATER BOARDED
IF ICE OPPORTUNITIES AT SHELL
WHERE APPROPRIATE ISSUE A
WATER TREATMENT OR DISTRIBUTION
OPERATOR CERTIFICATE BY
RECIPROCITY EXPERIENCE OR
EDUCATION CREDITS TO PERSONS
WHO PERFORM COMPARABLE
DUTIES WHILE SERVING IN
THE UNITED STATES MILITARY
SO OKAY
WITH THAT WE DECIDE WE'RE
GONNA DURING THE HEARING --
THIRTY THIS CALL THE ONE
HUNDRED DOLLARS REQUIRED JUST
LIKE WHEN I SOME OLDER ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY THREE A.
B. SEVENTEEN THIRTY A CHARITY
I BY SERVING I SIX ZERO ALI
OKAY SIX ZERO SIX HERE THAT'S
OUT WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN THAT
THANK YOU EVERYONE THANK
YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU STAFF